so
actually
me
uh
so
just that button yeah that regular
button
[Music]
and i won't be smiling later on now i'm
smiling
okay
okay move my head around i hope this
might drive
okay
is
i'm just up here for a momento this is
this is
eight eight years of my life and
there we go so i'm talking
and
and if we can only get rid of rex
sweeping
excellent excellent yes there we go very
nice very nice that's what we're looking
for here in new hampshire
[Music]
so
yes
hopefully everything will work as
um
[Music]
my
dog
so
the house will come to order members
family
members take your seats
[Music]
so
the house will come to order members
the chair recognizes the member from
auburn representative osborne who's the
house adjourned from the session about
16 2022
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it and
the house is adjourned
the house will attend to a prayer by
house chaplain reverend bob stewart
pastor of saint paul's united methodist
good morning my friends
let me start by offering you a irish
blessing for saint patty's day
may love and laughter light your days
and warm your heart and home
may good and faithful friends be yours
wherever you may roam
may peace and plenty bless your world
with joy that long endures
may all life's passing seasons bring the
best to you and yours
a loving god
in you we can be a transformation for
others
when the discouraged cry for hope
help us to be an encourager
when the hungry cry for bread
help us lead them to finding food
when the thirsty cry for water
help us lead them to a drink
of water
when the suffering cry for help
let us be their helping hand
when the sick cry for healing
let us pray to you
for your healing touch
when the outcasts cry for love
let us be your love
o compassionate god
look down with mercy on
the ukrainian people
protect and save them from the unjust
aggressors
who seek to subdue them
grant them steadfast trust in your mercy
and protection
and we also seek prayers for the russian
people
who do not want any part of this
aggression
oh god please help everyone learn
that you are a god of peace and love
oh god i once again ask for prayers for
all my brothers and sisters
through you that are gathered here today
i pray for their health and safety
as they lead this great state of new
hampshire
be with them as they work hard to make
the best decisions based on that which
is presented before the house today
give them the wisdom and guidance
they need
and be with all the leadership of the
house of representatives
and i ask that your hand be upon each
leader
to give them the strength and courage
to lead
oh god we pray all this to glorify only
you
for you are our shalom
amen
the chair recognizes the member from
loudoun representative howard pearl who
[Music]
the chair recognizes don taylor our door
keeper from loudon who will now perform
[Music]
[Applause]
the house will attend to request release
of absence
mr speaker the day illness
representatives birch cleaver connors
ellis gorg mary griffin heath hopper
kennedy lawton lundgren milor newton
salloway suffocatus spang stevens tudor
vale
the day important business
representatives buras bradley cody
crawford cross diesel vestro frost
harvey hunt mills the day illness in the
family representatives davis and elliot
these leaves of absence shall be granted
unless otherwise ordered by the house
house will attend the introduction of
guests
mr speaker please welcome james tebow
student from winnisquam regional high
[Applause]
mr speaker please also welcome muriel
and john stickney grandparents of
representative belanger faye linda
tafalt guest of representative pearl
mary hugh carino cousin of
representative yokela
marguerite moffat and beth boardman
mother and wife of representative moffat
they're with us in the gallery today
last night i gave an a parliamentary
inquiry
that crossed a line in delivery
i knew immediately that i upset some
people
including you mr speaker
when i sat back down i saw the look on
your face and i thought oh no
i own it that my words were harsh and
they lacked prudence
it pains me to know that i disappointed
you mr speaker
and you mr clerk and the others
i apologize to those i offended and i
ask for your forgiveness thank you
[Applause]
the house will now attend a continuation
of the regular calendar beginning with
house bill 1053 from the committee on
the majority of the committee on labor
and industrial and relativity of
services to which was referred house
bill 1053
an act relative to the hourly rate paid
to an employee for hours worked but not
previously scheduled considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate senator mark warden for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and unable to agree
with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative joshua adjunct for
the minority of the committee
the motion before us is the committee
report of inexpedient to legislate are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and committed reporters
adopted
majority of the committee on labor and
industrial and relevant rehabilitative
services to which was referred
house bill 1076 an act relative to
illegal productivity quotas have been
considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with amendment
representative josh adjunct for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator glenn
turcotte for the minority of the
committee what reason does a member rise
for a motion mr speaker state your
motion
it is a proper motion the motion before
a division has been requested members
this is a division
vote
yes
a roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1076
chair recognizes representative turquott
thank you mr speaker good morning
colleagues mr speaker if i know that
considerable time will be saved by
avoiding a debate to overturn the motion
of otp then a motion of itl
would i now now press a the green button
j i recognize representing adjutant for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that in the labor
committee during the executive session
on this bill
the totality of the debate
was me thanking the chair of the labor
committee for the weeks of bipartisan
work that we did to craft a committee
amendment that came out otp to you all
the midnight ols amendments all the work
that we did to make that happen and how
if i know that the chair himself would
like to have the debate on this belt
and lastly mr speaker
if i know that if i spent this entire
last weekend calling my friends on the
republican side of the aisle
and like with every vote i told them i
will not ask you to vote unless you hear
a debate
and if i know
that they can't have they can't listen
to a debate that doesn't happen would i
now vote red
to not have this tabling motion and
support the committee of the bipartisan
otp recommendation
the motion before us is tabling motion
on house bill 1076
it's a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you
oppose you'll press the red button
so
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
169 voting 852 voting nay
the tabling motion in house bill 1076 is
adopted
just a minute
for what reason does the member rise i
have a question for the chair
state your question thank you mr speaker
i've looked at the black book
and i've looked at masons and nowhere do
i find a legitimate reason
for a deliberative body to choose not to
vote
because not to debate because it might
take time
can you tell me where
you can find
a mention of a legitimate reason
representative
smith
i don't believe that is a fair question
to me i the body has a right to make any
motion they wish which both sides do
consistently
i thank you very much and mr speaker i
think you know that the last thing i
would ever do would be to challenge you
i have full respect for you and your
position as i do for the legislature
which is a deliberative body i'm i
really i'm sorry if you saw that as
for what reason is a member rise
thank you mr speaker good morning i rise
to make a motion to print the debate on
house bill 1673 into the permanent
journal
relative to women's health privacy and
repealing the fetal health protection
act the motion is to print the remarks
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
majority of the committee on labor
industrial and rehabilitative services
to which was referred house bill 1088
act relative to employee protections
from covert 19 in the workplace
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate senator greg
minority of the committee having
considered the same be an edible degree
with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass represent o'brien sullivan for the
minority of the committee
chair recognizes
to speak against the committee report
thank you very much mr speaker
um
1088 an act relative to employee
protections from covet 19 in the
workplace um its title is pretty
self-explanatory
it's the flip side to the many anti-vax
bills which have been introduced and
it says basically you just have the
right to be vaccinated against covet 19
and the right to use personal protective
equipment such as face masks and face
shields while employed in the workplace
and no employer shall discriminate in
any way against an employee based on the
employee exercising his or her rights
in this section and um
so it is narrowly limited to covet 19
but it
um
and the two of these some well three one
of the assumptions behind her is that
the vaccines the mass are worthwhile
they may not be 100 safe but they're
extremely safe certainly much safer than
the disease
and the
same goes for the mass and ppe so
employees should be able to wear them in
the workplace to protect themselves
and
all workers have the right to protect
themselves it's killed nearly a million
americans 966 000 last time i checked
which is a couple of days ago and i
don't and um so
there have been a lot of famous cases
about it but there have been some here
in new hampshire and certainly um there
were a number of employers who made the
business decision to shut down who
specifically cited the first the
uh
ppe's
the mass mandates during the state of
emergency as a reason why they shut down
even though that's a business this
season they had many factors in it so
um
so please uh
please protect the right of our workers
they have the right to protect
themselves and they certainly
no one has the right to spread a
communicable disease especially one as
terrible as covet 19 because even if you
survive there's the long-term
consequences are in some cases
quite quite horrific and life-altering
so please and also i believe your
employer does not have the right to tell
you
not to protect yourself against
a respiratory disease so please uh
please overturn the committee report and
vote for the series so an alternative
motion
can be introduced thanks
do you recognize representative
inverting to speak for the committee
report thank you mr speaker
the labor committee only had one
individual speak in favor of this bill
and no one against
we have no evidence that there is any
discrimination or has been any
discrimination that has gone on for
someone unwilling or because someone
wants to wear a mask or a shield
get vaccinated or not vaccinated
you've all seen me wearing my mask
around here it's because i have an 84
year old mom i like to go see and it
makes her happy
that i have a mask when i'm in public
settings
that's my choice
and i have not heard anyone from any
walk of life any email any anything
that shows that individuals have
discriminated because of this
i would ask you to follow the committee
and
don't
say this correctly don't try to have a
solution for a problem that doesn't
the motion before us is a majority
motion of in expedient to legislate on
house bill 1088 are you ready for the
question
all those in favor say aye
eyes the eyes have it and the committee
we have
78 i think bill's left on the regular
calendar
we don't have any real
contentious debates as we had yesterday
uh quite a few have one-on-one and quite
a few don't have the base at all so i we
should be able to get through this
calendar
without too much trouble today so i just
wanted to let everybody know that
today's calendar isn't anything like
yesterday's
majority of the committee on labor and
industrial and rehabilitative services
to which was referred house bill 1089
act relative to the unenforceability of
non-complete
agreements with termination of an
employee for non-compliance and with a
vaccination mandate considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with amendment senator
brian seaworth from the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
andrew manville for the minority of the
committee
the amendment is zero three seven six h
printed in house record 10 a page 13.
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted motion before us now is the
committee report about the past with
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
eyes have it and the committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on labor
industrial and rehabilitative services
to which was referred house bill 1094
relative to employee work schedules and
rest periods considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate senator linda turcotte from
the majority of the committee
minority of the committee haven't
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative joshua accident for
the minority of the committee
the motion before us is the committee
report of inexpedient to legislate are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
the eyes have it committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on labor and
industrial and
rehabilitative services to which was
referred house bill 1165 an act
repealing the granite state paid family
leave plan considered the same report
the same with the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass senator leonard
turcotte from the majority of the
committee
minority of the
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study senator joshua
adjutant for the minority of the
committee for what reason does the
member rise to make a motion state your
motion
i move to table bill
1165. that is a proper motion the motion
before us is the table house bill 1
division
our representative prout has requested a
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
so
the motion before us is the table house
chair recognizes representative sullivan
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know
the governor's granite state
family medical leave plan has not yet
been fully put in place and tested
and if i know that any family medical
leave is better than no family medical
leave
would i now press the green button to
table this premature repeal
i recognize representative turcotte for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know there are private insurance
companies that are wanting to offer this
type of fmli insurance to private
businesses on the open and free market
here in new hampshire without the need
for any bureaucratic involvement
and if i also realize we have a short
window of opportunity
to remove the granite state fmli plan
from our rsas while still in its infancy
and prior to it being fully implemented
later this year or early next year
and finally mr speaker
if i know by failing to remove from our
books legislation that was wrongly
slipped into hb2
we will forever
after be stuck with yet another
taxpayer-funded social entitlement
scheme
then would i press the red button
to allow
full consideration of the otp motion on
hb1165
thank you mr speaker the motion before
us is to table house bill 1165. this is
a roll call vote if you're unfavorable
press the green button if you oppose
you'll press the red button
[Music]
uh
while members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
160 voting 172 vote in a the motion of
the table fails
chair recognizes representative adjunct
thank mr speaker
i am in the unenviable position
of coming before the house today to ask
you not to repeal a program that i could
not possibly be convinced to vote for
i am not going to stand here and pretend
like that i think the fmli plan that was
passed as part of hb2 and 2021 was a
good plan
in fact i think it was extremely
regressive
were i to draft a paid family medical
leave plan it wouldn't look like this
for starters it's not universal
a private sector employee can only
receive the plan's benefits
if their employer happens to sign up for
the program
there's no path for an individual to get
the coverage as part of a larger state
pool without the employer signing up
and those benefits
sixty percent of your regular income
forbes magazine reported in 2021 that
six in ten americans live paycheck to
paycheck and now it's closer to seven
and ten
so if you're an administrative assistant
making fifty five thousand dollars a
year sure you can probably forgo 40 of
your income and still be okay
however if you're a state liquor store
employee who for reasons that escape me
only makes 12 an hour
that person is expected under the fmli
plan in hb2 to live on seven dollars an
hour
if they take advantage of a plan that
both people in this hypothetical pay
taxes into
this is an upward redistribution of
wealth from the working class to the
permanent managerial class and doesn't
benefit those who need the program the
most
however
these are not the reasons why a repeal
is being discussed i wish it was
in committee reasons for repeal of this
plan were it costs money it may balloon
as more people sign up for it
well yes there is no free paid family
leave
if you want a program you outline it if
it has the kind of popular support that
a real and robust paid family leave
program has shown to have in polls in
new hampshire you pass it and pay for it
this to me feels like the affordable
care act discussion in 2017.
i felt that the plan passed in 2009 was
alienating confusing technocratic
insurance company giveaways without even
a public option let alone universal
coverage
but the answer then wasn't repeal and
it's not the answer now
it was improved
the minority wants this bill to go to
interim study so paid family leave can
be improved and made better
we should fix this instead of throwing
away a bad plan and starting again at
the chair recognizes representative
turcotte to speak for the committee
report
thank you mr speaker
as previously stated 1165 would repeal
the granite state
paid family medical leave insurance plan
that was
part of hb2 last year
it's been touted as a way for the
private businesses to get paid family
leave insurance for their employees but
in fact in the end this is only going to
morph into a taxpayer-funded
entitlement
so let's talk a little bit of the
specifics
under the current plan
the nearly 11 000 state employees
would have their
premiums for this insurance plan
how much is that nobody knows the
answers because we passed this in hp2
without knowing how much it was going to
cost
doing my own calculations and
you you can
you can bet this is going to be in the
millions and millions of dollars every
year just for the 11 000 state employees
again on the backs of the taxpayers
this past january 1.9 million dollars
was authorized 1.9 million dollars just
to get paid the consultants to look into
getting quotes and getting the plan up
our last executive session the insurance
commissioner asked to address our
committee
they've had
two bills
to repeal this
fmli plan in two different committees
nobody from the commissioner's office
attended
so i asked we asked him at the executive
session the other day why are you coming
here now
why didn't anybody show up to these
original hearings if this was so
important
and he had no answer
we asked him about a few other things in
the current plan fifty percent of the
premiums that a business would pay
they would get a tax break on it
so i asked them
what's the net effect on the revenues
the commissioner also made the statement
during that hearing
that private businesses were very
interested in participating in this plan
when i asked him how many and what
businesses had indicated interest
he said he didn't have a number but he
thought he recalled some someone talking
now there are several other points in
the
in the uh purpose and policy statement
contained in the original language
that's in hb2 i'm going to only mention
one of them because it's it's kind of
interesting
excuse me it says
one of the primary reasons for this is
attracting and retaining workers
this is pure nonsense
all we have to do is look at some of the
states that already have fmli
new york new jersey california illinois
connecticut
note anything in common with those
states
these are the most heavily taxed states
in our country
where the residents are fleeing
they have the highest net negative
migration
of all the states in our country
no one is flocking to these states to
now the reason why private and private
employers are not going to buy this
anyway is extremely expensive
during our last term or the last term i
was here
senator felt has tried putting through a
plan
and during that testimony i won't go
through the whole thing but there was an
individual on our committee who was a
fireman
and he bought his own similar
type of insurance short-term disability
if you will
that had less coverage than this fmli
insurance plan had
and he had sixty dollars a week sixty
dollars a paycheck every other week
taken out of his plan so that's a
hundred twenty dollars per employee
so
without getting in boring you with a
private businesses are not going to be
signing up for this scheme
we're going to be back to the
taxpayer-funded state employees
getting the benefit on the backs of the
taxpayers
i mentioned before
insurance companies now one has already
filed and more will follow
to start providing similar fmli
insurance to private businesses in new
hampshire
outside of the granite state
plant that's in our books
i have a copy of the document from the
the most important part and i mentioned
it briefly in my reason against tabling
is we have an opportunity now a short
window before the this thing gets fully
implemented
to remove this off our books and allow
to allow the free market to uh
do its thing
so
i'm going to ask that you join me in
supporting the committee's
recommendation
of ought to pass
and i do ask for a roll call vote mr
speaker
senator turkin asked for a roll call was
that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
okay
the motion before us is the majority
committed report of octopass and house
bill 1165.
this is a roll call
vote the chair recognizes representative
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know that the granite state family
medical leave program
ought to be tested
and has not yet been implemented
and if i further know
still know
that any family medical leave is better
than no family medical leave
would i now press the red button to
defeat this premature repeal
thank you
chair recognize representative turcotte
for parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker if i know that private insurance
companies are
wanting to offer this type of fmli
insurance on the private market but i
also know we have the opportunity here
to remove the
fmli program from the rsas prior to it
being implemented and finally mr speaker
if i know failing to remove this from
our books the legislation
this nation legislation will be forever
stuck
in our rsas and become a taxpayer-funded
entitlement scheme then would i press
the green button to sustain the majority
vote of ought to pass thank you mr
speaker the motion before us the
majority committee report about to pass
house bill 1165
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor
you'll press the green button if your
pros will press the red button voting
so
[Music]
while members president had an
opportunity to vote
172 voting yeah 164 voting a committee
majority of the committee on labor
industrial and relabilitative services
to which was referred house bill
1210 an act relative to exemptions from
vaccine mandates considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with amendment senate
letter turcotte for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being
unbelievable to agree with the majority
report with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate president brian sullivan for
the minority of the committee
the amendment is 0724
h
printed in house record 10a page 26.
are you ready for the question on the
amendment
all those in favor say aye
mr paul's nay
[Applause]
you guys have it the amendment is
adopted chair recognizes representative
sullivan
thank you mr speaker
it is dangerous medically
what it does is expand the exemptions
for vaccine mandates
for institutions in schools that accept
let's be clear
this is not a covet bill
it exempts all vaccines
diseases that have been long
been eradicated
welcome back to polio
this is a very dangerous medical
bill
currently
under our current rules
medical and religious exemptions are
allowed
under hb
there's a new exemption
currently institutions can create
policies
to to evaluate whether or not an
exemption
should or should not be accepted
under hp 1210
employees simply sign a declaration
saying that they want an exemption
there's no
review
it is clear
that the more exemptions there are
the more disease we will have
since this bill also applies to colleges
schools will be less able to protect
students from
infectious disease
one disease that they are very
active about protecting is encephalitis
students who don't want to get into
encephalitis vaccination
won't
that puts all students at risk
colleges and universities
operate in close quarters
students live in dormitories
they go to class together
in groups
infectious disease can spread
quickly on college campuses
for that reason
colleges often have vaccine mandates
again not just against covid against
i got a call this morning from the
they ran the numbers
and have concluded
that just for the hospitals
the amount of medicaid and medicare
funding that we are at risk of losing
is in the vicinity of 2
our hospitals operate at a very
hospitals have already closed because of
economic situations
we will lose hospitals if we lose our
it is at risk because
the
the center for
medicare and medicaid services
allow for exemptions
for medical and religious reasons
they do not allow for exemptions
on the
rights of conscience
if we add that exemption
and people
act on that exemption
we put all of that medicare and medicaid
funding at risk
this bill also does not allow for
those institutions to evaluate
exemptions
that is part of the
expectation from the cms
if we don't follow cms regulations
we might hear arguments that other
states have done exactly the same thing
as this bill intends to do
we'll hear that those states have not
lost funding for medicare and medicaid
yet
there's a process
when that process takes place it'll be
evaluated whether or not our
institutions
are following the the guidelines
if they are found to be in violation of
the guidelines
they will be warned
this is way too risky for us to
undertake
i also need to point out that our county
nursing homes
county nursing homes that all of us
are responsible for taking care of
we are all delegates
those county nursing homes cannot
operate without medicare and medicaid
funding
if this bill passes
they lose that funding
i think it's going to be county taxes
so essentially if we lose the funding
for medicare and medicaid
we're voting for a gigantic
increase in county taxes
hb 1210
is a dangerous bill
please vote red
on the ought to pass
we're down to our last speaker
senator blasic has requested a roll call
as that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take your seats
chair recognizes representative
infantine
you heard a lot of
really
tough and dangerous talk just now
while i respect my colleague
on the labor committee i
vehemently disagree i think we're
looking at two vastly different bills
the labor committee had about i'd say 10
or 11 bills that came for us that had to
do with
covert related issues
and one of the things the labor
committee tries to do at all costs is
not to get in between business
and the legislature we try to tell them
what to do except for things of safety
so we have a situation where people have
the ability
to have
a waiver if they had a medical reason or
what happens if you didn't have a
medical reason and you're not overly
religious
what happens if you were
put on the spot explain to me exactly
why
medically you are unable to do this
explain to me exactly why
you have a problem you cannot take this
because of a religious reason
so the concept came up
of personal
um
right of conscience so what is right of
it means something within you says i do
not want to do this for my personal
reasons that has never been offered
the goal of all the pieces of
legislation that we had we brought them
down to one
had a study committee and came up with
what you see now
trying to provide individuals the
the bill was
very
well crafted
and has nothing to do with what mike you
heard just previously
do you really think
that after 14 years here as a chairman
of the committee i am going to put my
name on a piece of legislation that
takes two billion dollars away from new
hampshire and closes every single
nursing home
there are contracts
between the federal government
and providers of medicare and medicaid
we do not want to get involved in
between that contract
those contracts do say
vaccinations are required for certain
things or you're not going to get the
money no doubt
we don't want to get in between that
what this allows
is someone to be able to say hey i have
a right of conscious here i'm going to
sign a piece of paper and say i've
written a conscience
it has to be accepted by the employer
at that point the employer
can say well i'm sorry thank you very
much
but that is what is required under our
contract
and
i'm sorry you can no longer have your
job here
at which
they could go to unemployment and other
mechanisms or this opens up the ability
for any medical institution or whatever
to say okay we accept that
maybe we want to keep you we can put you
somewhere else and do something else
which is not going to be in violation of
that contract
so we've given the employee
a new mechanism
right of conscience
and we also haven't gotten in between
that contract
now what will happen after that if
they're consistent
the the employer is consistent with
how they rule on each one of these
things sorry can't do it it's in
violation of our contract we will lose
all the funding we get from the federal
government
maybe we can do something else with you
somewhere else it won't be in violation
or you can go to unemployment
up until about a month ago unemployment
and securities told us they had 200
people
filed for unemployment claims
through medical institutions because
unwillingness to take the vaccine
a certain percentage of those were
provided benefits as long as there was
consistency with what the employer did
so
we kind of very narrowly put this
together it's not as much as some people
would like trust me we have some people
say you didn't go far enough
we wanted you to make sure that that
person for the conscious has a job no
matter what
we can't do that ladies and gentlemen
because we would be putting this money
in in jeopardy
so
in recap we gave them
individuals so you now have medical
religious right of conscience
but the we have not interfered with the
contract between the employer
and the federal government
and we've given everyone as best options
we can we didn't go overboard
trying to to
deal with some of the
negative things that came out of kovitt
which we all know
i call it the great overreaction
but we did the best we could
and i stand here today
this committee the majority of the
committee
did not and does not feel
that they have put two billion dollars
in jeopardy
is going to put medical institutions
hospitals and nursing homes out of
business
it is a very narrowly written bill and
if it's not read correctly
it will look like we did do that
um
i would ask you to support the
committee's recommendation about to pass
thank you mr speaker
the motion before us the majority report
about the past has amended on house bill
1210 this is a roll call vote members
clear
the motion before us is the majority
report of auto passes amended on house
bill 1210
this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative soucy
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i believe that hb 1210 as
amended were to become law
that new hampshire would place our
health care providers in direct conflict
with the vaccine requirements and
incentives for medicare and medicaid
services potentially causing them to
forfeit billions of dollars of federal
funding
and mr speaker if i know that house bill
1210 attempts to create a right of
conscience in the state that
a state law that is in direct conflict
with the federal vaccine requirements
and if i also know that the language in
hb 1210 requires that any exemption
request made either for religious
medical or right of conscience must be
granted which is in clear violation of
the federal vaccine requirements placing
an undue burden on our businesses and
health care providers once again putting
at risk billions of dollars in medicare
and medicaid funding
and finally mr speaker
if i know that hb 1210 seeks to usurp
the decision of business and health care
leaders in our state for making the
decisions they believe are in the best
interest of their businesses health care
organizations employees
customers and patients but i now press
the red button to oppose the ought to
pass amendment motion so that another
motion can be made thank you mr speaker
[Music]
chair recognized representative lang for
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
happily agree with the rep from walpole
when while speaking yesterday on house
bill 1080 she said all persons deserve
the right of conscience and mrs further
mr speaker if i am happy knowing that is
exactly what this bill does extending
the right of conscience to all new
hampshire citizens in alignment with our
new hampshire constitution part one
article four
and end the rep of the rep from
walpole's beliefs
mr speaker i know that new hampshire
constitution part 1 article 4 reads and
the right of conscience unalienable
among these natural rights are some by
their very nature
unalienable
because no equivalent can be given or
received for them
of this kind are the rights of
conscience mr speaker if i know the word
unalienable means that which will not be
given or taken away
lastly mr speaker if i know this bill in
addition to aligning our law with the
new hampshire constitution
has the additional benefit of
streamlining business processes
reducing the potential lawsuits based on
the ada and civil rights acts
and would i now press the green button
to support both our new hampshire
constitution our new hampshire citizens
and our new hampshire businesses please
vote green
the motion before us is the majority
report about the past has amended on
house bill 1210
this is a rope for what reason member
rise
we're in we're in the voting mode right
now representative
weber
the motion before us is the majority
report of our passes amended in house
bill 1210
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press a green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
if all members president had an
181 voting a 155 voting a
now representative weber
thank you mr speaker and my apologies
for being a little too precipitate
i rise as a point of personal privilege
to state
that my words were taken entirely
out of context by the previous speaker
the majority of committee on labor
industrial and rehabilitative services
to which was referred house bill one two
five one
an act prohibiting payment of sub
minimum wages have been considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate senator leonard turcotte
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass from mrs brian sullivan to the
for what reason does the member rise
rise to make a motion mr speaker motion
motion to table hb one two five one
the motion the table is
correct
the motion before us now is the table
house bill
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1251
this is a division vote the chair
recognizes representative turcotte for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know the
average tipped employee in new hampshire
makes north of twenty dollars an hour
and much higher and higher under higher
end
establishments and if i further know
that restauranters
restauranteurs and tip staff know best
how to operate their businesses better
than we politicians do
and finally mr speaker if i know that
here in new hampshire in our neighbor to
the northeast the state of maine there
are real world examples
of how ill-conceived legislation like
this has proven disastrous and i won't
get to tell you those stories
would i now press the green button to
tell table hb one two five one thank you
mr speaker
chair recognize reminiscent schultz for
a parliamentary inquiry
if i know that the average american now
believes that hard work is not being
rewarded
if i know we as granite staters need a
robust
capitalism that has the real
conversation about wages
if i know
alex ray of the common man family of
restaurants the largest new hampshire
employer
of restaurant workers almost 10 000
granite staters
and if i know new hampshire ought to be
the land of opportunity
not the land of the lowest wages in our
region
i would then push the red button
and start that robust conversation
the motion before us is the tabling
motion on house bill one two five one
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppose you'll press
the red but voting stations are open for
so
while members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend this
187 voting a 149 voting a
the tabling motion on house bill 1251 is
adopted
majority of the committee on labor
industrial relative services to which
and act relative to the duration of
unemployment benefits having considered
the same report the same
the following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with the amendment senate have
lended turcotte from the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution result that is
inexpedient to legislate
president of andrew manville for the
minority of the committee
the amendment is
0732h printed in house record 10a pages
51-52
the question is on the amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
[Music]
the amendment is adopted the chair
recognizes senator manville to speak
thank you mr speaker
i rise in opposition to house bill 1337
today
this bill if enacted
would index
the
time for unemployment benefits
to be paid
to claimants under that system
indexing it to the state
average unemployment rate
that is
the if this bill is enacted
the maximum number of weeks of coverage
for
unemployment benefits
would be 16 weeks
if the unemployment rate is 3 percent
with that time
increasing to 26 weeks
in
half point increments per week
up to 26
at an eight percent rate of unemployment
this bill has a good objective
to get people back to work but
it is a bad methodology for doing that
our new hampshire unemployment benefit
system
already has built-in incentives for
people to get back to work
it only pays a portion of
the earnings claimants make prior to
going on unemployment it has a 26 week
limit
and
claimants
must be actively looking for work and
there are
rules in place to help ensure that this
happens
but the proof is in the pudding
the vast majority
of
people who apply for and get
unemployment benefits
do not use all 26 weeks
so who are
the relatively few
people who do
well this bill would appear to assume
that they are freeloaders
happy to
take advantage of
a golden goose
and
the bill then assumes
that the time they should have for
finding a job should be linked to the
state
unemployment rate
this is illogical
the unemployment rate does not take into
account
particular
trades
or occupations
certain geographical variances
or the demand for or availability of
particular
skills experience or training
but most
importantly
it doesn't take into account the
individual circumstances of the people
who are in
this
minority of people who need time to find
work
those individual circumstances
health issues
we just heard that they might include
rights of conscience
they include local
employment challenges
transportation issues
lack of experience
or training in a particular
sought sought-after
they ignore the possibility that someone
would choose to stay in a particular
field of endeavor rather than take
whatever is available on the market
and generally they
do not relate it all to anomalies at any
point in time in the job market relevant
to a particular person
as addressed by the state unemployment
rate
mr speaker very few people
those
who
those relative few who stay
unemployed longer
than others
often face challenges that most of us
aren't facing
their circumstances are peculiar to them
not to
a
determined state average unemployment
rate
for this minority of job seekers
reducing the benefit period
because of a low unemployment rate
would have a cruel
and punitive effect
on them
and
in respect to their circumstances and
also on their families
this bill if enacted
could create further welfare benefit
exact other demands on our safety nets
and even potentially exacerbate
homelessness
our current system works
i urge you to vote against
this bill so that a motion for itl can
be made
we're down to our last speaker a roll
call has been requested by
representative turcotte is that
sufficiently seconded
it is officially seconded this will be a
roll call vote members take your seats
thank you mr speaker
hb 1337 is a common sense and rational
approach to unemployment that has proven
successful in the other states that
has implemented such a plan
businesses see their unemployment
compensation insurance rates decline
and it also allows the state's trust
fund to be strengthened
remember businesses are the ones who pay
for all the unemployment compensation in
this state
florida i'll give you one example is the
shining star of where this has happened
at one point during the 2008 finite
financial crisis
its trust fund had swung to a negative
1.7 billion dollar
loss
after a few years of implementing this
type of a plan
it swung positive 3.9 for a net gain of
5.6 billion
and florida now enjoys the lowest
unemployment
insurance rates in the country
as the previous speaker mentioned this
does tie the length of time one can
receive the employment
compensation to the employ unemployment
rate
the maximum of 26 weeks does not change
and it does reduce
uh down to when whenever the
unemployment rate is less than three
percent
the member will suspend for a minute the
member has a right to be heard take your
one other issue that came up in uh
and was a few of the reasons why we had
changes in the the amendment
were
the concerns over what would happen in
case of uh like the financial crisis in
2008 or even the recent covert crisis
where we had individuals on
unemployment for extended lengths of
time the the deputy commissioner
actually actually made the point that he
wasn't concerned about it only because
the federal government had stepped in to
extend those benefits
even with that i decided to put an
additional provision into the language
that would give
the governor an extreme circumstances
similar to the covert 19 the the ability
to
adjust those
rates
the good news about this there is
absolutely no financial downside risk
the only probability for a positive
upside for both the state's trust fund
and more importantly the businesses who
will see their unemployment taxes go
down
new hampshire does have a pretty good
system now this bill would only make it
better i ask that you support the otp
motion by pressing the green button
the motion before us is the majority
report of what the pass has amended on
house bill 1337
this is a roll call vote
so
motion before us is the majority
ought to pass as amended on house bill
chair recognizes
representative sullivan for
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know
that our unemployment benefit program is
working effectively as it is
and if i further know that the
relatively low level of unemployment
benefits
and the requirement to seek employment
provide a strong incentive for folks to
seek
to return to work
and finally if i know that a small group
of individuals find it very difficult to
find a new job
due to age
physical frailty
or family circumstances and therefore
need
26 weeks of benefits available
regardless of the unemployment rate
would i then
press the red button so that another
motion might be made thank you
i recognize representative turcotte for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know indexing the time the
unemployed may collect unemployment
compensation to the unemployment rate is
both rational and grounded in common
sense
and if i also know the net effect of
this legislation would be to improve new
hampshire's unemployment trust fund
while also lowering the cost of
insurance premiums our new hampshire
businesses currently pay
then when i press the green button to
send this fiscally sound bill to the
those on the other side of the wall
behind me thank you mr speaker
the motion before us a majority
committee reported what a pass has
amended on house bill 1337
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you press the red button
so
while members president had an
opportunity to vote
179 voting a 153 voting a committed
the majority of the committee on labor
industrial and rehabilitative services
to which was referred to house bill 1472
an act prohibiting anti-union activities
by employers having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolve that it has been
expedient to legislate representative
gregor for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative dan toomey for the
the member from nashville representative
jimmy is recognized to speak against the
working people
sometimes question whether it's in their
best interest to bargain with their
employer as
an individual
or
[Music]
bargain as a group
and so
if a majority of them
decides
it's in their best interest to bargain
as a group
and an election and be certified as a
yet
more
and and they should be able to do this
without interference from their employer
yet more than 75 of private sector
employees
respond
to organizing drives
these typically involve a series of
at the workplace where the employer
makes this case
against unionizations
these meetings are by their nature
coercive
because workers must attend
an employee and employers make dire
claims about the consequences of
unionization
and those who question the company line
can face discipline
or termination
and that happens
high-ranking company officials often
attend
and union activists are pointed out for
derision
these meetings are often
followed by supervisor one-on-ones
as the primary means through which
employers deliver threats
and engage in interrogation
employers use
these supervisors
one-on-one
to threaten workers with union activity
time and
interrogate workers about their union
activity
and that of co-workers in at least 63
percent of the time
employees use survey surveillance in
there are laws against
firing employees for organizing union
but in more than 40 percent of the union
election campaign
laws however
the penalties for breaking the law are
minimal
and they're applied many months after
an employee is fired for the purpose of
employers own their business but they
don't own their employees
employers are free citizens
whose work
makes all of our lives better
and as such they are deserving of
dignity
and respect they should be free from
coercion or intimidation
claim that these meetings are an
exercise in free speech
but mandating a person or a group to
listen to your point of view is not free
speech
it's not free
i don't know what it is but it's not
please vote against the committee's
recommendation
of itl and press the red button thank
you
the member from manchester
representative infanzine is recognized
to speak in support of the committee
report
thank you mr speaker
when a group of individuals decides that
they're going to
[Music]
make an attempt to form a union to be
organized
that's okay that's all fair and that's
the way
but we all know and i'll use a
legal term here
that more often than not
in the trenches no one has clean hands
all right
management may say something that
is
against
forming the union and say well you're
going to spend money on this and this
and you may not get that union on the
other hand will say yeah but we'll get
you this this and this
so then each one uses the media to see
what we can do that they can do to try
to
dissuade
an opinion national labor relations
board is in place does their job gets
the bill was one-sided
said that management can't say anything
negative about a union well what about
the other side
why do we have a one-sided bill that was
that was a
something that
the majority couldn't get past
if you're going to do something it needs
to be fair for all
that's what the national labor relations
board does
they try to get involved when things get
out of control and bring things back to
where they should be so we had a bill
that was not equal to both
we have an organization that is already
in place to do things
and unfortunately as i said
things
don't always aren't always pretty
when we're making legislation and
they're not always pretty
when uh
a group is trying to organize
it is not the best system but the best
one we have
and so far it seems to be working so i
would request that the members of the
committee or excuse me the members of
the house support the labor committee
position of inter-speeding to legislate
and mr speaker i would like a division
vote
the question before the house is the
majority committee report of
inexpedience legislate are you ready for
the question a roll call has been
requested is that sufficiently seconded
is that sufficiently seconded
it is not sufficiently seconded this
so
house will be in order
representative bluchart is recognized
mr speaker
if i know that employees should have the
right
to come together and decide
and then bargain as a group without
employer interference
and
mr speaker if i know that this decision
to come together to decide and then
bargain as a group must be free
from coercion and intimidation
then mr speaker
would i press the red button
so that someone can make
another motion
thank you mr speaker
representative infantine is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker
if i know that the bill was well
intended but is one-sided
if i also know that there are mechanisms
in place with the national labor
relations board to deal with issues that
go on
when a group of
employees wants to organize than what i
support
the committee recommendation of
the question is on the majority
committee report of inexpediency
legislate this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll be pressing the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
uh
[Music]
representative
have all members president an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
181 having voted in the affirmative 149
on the negative the committee report has
adopted
mr speaker for what reason does remember
us i rise to request that hb the remarks
on hb
1472 be placed in the permanent journal
without objection
there is an objection
are you ready for the question
what
the motion is whether to print the
remarks of the previous debate in the
permanent journal all those in favor say
aye
well done
we had a division all right this will be
so
the question is whether to print the
remarks of the previous debate and the
permanent journal this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
representative wilhelm
all memphis president had an opportunity
to vote
i also attended the state of the vote
195 having voted in the affirmative 141
and the negative the remarks will be
printed
the majority of the committee on labor
industrial and rehabilitative services
which referred house bill 1508 fn
an act prohibiting discharge of
volunteer firefighters or volunteer
emergency medical technicians from other
employment having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolve that it has been
expedient to legislate representative
leno avalani for the majority of the
committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative andrew manaval for
the minority of the committee
questions on the majority committee
report of inexpediency legislate are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes haven't the committee reports
adopted
the majority of the committee on labor
industrial and rehabilitative services
to which was referred to house bill 1514
fm an act relative to an employee's
unused earned time having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate representative leno
avellani for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment representative
michael cahill for the minority of the
committee
the member from newmarket representative
cahill is recognized to speak against
the committee report
uh
i'm sorry what for what reason does a
member rise i make a motion
state your motion a motion to table this
bill
representative harrington moves to table
house bill 1514
are you ready for the question
division has been requested this will be
clearer
okay
the question is whether to lay house
okay representative cahill is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that there are
people of goodwill
who are interested in fairness
fairness of how we treat our workforce
who
may have been here for previous
reversions of this bill which the house
has voted to pass twice before once with
the overturning of a committee report so
it could happen again
uh if if maybe if i'd like to
talk about the bill and hear the
other side talk about their perspective
if i think it's worth talking about
worth considering would i then vote red
on the tabling motion and i ask your
support
the question is whether to lay house
bill 1514 on the table this is division
vote if you're in favor you'll be
pressing the green button if you're
opposed you'll be pressing the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
of all members president an opportunity
to vote
the house will attend to the state of
168 having voted in the affirmative 172
we're back to the majority committee
report
member from newmarket representative
cahill is recognized to speak against
thank you mr speaker
and thank you
colleagues
three hundred dollars
three hundred and six dollars and sixty
cents
four hundred and ninety three dollars
and sixty six cents five hundred and
seventy dollars
five hundred and ninety one dollars and
eighteen cents
mr speaker colleagues this is not the
proposed pay increase for the members of
the house
this is these numbers are the number or
the amounts that people lost
when they were working a job
and the and the owners sold the company
but did not
provide that their vacation hours would
be transferred to the next employer he
did not pay them out so they lost a
combined total of two thousand two
hundred and sixty one dollars and forty
four cents
many of us think that's not that
shouldn't happen that's the wrong way to
handle your employees that what should
happen is that you would transfer
everything to the new employer or pay
them
18 days
144 hours at 16.32 cents per hour
2300 dollars 50 cents
23.50 and 8 cents
that is what another employee lost when
she was told today is your last day
you you may have vacation hours and this
cut this employer had the policy
of if you did not use all your vacation
hours during the year they would not it
would not say use it or lose it but they
would pay you a very progressive company
they would pay you what you hadn't used
but it when terminated
they did not pay because this employee
unable to request the vacation time two
weeks in advance per the policy because
she had no notice of the other being
laid off
she lost twenty three hundred dollars
now
while the other people were fortunate to
have a job to go to this this person had
to go and collect unemployment
which i think probably hurt the
unemployment trust fund
small enough but it still impacted the
trust fund
so
i've been working on this for a few
years now with my good friend from
hudson
the man with the wonderful thai
collection
and
we began this quest because he was
interested in using or losing
the practice where an employer says you
know you get this much time in a
calendar year or your anniversary date
if you don't use it you lose it
this bill does nothing has nothing to do
with that that's practice remains does
not affect it
this bill only comes into effect
when the company is sold
or there's a layoff and a permanent
layoff at that because we heard from the
people who paved the roads at the
seasonal employer if you lay them off
you know you're probably going to come
them back so this is a permanent the
amendment that we'll talk about later it
deals with that so it's only two special
circumstances that we think
when an employer writes their policy
that says i don't pay a termination
that termination can have many many
causes without where the employee is
blameless has not uh caused the trouble
at work has done their job
has
obviously been paying 16.32 cents an
hour had done a good job for the seven
years she worked there
and
it's just not it's just not right for
the employee to suffer
when they have no role in this it was
beyond their control and all of a sudden
what was on their pay stub whether it
was paper digital it's gone
so i asked you to overturn
the committee report so that we might
look at the amendment
and pass that so i can stop bothering
you and i want to do this again next
year
does this member yield for a question
yes
you may inquire
thank you mr speaker and thank you for
taking my question
according to the bill it says that this
only takes effect if the company is sold
or transferred or if it's a layoff if
you have a worker who has accrued a
thousand or two thousand dollars in
unpaid time vacation time sick time
something like that and they walk off
the job they quit it doesn't apply to
that it does not all right thank you
last speaker the member from manchester
representative infantine is recognized
to speak in favor of the committee
report
thank you mr speaker
employers choose many different ways
to offer enticements or benefits to
their employees to be good employers to
have good employees you must offer these
things
some are health benefits disability
vacation time sick time but the way each
company does this is very different
depending on what kind of a business
they are if they're seasonal uh they
have
busier times slower times
whether they offer bonuses on a
quarterly basis for exceptional
production
or any of these things some say well
you're going to get two weeks vacation
five sick days
and five personal days other companies
have said we're going to take that
entire amount we're going to give you
equivalent to three weeks to use what
however you choose whether it's vacation
time personal time or sick time
it varies
in the labor committee we try not to
tell businesses what to do and how to do
it
for example my company chooses to
provide people with vacation time
and they want them to use the vacation
time i want them to be fresh i want them
to take that time with their families
and do what they need to do to enjoy
their lives
at the end of the year i don't want them
to carry it over to other times i want
them to use it
right but i will if they don't use their
sick time roll it over because something
terrible happens where you're sick for a
month you want them to have those
benefits those are decisions i make as
an owner
other other owners make other decisions
on how they're going to do it and we try
not to interfere
what the bill is trying to say is that
vacation time and sick time is earned
money
it's not a benefit but it's cash in hand
now we're here every once in a while
especially with some organized
municipalities or something where
someone will retire
and they haven't taken sick time in five
years or vacation in five years and they
walk away with a large check that's fine
because that's negotiation with the
union and that's what was developed
again labor committee not getting
involved with a private business or a
private municipality and their employees
we don't want to do the same thing here
we do not want to tell employers
that sick time unused sick time and
vacation time
is cash in hand to take with them if
that is not if that is the intent of the
owner
then it's in the employer's manual
if it is not the intent of the employer
we shouldn't be telling that they should
have to do that and that is the only
difference i don't disagree with the
previous speaker if a business wants to
do that
but again
it's up to the individual business the
individual owner and how they treat
their employees and what's their
employee manuals
and we don't like to interfere with that
so i would ask you to support
the committee
recommendation of it expedient to
legislate and i would like a division
the roll call has been requested by who
the representative chair cut request
roll call and it is sufficiently
all right
the house will come to order
the question is on the majority
committee report of an expediency
legislate
this is a roll call vote the member from
newmarket representative cahill is
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know
that
i agree with the previous speaker my
good friend from manchester
that
hour isn't these policies are set by the
employer that's that's a good situation
to have and i know that in many cases
most cases the employer will use
something else beside the law they'll
use their conscience something will tell
them what they should and shouldn't do
what's the right thing to do
but it doesn't always go that way and if
i know that this law
would only cover two very narrow
circumstances which i think most of us
will agree
were egregious they were not handled
well they would they would not fair to
the employer to the employee would i
then vote green sorry
red to defeat the itl so that another
representative infantine is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know
there are always circumstances that we
can't account for but not everything has
to be in law
and by a further know that we do not
tell businesses for the most part except
for safety type things
what to do then i would request that you
support the majority report of itl thank
this is a roll call vote if you are in
favor of the committee report you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
[Music]
of all members present at an opportunity
to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
172 having voted in the affirmative 164
in the negative the committee report is
adopted
the majority of the committee on
legislative administration which was
referred cacr 23
enact
the new hampshire constitution that's
awkward wording providing that all
references to persons in the new
hampshire constitution be gender neutral
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative bob green for
the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative manny a special for
the minority of the committee
for what reason does a member rise
make a motion state emotion i'd like to
table cacr23
representative hill moves that cacr 23
be laid on the table are you ready for
the question
a division has been requested this will
be a division vote members take your
seats
up
all right the question is whether to lay
crc
rcacr23 on the table this is a division
vote
representative lebranch is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
oh sorry i did that wrong
represent i know i'm sorry
representative hill is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker mr speaker if i know there
there's little chance that
the necessary percentage will be
received
and if i know the testimony was that
since each and every
change that would need be needed to be
included on and shown to the voter that
the ballot for this question would be 12
pages long
leading to much confusion and wasted
resources would i now request and follow
the committee suggestion to
table this bill thank you
representative lebranch is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker
if i know that this is a very important
cacr
and if i know that this cacr has passed
this house before with a bipartisan
majority and it has also passed
the other body with a bipartisan
majority
and if i know
that back in 1998 56 of voters have
voted in favor of the cacr and i believe
we've come a long way since 1998
and if i believe that today we would
have had the requisite support from the
population to pass the caacr would i now
pat press the red button so that we can
the question is whether to lay cr
cacr23 on the table if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
[Music]
also of all members president an
opportunity to vote
get him
all right the house will attend to the
state of the vote
190 having voted in the affirmative 140
in the negative cacr 23 is laid on the
table
the committee on legislative
administration which was referred to
house bill 1007 and act relative to
qualifications for office having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
it is inexpedient to legislate
representative matthew simon for the
committee
for what reason does a member rise to
make a motion state your motion i'd like
to table house bill
representative hill moves that house
bill 1007 be laid on the table are you
ready for the question
okay
yes
alrighty so who requested the roll call
representative tim smith requests a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
and it is this will be a roll call vote
there
all right the house will come to order
the question is whether they house bill
we're going i also come to order please
representative ruler is recognized for
thank you mr speaker
if i know that removal of a member of
this house
for insurrection and rebellion would be
a very
difficult task
and if i know that this bill is vague
the language is poor and there's no
procedure outlined for removal in the
bill
and if i know that this bill
could be used
as a political weapon
by one party against the other
would i vote with the majority of
legislative administration
and vote the color of my jacket
representative marshall is recognized
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that the
disqualification clause of the 14th
amendment already prohibits those who
engage in insurrection
and rebellion from holding any public
office and at this time even without the
passage of this bill
a member can be removed or not seated
and if i know that the new hampshire
constitution gives the new hampshire
house under part 2 article 14
and the new hampshire senate under part
2 article 29 the sole authority to rule
on the qualifications of their members
but if i know that there is no authority
under current statute to call a special
election if either body disqualified a
member for violating the 14th amendment
and therefore an entire district
of this house or if the other body could
remain unrepresented for an entire
biennium
then would i push the red button so that
we can ensure that all of our citizens
the question is whether the lay house
bill 1007 on the table this is a roll
call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
186 having voted in the affirmative 150
in the negative house bill 1007 is laid
the committee on legislative for what
the committee on legislative
administration which was referred house
bill
1033 fn local
an act prohibiting recipients of state
or local grants or appropriations from
using such funds for lobbying having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendments and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment representative
gregory hill for the committee
the committee amendment is zero eight
one five h printed in house record 10-a
on pages six and seven
the quest question is on the committee
amendment
for what reason does the member rise
again you're so kind mr speaker i move
that retable hb 1033. i couldn't
understand that
i couldn't
mr speaker i move that we table hb 1033.
okey-dokey
the motion is whether chile house bill
1033 on the table
a division has been requested this will
representative belanger requests a roll
clearly
the question is whether to lay house
bill 1033 on the table this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button
so
of all members president an opportunity
to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
174 having voted in the affirmative 161
on the negative house bill 1033 is laid
the committee on legislative
administration which was referred house
bills 1041 fn
an act extending the public employees
labor relations act to employees of the
general court and relative to the duties
of the joint committee on legislative
facilities having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolve that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
scott wallace for the committee
the question is on the committee report
of inexpedient to legislate
representative hill requests a division
uh for what reason does a member rise
for a motion
may i table house bill 1041 please
representative hill moves at house bill
1041 be laid on the table
okay there it is the division vote's
been requested this will be a division
clearly
all right the question is whether to lay
house bill 1041 on the table
representative turcotte is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know this
legislative body has heard the same bill
at least four times in recent years and
and the employees of the general court
have not once been asked for their input
regarding such a bill and its
proposition
if i further know that just like
previous bills
like previous similar bills the language
and provisions of the bill are nothing
but
clear and in fact very confusing and
ill-thought-out and lastly and most
importantly mr speaker if i know the
staff of the general court has always
been and should continue to be exemplars
of nonpartisanship
in the fulfillment of their duties then
would i now press the green button to
support the tabling motion thank you mr
speaker
representative schultz is recognized for
if i know
that
the reason the bill keeps coming back is
because
being able to organize a union is a
human right
and if i know
that
our leader
who recently passed
worked hard on this bill because he
understood the human right to organize
and that state all government employees
it's the right thing to do
press the red button so another
motion
the question is whether to lay house
bill 1041 on the table this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
so
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
187 having voted in the affirmative 146
and the negative house bill 1041 is laid
the committee on legislative
administration which was referred house
bill for what reason does a member rise
i rise to ask
for
the remarks on
oh sorry
i asked to uh i rise to ask that the
remarks for house bill 1007 be added to
the motion is whether to
print the remarks for house bill 1007
yes
just parliamentary chris
okay without objection
the committee on legislative
administration which was referred to
house bill 1084 and act relative to the
disclosure of the sources of legislative
bill proposals
oh my having considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolve that it is in expedient to
legislate representative bob green for
the committee the question is on the
committee report of an expedient to
legislate are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
yeah i just haven't the committee
the committee on legislative
administration which was referred to
house bill 1102 an act relative to
certain committees and commissions of
the department of state
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with amendment representative
bob green for the committee the
amendment zero one eight eight h is
printed in house record 10-a on pages
13-14 the question is on the committee
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those beau's nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted the question is now on the
majority committee report of ought to
pass with amendment are you ready for
the question all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
the committee on legislative
administration which was referred to
house bill 1129 an act relative to the
fiscal committee of the general court
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative claire roulard
for the committee the question is on the
committee report of an expedient to
legislate and a division has been
requested this will be a division vote
so
the questions on the committee report
have been expedient to legislate this is
a division vote representative timothy
smith is recognized for parliamentary
inquiry
mr speaker if i know that in the long
history of the new hampshire general
court
the membership
of the joint fiscal committee
has not historically been
a partisan issue
that the composition of that committee
has historically followed the same
proportional representation as other
committees in both chambers however if i
also know
that unfortunately in recent years
the membership count and the party
balance on that committee has become a
partisan issue
and the process
is no longer working and that the
parties are no longer balanced on that
committee
and if i know mr speaker that the
purpose of this bill is not about any
current
issues but that it is looking towards
the future
to make sure that moving forward
future legislatures our successors in
these seats
four six twenty years from now
won't have to worry about the membership
of this joint fiscal committee becoming
a partisan football regardless of which
party is happening to be in control of
did you want to press the red button
representative ruler is recognized for
thank you mr speaker
if i know the joint fiscal committee
made up of members from the house and
the senate
has been appointed
for 35
years
by the same mechanism since
1987 we have not had that problem
and if i know that changing who appoints
the members
will not affect the great work that's
currently done and has been done by the
fiscal committee
and if i also know that the change is
unnecessary because they continue to
work well together and will continue to
work well together regardless of who
appoints them
would i now vote with the majority of
the legislative administration and still
press the button the color of this
the questions on the majority committee
report of inexpedience at legislate
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
so
representative oregon you need to be in
have all members president an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
188 having voted in the affirmative 142
in the negative the committee report is
adopted
the committee on legislative
administration which was referred to
house bill 1170 an act limiting the
authority of new hampshire delegates to
policy-making conventions having
considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with amendment
representative scott wallace for the
committee mr speaker the committee
amendment is zero two seven zero h
printed on house record 10 a on page 16.
for what reason does the member rise
it's a little too late because we're
already into the amendment so wait a
minute sorry
we're already into the amendment so i'll
um mr speaker i would move that house
bill 1170 be placed upon the table but
it sounded like you had started to call
so moved
representative tim smith moves that
house bill 1170 be laid on the table
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested this will
be a division vote members back in your
seats
requests for roll calls that's
officially seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
okay this is a roll call vote weather
delay house bill 1170 on the table
representative tim smith is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i have been
working on the article 5 issue for well
over a decade
and if i have been approached over the
years
by members of both parties and used as a
resource
in regards to the nuance of article five
of the us federal constitution
and mr speaker if i am in firm agreement
with the intent and principles behind
this legislation
however mr speaker
if i have also found that the language
in this bill is unenforceable under
federal law
and if i have found mr speaker that the
language in this bill is unfortunately
overly broad
and could interfere with the state's
ability to engage in other interstate
conventions and pacts unrelated to
article 5 of the u.s constitution
for example mr speaker if this could
negatively impact the ability of new
hampshire to participate in periodic
renegotiations of things like the
interstate driver's license compact
which we kind of need would i now press
representative wallace is recognized for
yes thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that this body
passed an identical bill in 2015 by a
bipartisan three to one majority and mr
speaker if i further know that the body
on the other side of the wall behind me
passed the bill on on a voice vote
and mr speaker if i further know that
the governor's veto was due to the need
for this legislation was in the future
and the future is now
and finally mr speaker if i know that we
are only a couple of states away from a
convention call with two states filing
resolutions just in the time period
since this bill was introduced would now
press the red button
to stop this tabling motion so another
the question is whether lay house bill
1170 on the table this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll be
pressing the green button if you're
opposed you'll be pressing the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
[Music]
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend another state of
the vote
157 having voted in the affirmative 186
the question now is on the committee
amendment zero two seven zero h are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
the question now is on the majority
committee report about to pass with
amendment the member from seabrook
representative abramson is recognized to
thank you
mr speaker
mr speaker the last time that the house
passed this bill
both sides admitted in hearings and on
the floor that unless any convention of
the states occurred in new hampshire
the event would probably be outside
the state's jurisdiction and the
jurisdiction of our laws and have no
impact but out of nearly 200 conventions
of the states in our country's history
and over 200 state constitutional
conventions
not one single delegate
has been recorded to have ever exceeded
their legislative commission
at no time
has either type of convention resulted
in a loss nor erosion of anything in any
state nor federal bill of rights
whenever conventions meandered outside
the scope of a delegates commission
they have always returned to their
respective state legislatures to seek
guidance and were allowed to do so
the problem with this bill
is that it provides a false sense of
security to legislatures
to legislators sorry
since 269 members of congress if we're
talking about an article 5 convention
269 members of congress can bypass our
state legislatures and choose state
ratifying conventions as they did with
the 21st amendment
while three other states have laws in
place for state ratifying conventions
even allowing voters to elect delegates
to a state ratifying convention who are
committed to a no vote
this house rejected that bill when i
introduced it a few years ago
worse state law has
that the governor not the general court
makes the appointments to conventions of
the states such as with the uniform law
commission
most state legislatures make those
appointments themselves still worse is
that if this bill
if it were successful in binding any
delegate would automatically take our
delegate
out of the debate on any proposed
constitutional amendment if someone
discovered structural or constitutional
issues since they wouldn't be allowed to
vote on an amendment to the amendment or
any change to the amendment late
proposals at that convention of states
could not raise the debt ceiling without
a the ascent of three quarters of state
legislatures or limiting the scope of
spending cuts in a balanced budget
amendment which were two states away
from now
might prevent our delegate from voting
on the matter
this bill is the worst idea since the
cia spent 20 million dollars on studies
to find out whether human beings had
psychic powers if we'd had psychic
powers we'd have known to itl this bill
the member from durham representative
horrigan is recognized to speak against
how is it okay
actually
thank you very much mr speaker i guess i
originally thought i was signed up to do
a pi but plans have changed but
um
so
the main problem with this bill is that
it's
totally unnecessary
our an article five convention is it's
not imminent it's not on the horizon um
i
if one happens
we'll have plenty of uh plenty of lead
time to
craft a bill similar
cr well crafter bill covering the same
subject matter as this
it's not you know we're not going to
have one next week we're not you know
we're not going to have one
for quite some time if we have one at
all
but then the second problem is
we don't know what the rules for this
convention is even if it's a so-called
assembly of the states whatever body
uh convenes that amendment will set its
own rules they're probably
going to have nothing whatsoever
to do with the detail in this bill
and
also
the whole basic concept that we're
supposed to remove these delegates if
they approve and under a so-called what
what the term is un
unapproved amendment
they'll have the same rights that we
have as members of the new hampshire
house the same rights as members
congress has those are guaranteed not
just by the u.s and state constitutions
but by common laws so
when we're on the floor of the
convention the people of the our
district can't can't remove us just
because they don't like our vote at
least and the same will same go for
those delegates regardless of whether
it's an article 5 convention could mean
by congress
or some other some other body
then finally let's say let's say they do
let's say the body does vote for some
unapproved uh unapproved amendments um
those still have to be ratified by
a super majority of the states that's
very difficult it's happened i think
only
now i forget the exact number but i
think it's 26 times in uh
250 years
so anything that this convention passes
is going to be harmless unless it's
incredibly popular there's a very broad
consensus
that we should change the constitution
or even
i suppose theoretically they could even
uh enact a new conference constitution
people talk about the articles of
convention the runaway convention
that was supposed to just amend the
articles confederation that was a
convention that caused the u.s
constitution which has uh
served us well since 1789.
and um
the member from
and the the member from manchester
already mentioned this but this bill
this particular version of it is so
broadly written it covers the members of
i believe there's 41 interstate compacts
dealing with things as big as driver's
licenses
or things as small scale as our
interstate school districts in the
rivendell school district and the
hanover
the dresden school district in the
hanover area of the rivendell school
district up in the upper valley the
connecticut river so this uh
bill is you know this bill is
unnecessary it's premature
and it would have some very bad
unintended consequences
so we should uh
we should
we should overturn the octopass's
amendment and itl today and we can
always
revisit this once we know
if there's a convention we'll plenty of
time to revisit it once we know what the
framework for the convention will
actually be
thanks
so uh
all right we are at the final speaker
and a division was requested on this so
start migrating back
remember from danville representative
wallace is recognized to speak in
representative wallace waves off the pi
so this will be a division vote members
now
yes
the question is on the majority
committee report of house bill 1170.
this is a division vote
representative horrigan is recognized
thank you very much mr speaker
so if i know that
hb 1170 is totally unnecessary no
article 5 convention is going to happen
you know in the very near future may
happen someday but it's
it'll happen
and if i do know it's premature we will
know when such a convention is called
we're going to know well in advance
we'll have plenty of time to
write another bill
um if i know also this bill a lot of the
details in the bill are highly
questionable in fact it's probably
unconstitutional
the uh
the members would have the same rights
and responsibilities as those of any
other legislative body such as the us
congress or this house you know so
a lot of the things in the bill are
things that's just sort of the state
cannot
cannot do and
finally this also interferes with our
participation over 40 interstate
compacts
it's supposed to be a problem if i know
all these things
i apologize for leaving out the if i
know so if i know this feels unnecessary
if i know it's premature if i know it
adversely affects our participation over
40 interstate compacts
press the red button representative
are you getting to the point where
you're going to ask the question
that's a parliamentary enquiry yes if i
know all these things would i then press
representative wallace is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker if i know that the previous two
speakers were not present for the
thank you thank you mr speaker if i know
that the two previous speakers on this
matter were not present for the hearing
on this bill and i know that the
the committee had a bipartisan amendment
to this bill and it passed
by a narrow margin when i now press the
green button
so we can be prepared for this in the
future and keep new hampshire delegates
faithful
the question is on the majority
committee report of octopass with
amendment on house bill 1170. if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
representative
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
173 having voted in the affirmative 162
in the negative the committee reporters
adopted
committee on legislative administration
to which was referred house bill 1309
knack establishing a committee to study
visiting house rules to assure that all
sections of the budget trailer bill
receive an adequate public hearing
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
result that is inexpedient to legislate
the motion before us is the inexpedient
to legislate on house bill 1309 are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
well suppose nay
[Applause]
division has been has been called
members
will stay in their seats nobody can come
in
this is to verify the vote we're not
doing pis or anything
the motion before us is
the inexpensive legislator in house bill
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're imposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
of all
members president had an opportunity to
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
180 voting yeah 154 voting 80 committee
all right the next bill
which will be the last bill before lunch
and we have a couple of announcements
before be so don't leave before the
announcement
this is a
division this will be a division vote
with just parliamentary inquiries
majority of the committee on legislative
administration to which referred house
bill 1370 an act establishing a
committee due to study child care
options for new hampshire state
legislators we can consider the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpensive
to legislate said matthew simon for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass sent allison dunning wong for the
minority of the committee
this is going to be a division vote
the motion before us
is the majority committed report of
inexpedient to legislator on house bill
13-7-0
this is going to be a division vote
the chair recognizes
representative wilhelm for our
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that when it comes
to serving in new hampshire's citizen
legislature which as i hope the members
assembled know
meets during the work day and pays just
a hundred dollars per year
there are significant and unique
challenges faced by parents who wish to
serve in this hallowed chamber and mr
speaker if i know that there is a great
deal of wisdom and a life experience in
this chamber which at the start of the
2021-2022
session had a median age of 61 with
nearly four in five
members over the age of 50 leaving
granite staters in their 20s 30s and 40s
many of whom have young families
significantly underrepresented
and mr speaker if i know that we have
great work to do to live up to dr king's
belief that anyone can be great because
anyone can serve
at least so far as it's concerned in our
citizen legislature then would i now
push the red button so that another
motion can be made and we can consider
taking some simple steps to make it
possible for more working parents to
joe recognized representative shaheen
for a
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that it is not the
responsibility of the general court to
provide child care options for
legislators
lobbyists or visitors
and if i know in addition to the extra
cost and liability to the state
the decision to serve falls exclusively
to the legislator in his or her family
when i press the green button and
support the committee recommendation of
itl
and save us all from yet another study
the motion before us is the majority
committed report of
legislative house bill 1370 this is a
division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppose you press the
red button voting stations are open for
mr speaker
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
187 voting a 153 voting a
we've got i'm going to read a
proclamation
is everybody stay in your seats
and then i'm going to tell you about
lunch and then we have a announcement
whereas in this day march 17th irish
americans celebrate the feast of saint
patrick the patron saint of ireland
whereas on this day all who wear green
partake in the spirit of saint patrick
bridget
and this is a good word
columbil whose 1500th anniversary was
observed within the last year and
whereas
we honor and acknowledge the cultural
influence and contributions of irish
immigrants
who came here and laid down a strong
foundation and called america home
whereas we celebrate the establishment
of the american irish state legislators
caucus with its mission of growing and
strengthening the long-standing
relationship that the united states of
america and ireland have enjoyed
whereas we recognize the rich cultural
history of ireland
celebrated through songs and literature
that mark the endurance of its people
the love and joy and the tragic losses
of the emerald isle
and declare that this house commemorates
the celebration of the feast of saint
patrick
patron saint of ireland
and declared by virtue of my signature
subscribe below the new hampshire house
of representatives does extend its
highest accolades and applaud us to the
american irish state legislators caucus
and their resolve to have this day st
patrick's day remembered as a day of
honor the irish americans their
and probably like a good number of
people in this body i am part irish too
so
the kiwanis club of concord is helping
us by cooking hot dogs and hamburgers
i want you to join me in thanking them
for them for their service and doing
this for us
[Applause]
the general court will be making a
donation to their organization as a
recognition of our thanks in addition to
burgers and hot dogs they'll have
various sides chips and drinks
please make your way outside to the
plaza and form a line
we don't have diamond dining tables
outside but you are free to eat inside
in the cafeteria dining area or anywhere
you'd like in or outside
quarter quarter past one at the latest
and thank thank you again
yeah
thank you again to conquer qantas wait a
minute we got one announcement please
everybody take your seats for a minute
representative walner is is acknowledged
for an announcement
thank you mr speaker and um thank you
for
recognizing the irish i'm a little bit
myself
oh my mask i'm sorry
um i would just like to ask that the
democrats maybe wait a few minutes and
um during the lunch hour we'll wait to
get started
until
we get started on our lunch until
after
we've had a few minutes together
so thank you
members will take your seats the house
the chair recognizes representative
mcguire
the house will come to order
members will take your seats
thank you madam speaker i move that the
gentleman be allowed to remove their
jackets
so moved
the majority of the committee on
municipal and county government to which
was referred house bill 1046
an act relative to the election of the
sullivan county commissioners
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative richard tripp
for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass
representative rosemary rung for the
the chair recognizes representative
tripp to speak in favor of the committee
nope
oh i'm sorry
representative rung to speak against the
committee report
thank you very much madam speaker
hb 1046 is a simple and straightforward
bill brought to the municipal and county
government committee by sullivan county
delegates
it would allow voters in each of the
three districts of sullivan county to be
the only ones
to elect their county commissioner
presently each voter in sullivan county
has a say in who gets elected
to every other county district
even if the voter does not reside in
that district
opponents of this bill
none of whom live in sullivan county
say that it is not clear
difficult to understand
and needs more study
well eight of the ten counties in new
it doesn't make much sense does it
it's an anomaly in new hampshire
elections
only carroll county elects their county
commissioners this way besides sullivan
county but belknap chester
cheshire coast grafton hillsborough
merrimack rockingham and stratford elect
commissioners by district
and only by the voters that reside in
those districts
imagine being elected by voters who
don't even live in your district
and worse
imagining voting for someone who doesn't
even live in your district
this is the reality for the folks
residing in the three districts of
sullivan county
colleagues don't have people elect other
people's representatives
let people elect their own
representative
if eight of the ten counties in new
hampshire can do it
so can sullivan county
please vote no
to expedia to legislate so a motion to
the chair recognizes
the
member from dairy representative tripp
to speak in for the committee report
thank you mr speaker
i rise in support of the committee's
recommendation of inexpedient
to legislate
house bill 1046 seeks to change the
process by which sullivan county
commissioners are elected
for more than 30 years
the county commissioners have been
elected by all the voters in the county
rather than just a district they
represent
it is one of three counties
carroll stafford and sullivan which used
this method
to elect the county commissioners
this bill seeks to limit voters to only
those in the district the commissioner
seeks to represent
during the bill's hearing it was argued
that the commissioners should be elected
only by those they will be representing
it was also mentioned that campaigning
is expensive since they have to do
throughout the county rather than just
within the district
i wonder what the actual reason for
changing from at large the district is
is it representation or the cost of
campaigning
as previously stated carroll county has
been using the at large election
method for more than 30 years
it seems that the at large method for
electing commissioners is preferred by
the voters in this county
if this is the voter's wish then why
should the method of voting be changed
of election be changed
thank you very much and i ask you press
the green button and support the
committee's recommendation of
inexpension and expedient to legislate
okay the motion on the floor is the
majority recommendation of an expedient
to legislate are you ready for the
question
division has been requested members will
this will be a division vote if you are
in favor you will press the green button
if you are opposed you will press
oh wait a minute
first i'm going to recognize
representative band for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you madam speaker and thank you
members of the house if i know that
people ought to be able to vote for
their own representatives and not for
those that do not representative
represent them
and if i know that most of the counties
in new hampshire
use this method
would i now
press
the red
button
so that another motion can be brought
thank you
the chair recognizes representative
mcdonald for pipe pi
thank you madam speaker
madam speaker if i know that hp 1046
would change a long established process
30 plus years of all sullivan county
voters electing their county
commissioners
and madam speaker if i know that the
responsibility of each county
commissioner should be to represent the
best interest of all county residents
and madam speaker if i know that there
are two other counties in new hampshire
in which voters elected county
commissioners the same way as sullivan
county
and madame speaker if i know that the
cost of running a county-wide campaign
should not be reached for changing a
long-established
madam speaker request that everyone
press the green button in order to
support the committee's recommendation
of itl thank you
the question is on the majority
committee report of itl on
hb1046 if you are in favor you will
press the green button if you are
opposed you will press the red button
voting stations will be open for 30
seconds
have all members present had the
opportunity to vote the house will
158 in the affirmative 169 in the
representative wrong moves the minority
report of itl
yes thank you otp
yeah
i'm sorry
thank you madam speaker i move ought to
pass on hb 1046
and i ask for a division vote
this is a division vote members will
this is a division vote the motion on
the floor is the minority report of
ought to pass
if you are in favor you will press the
green button if you are opposed you will
press the red button voting stations
[Music]
have all members present had the
opportunity to vote the house will
192 in the affirmative 141 in the
the majority of the committee on
municipal and county government to which
was referred hb 1070 an act relative to
the default budget
in official ballot jurisdictions having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass representative richard tripp for
the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
julie gilman for the minority of the
committee
the chair recognizes representative
gilman
thank you madam speaker
this bill is yet another manipulation of
the definition of default budgets in
official ballot town meetings
and i know when you hear official town
ballot town meetings your eyes are going
to roll
and the
and when you hear default budget that's
also going to make your eyes roll but
here we are again
the new language includes
less any reduction to an appropriation
the governing body made in the proposed
operating budget
so this will now use three different
budgets to calculate the default budget
for the third fiscal year
fiscal year 22 operating budget and
default budgets are based on fiscal year
21.
do we need more or less of something
have we overspent or underspent
something
the fiscal year 2022 default default
budget is based on the difference
between 21 and 22.
budgets
were 21 and 22 budgets with the
additions and subtractions as specified
in the current rsa
the proposed fiscal year 23 budget and
subsequent default are based on the
operating budget of fiscal year 22.
this bill includes contracts in its
definition of the default budget
calculation
but in fact
the existing rsa there is a definition
of contracts saying that contracts
previously approved in the amount so
approved
are included in the default budget for
example in fiscal year 21 the voters
approved a three-year contract at twenty
thousand dollars per year
during fiscal 20 year 22 a conservative
fiduciary decision offered the
municipality the ability to pay off that
last year of the contract that had been
approved at 20k
for 21 22 and 23.
with this bill the proposed fiscal year
23 and its default budget do not include
that contract appropriation because it
hasn't been because it's been paid off
and is no longer needed in the budget
but the 20k as previously approved
contract included in fiscal year
2023 default budget because the voters
contracted an amount approved in 2021
20k for four-year contract paid off
no longer necessary but is necessary
because that's the definition of
contracts
so the default budget is going to be
twenty thousand dollars more than the
proposed budget
the new language in this bill conflicts
because it requires that change
and and doesn't include the uh money
that we would not have had to
appropriate
there's an approved contract in the
amount so approved but the voters
previously had not
previously had approved it
the circular calculation and confusion
is one of the problems that the minority
had with the
and do not agree with the ought to pass
recommendation and i asked for a
the chair recognizes the member from
litchfield representative boehm to speak
the reason for the municipal budget law
was that towns did not have a facility
big enough to hold regular town or
school district meetings
one town i know it had the tv set up
between
multiple places
so this was passed back i believe 95 and
was initially called sb2 so still
reference to that sb2 towns and it will
only affect those towns that have passed
this and school district this bill is
common sense
if the governing body reduces something
in their proposed operating budget they
must make the same reduction in the
default
the argument about contracts contracts
will be in both
the proposed operating budget and the
default budget so that's not an issue
but
but after a while when the first time it
was passed for the first number of years
the default was always lower
than a proposed operating budget
but after a while certain associations
and lawyers figure out a way by using
the wording of the law to manipulate the
default budget to make it higher than
the operating budget to ensure that the
budget will pass
but that was not the intent of the law
and if you read the section
roman
it's pretty much says it
this is what's got to be on the warrant
shall the local governing body
political self raise an appropriate
operating budget so much and then it
says
should this article be defeated
then the default budget will be this
okay
or the governing body
may hold one special meeting in
accordance with this law to take the
issue of a revised operating budget only
so
if your governing body your selectmen or
your school board
have a higher default budget
and it the
warrant passes are they going to have a
special meeting because they got more
money than they asked for i don't think
so
so that's why they're manipulating the
default to be higher
what school district is going to follow
the law if for example not needing three
teachers they are removed from the
proposed operating budget but left in
the default
of course the default is going to be
higher
if the teacher's contract says they will
fund clubs and sports stipends for say
for twenty thousand but never spent more
than fifteen thousand you guessed that
the proposed operating budget will be
fifteen thousand but the default will be
twenty
on the town side if every other year the
town buys two police cruises but then
then one the next year
guess what the year one will have two in
the default
etcetera it say you know this is not
common sense and
for example in this year in my school
district the proposed operating budget
is 23 million 700 000
the default is 24 million
of course how you people and the people
did vote for the
operating budget because the default was
higher and sometimes they say no and not
realizing that they're spending more
money
so
and like i said before contracts
teachers contract will be an addition
not a reduction
in both contra and both the proposed so
it's not going to be higher because of
that
the default is higher because of
manipulation
a division must be crest requested the
members will take their seats
a roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded yes that is
sufficiently seconded members will take
the question is on the majority report
of ought to pass for hb one zero seven
zero
this is a roll call vote
if you are in favor you will press the
green button if you are opposed you will
press the red button voting stations
oh
the chair recognizes representatives
davis
thank you madam speaker
madam speaker if i know
that hb 1070 conflicts with existing
laws in numerous ways
and if i know that default budgets do
not include previously approved
contracts such as bond agreements
and if i further know that this
oversight concerning contracts and bonds
will result in a tangle of confusion for
towns across the state
would i now press the red button to
defeat the majorities ought to pass
recommendation so that another motion
the chair recognizes representative
lasalles to speak in favor of the
committee report
thank you madam speaker
madam speaker if i know
that when you have an
issue where budgets continually
over and over and over again
year after year
the default budget comes out greater
than the operating budget
how would you feel
if you're on a budget committee
and spend all those time
times
working on the operating budget
and when it comes to this is this is a
pi
my apology
if i know
that we need to stop the kabuki dance
the question is on the majority
committee report of ought to pass for
hb-1070
this is a roll call vote if you are in
favor you will press the green button if
you are opposed you will rest you will
press the
green button the red button
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote the house
well
okay the house will attend to the state
no
have all members present had the
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
with 172 in the affirmative and 162 in
the negative
the majority of the committee on
municipal and county government to which
was referred
hb1081 and act relative to the
dissolution of a village district
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass represent
representative richard tripp for the
majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report that the
following resolution resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate
representative jim maggiore for the
minority of the committee
the chair recognizes representative
wrong to speak against the committee
report
thank you madam speaker
hb 1081
is one of those bills that tricks you
into thinking that an equivalency exists
that an action on one side must be met
with the same action on the other side
in this case that since only a simple
majority is needed to form a village
district
that the right thing to do is to change
the law so that only a simple majority
is needed to dissolve it
with village districts
nothing could be further from the truth
to illustrate my point i will use the
merrimack village district as an example
it's my hometown municipal water
district
it was founded by a simple majority to
supply municipal water to the residents
in merrimack
at the time the vote was taken residents
did not have municipal water
nor did mvd have any assets or capital
nor did it have any employees
it was nothing but a dream to the voters
of merrimack
in fact if that vote had failed
merrimack residents would have been no
worse off than when they were there
before the vote was taken
a simple majority was exactly that
simple
fast forward to today
mvd manages over seven thousand and five
hundred service locations
which is more than eighty seven percent
of the town
these locations include residents
municipal commercial and industrial
properties
nvd services and maintains
approximately 176
miles of water mains
fire hydrants
six wells
three storage tanks an iron and
manganese treatment plant
three booster stations
and a pfast treatment plant with two
more coming online later this year
as you can see
this village district like many others
throughout new hampshire is not simple
mvd's total assets are over 34 million
dollars
if we require two-thirds vote majority
vote
to acquire bonded debt
shouldn't we maintain the same threshold
when we are divesting far greater
holdings
but beyond our fiduciary responsibility
we have a responsibility to the lives of
granite staters
village districts
provide essential
life-dependent resources to our citizens
water
fire and emergency response wastewater
treatment
and a host of other targeted services
making the decision to dissolve those
services from our communities is not
something to be taken lightly
certainly not lighter than a decision to
secure a bond
let's keep the two-thirds vote
requirement to dissolve a village
district let's not change the law when
so much is at stake
please vote no on ought to pass thank
you
the chair recognizes representative
jonathan smith
defeats me speak in favor of the
committee report
thank you madam speaker
hb 1081 really is a simple bill
the purpose is to change the legal
requirement to dissolve a village
district from a two-thirds majority of
legal voters to a simple majority of
legal voters
the simple majority standard is what is
a village district should be no harder
to dissolve than it was to create the
i have had concerns from people asking
if the bill allows non-residents to vote
the answer is no the standard of voting
is like every other election in the
state you must be a legally registered
voter and only those present and voting
are counted that was a court case sugar
hill association versus lisbon 1962.
during testimony i had questions
comparing the bill to a bond
which has a two-third majority
requirement but was lowered to a
three-fifths majority requirement in
2020 by this legislature
the only way to answer answer the
question regarding bonding and village
district is that bonding and dissolving
a village district are entirely two
different subjects
finally the minority blurb indicated
that the municipality would absorb the
cost of the dissolved district which is
not correct
rsa 5221 states clearly the selectmen of
the town or towns in which the district
was situated shall assess the taxes and
betterment assessments in the same
manner
as if the district had not been
dissolved
to close this bill is about fairness to
the voter and i ask you to push green
the question on the floor
is the adoption of the
majority committee report for ought to
pass on hb1081
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested
a roll call has been requested
is that sufficiently seconded
yes that is sufficiently seconded
the house will
the house will come to order
the chair recognizes representative
thank you madam speaker madam speaker if
i know that dissolving a village
district is more than just erasing a
line
and if i know that within the boundaries
or lines of that village district
the residents of that district may have
created their own public safety
departments
may have hired first responders and
employees
may have built wastewater treatment
facilities
may have installed infrastructure such
as sidewalks street lights parks
recreation fields fire hydrants all as
permitted by law
and if i know that this illusion of such
a district would mean that the
surrounding community would then need to
absorb all the costs
for that infrastructure employees
maintenance
and long-term payments
then finally madam speaker if i know
that the dissolution of the test of the
district and said investment should
require a two-thirds majority of voters
rather than a simple majority
then would you please vote red so that
another motion can be made thank you
the chair recognizes representative
jonathan smith for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you madam speaker
if i know that it takes a simple
majority to create a village district
and i also know that it should not be
any harder to dissolve a village
district than it is to create would i
the question is on the majority
committee report about to pass on hb one
zero eight one
this is a roll call vote if you are in
favor you will press
the green button if you are opposed you
will press the red button voting
have all members present had the
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote with 174 members in the
affirmative
and 162 in the negative
the motion
passes
oh did i forget oh
i've never done it up here before so
i'm feeling a little nervous and very
for what purpose does the member rise
uh madam speaker i first wish to say i
think i speak on behalf of the house and
say that we think you're doing a great
job and we appreciate you
but i'd like to be recognized for motion
state your motion
i move hb 1076 be pulled off the table
labor
the motion is to pull house bill 1076
off the table
[Music]
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded that is
sufficiently seconded the members will
the house will come to order
the chair recognizes representative
thank you madam speaker
if i know that the underlying bill
with the otpa motion
seeks to rein in some of the biggest
excesses from big tech
by ensuring that large companies that
use productivity quotas cannot deny
their employees the bathroom breaks that
they are legally entitled to but are
being denied due to a small technicality
that we seek to fix
if i know that this bill thanks to
much much bipartisan cooperation on the
labor committee and weeks and weeks of
negotiations in good faith with the
chair and my friend from manchester
passed and the labor committee deemed it
and if i know those things
and
if i spent this weekend calling my
friends asking them to listen to the
debate
and i want to be sure that there is a
debate for them to listen to would i now
vote green
and allow the bill to come off the table
thank you
the chair recognizes representative
osborne for a parliamentary inquiry
well thank you madam speaker if i know
that i just had the pleasure of
listening to an entire speech on this
bill would i leave this on the table
right now
the question is on pulling
hb
1076 off the table
this is a roll call vote if you are in
favor you will press the green button if
you are opposed you will press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
representatives
[Music]
have all members present had the
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
165 in the affirmative 171 in the
negative
the majority of the committee on
municipal and county government to which
was referred house bill 1087
and act relative to zoning for
single-family housing lots having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
it is inexpedient to legislate
representative joseph guthrie for the
majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report that the
report with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass representative
laurels davis for the minority of the
committee
the chair recognizes
representative van to speak in
thank you madam speaker
and thank you members of the house
i rise to oppose
the inexpedient to a legislate
on this bill because
there's really
no reason
to require
half an acre
or more
for a single family house
served by water and sewer
there's no reason why you couldn't have
one
it's the requiring that's the problem
land costs are a big part
of the cost of a single family house
usually you say it's about 20 percent
so as
people are building houses if i have to
spend
[Music]
a hundred thousand dollars on a lot
i'm gonna have to
build
a bigger
fancier
more expensive house
on that lot
if we want to encourage
the creation of smaller houses at a
lower cost
one thing that we can do
is stop
artificially requiring
big
lots
that's what this bill does it says you
can't require
a large lot
if
it is served by water and sewer which of
course is a big important piece of that
because we all know that you need x
amount of square footage to safely have
a well and septic system
so this only applies to places that have
municipal
water
and sewer
it doesn't preclude people from
buying larger pieces of land
whether they're individuals or
developers it just says
don't require
a really big piece of land
the other thing i'd remind you is that
if you look
at
historic surveys of new hampshire towns
the sanford insurance maps are the most
famous ones
and what you'll see is that
in most town centers the lots are
considerably smaller than a half an acre
when i did the survey for the town i
live in
it looks like our average lot size
in the what you would think of as the
village compact
is about 8 000 square feet
so
this is not an unusual thing to have
a smaller lot
it's a pretty usual thing
and we need to stop requiring bigger
ones
in places where they're not required
please vote red
on the unexpedient legislate
so that another motion can be brought
the chair recognizes representative
dolan
for a motion thank you madam speaker i'd
like to make a motion to table
the motion on the floor is to table
house bill 1087
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it emotion is adopted
the majority of the committee on
municipal and county government to which
was referred house bill 112 fn an act
relative to competitive bidding in
countries having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate representative richard
tripp for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report that with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass representative julie gilman for
the majority of the committee
the question is on the majority
committee report of
itl
are you ready for the question
although a division has been requested
the house will come to order
the chair recognizes representative
maggiore for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you madam chair
if i know that
a very valuable tenant is to treat like
things alike
and that competitive bidding for
community or for counties
would allow us to do that and
competitive and if i know excuse me if i
know
that competitive bidding
is a better guarantee for getting better
pricing and we all want to have the
lowest price available for things that
are very important to our counties
then would i please vote which way do i
want to go
then would i please vote against the
motion so that another motion can be
made plus
red
thank you thank you
madam
the chair recognizes representative
dolan for parliamentary inquiry
thank you madam speaker i'd like to make
madam speaker
if i know that one size fits all
is bad
for dissimilar
entities
and i know that local control is our
means of operation
in this state of new hampshire
the question is on
the majority committee report of itl on
hb112fn
this will be a division vote if you are
in favor you will press the green button
if you are opposed you will press the
red button voting stations are open for
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
with the 175 in the affirmative and 160.
i did
i'm hitting it he closed the vote
he closed the vote okay
so
state state the vote
he closed it he closed it on our end so
it's not we can't show it so this wasn't
with 175 in the affirmative and 163 in
the majority of the committee on
municipal and county government to which
was referred hb 1119 an act relative to
the regulation of single-use bags having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolve that it
is inexpedient to legislate
representative charles melvin
for the majority of the committee the
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment representative
rosemary rung for the minority of the
committee for what purpose does the
member rise
to make a motion madam speaker state
your motion i'd like to make a motion to
table
hb1119
okay the motion on the floor is to table
house bill 1119
question representative byrd has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members will take their
seats
the house will come to order
this is a roll call vote the question is
on house bill one one one nine the
majority report of and i
oh the motion to table
if you are in favor you will press the
green button if you are opposed you will
press the red button voting stations are
with 300 in the affirmative and 35 in
the negative hb1 when 9 is laid upon the
table
to make a motion madam chair please
state your motion
having voted on the prevailing side of
house bill 1087
and
not sure that the vote was
correctly called although not not on
purpose i would
is it table can i can i move to
reconsider
okay so the motion is to reconsider
no
are you ready for the question
okay
the chair recognizes representative
vervo for our parliamentary inquiry
thank you madam speaker
if i know that i voted on the prevailing
side
but i also
believe that the gavel came down quickly
and perhaps
the true will of the body was not
determined
and if i believe that the rightful and
fair thing to do would be to allow the
division vote on the tabling motion
but also madam speaker if i believe
if i know
that i do not support removing this bill
from the table
would i now not press
the shiny
red button
to leave this bill
the chair recognizes representatives
davis for a parliamentary inquiry the
house will be in order
thank you madam speaker i think i hope
i'm doing the right thing here
madam speaker if i know that we are in
the midst of an unprecedented housing
shortage
and if i know that we need housing of
all kinds to alleviate this crisis
if i further know that hp 1087 would
make it easier to build single-family
homes in areas served by public water
and sewer
and if i know that doing so would have
zero impact on the beautiful rural parts
of our state
would i now press the red button to
defeat the majority's inexpedient
to remove it from the table thank you
madam speaker
the question before the house
is removing
hb1087 from the table
if you are in favor you will press the
green button if you are opposed you will
press the red button voting stations are
this
macbeth
have all members present had the
opportunity to vote the house will
166 in the affirmative 169 in the
the majority of the committee on
municipal and county government to which
was referred hb 1172 fn
an act requiring composting and waste
recycling to be made available to
residents of public housing having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill be
referred for interim study
representative ivey van for the majority
of the committee
the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
that the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate
representative tony piamonte for the
minority of the committee
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those oppose nay
the eyes have it and the committee
the majority of the committee on
municipal and county government to which
was referred hb 1177
and act relative to permissible
residential units in a residential zone
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill off to pass representative ivey van
for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee on munici
having considered the same
and being unable to agree with the
majority report with the following
resolution resolve that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
richard tripp for the minority of the
committee
the chair recognizes representative
abrams from some to speak against the
thank you madam speaker
madam speaker i rise in opposition to
the ought to pass motion on house bill
1177 requiring apartment buildings
be added in suburban areas
almost the same bill
came through municipal and county when i
was there and comes through almost every
year this bill
tries to override local control by
forcing our towns and cities to accept
apartment buildings where the voters
have only improved the construction of a
single family house
according to bill quote
these may be configured as a single
four-unit building two duplex units two
single units one duplex unit with two
accessory buildings
four town houses or a single family
house with three accessory dwelling
units
really
but you can't have a duplex a townhouse
and an accessory for each how about a
mini courtyard plus
for three plus a whole mcmansion added
on or two two houses in a hotel on
marvin gardens
will this require the towns except a
four-story high mini skyscraper like
those in downtown manchester near where
i used to live
should even the inner suburbs of
manchester be required by the state
to allow buildings that would only fit
in the busier parts of elm street
and would buildings on elm street be
torn down and replaced with pairs of
duplexes contrary to the intent of the
planners at city hall who put years and
years and years into developing their
city's plan a kind of nightmare on elm
street
towns like
towns like seabrook okay
it wasn't meant to be a joke but i guess
it is
towns like seabrook are already
overloaded with apartment buildings and
most people there are now dead set
against them i used to serve on my
town's planning board and every single
member of my planning board was opposed
should the state override the will of
the voters also
should towns like hampton falls and
hampton be commanded by another top down
one size fits all solution to replace
the suburbs with medium density
apartment buildings over 40 feet high
blocking everyone's view of the water
would you want to see your neighborhood
overbuilt
would you want to explain to angry an
angry planning board and other land use
boards while you've thrown out years of
town planning built around limited
municipal services and staff
to turn everything
into something that looks somewhat like
downtown lawrence
what will we tell our constituents when
we see when they see their property tax
rates nearly double because of the
sudden need to add to police
stations to fire stations another high
school
to serve a state induced surge in
migration and where will already
overworked water departments find more
water and bigger pipes in towns that are
already at their limit
or six million dollars for a new
wastewater treatment facility how will
our emergency rooms and fire departments
deal with a large influx of people
moving up from lynn and lawrence and
north shore mass because thousands of
cheaply built low income stack and pack
or section 8 apartment buildings are
only 10 feet apart sometimes not far
enough apart
for our fire trucks in some of these
small towns this bill is the worst idea
since congress forced us to pay for
giant pink flatulence balloons that cows
have to have strapped on to combat
global warming please press the red
button
for what purpose does the member rise
to make a motion
please state your motion yes i'd like to
make a motion to table this bill
the motion on the floor is to table
house bill
a division vote has been requested
so
uh
a roll call has been requested is that
it's hard to tell that is sufficiently
the house will come to order
the chair recognizes representative
aldisaro for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you madam speaker madam speaker if
i know that this bill allows residential
zone single-family homes be re-zoned in
purposes for up to four residential
units and madam speaker if i know new
hampshire believes in local control and
if i know statewide zoning mandates
creates a one size fits all
and madam speaker if i know many in this
house have invested their hard earned
money and property only to have it
changed by a vote here in the house
would i press the green button and table
his bill
the house will come to order
the chair recognizes representative van
for a parliamentary inquiry thank you
madam speaker
members of the house if i know that new
hampshire is short somewhere between 20
and 30 000 housing units and if i know
that our restrictive zoning is part of
the reason that we cannot build more
units
and if i know
that this bill allows four
four
four units
and if i know that the federal home
administration believes that four units
is a house
would i now vote red
against the tabling motion
so that we can debate this bill thank
you very much
the question is on the tabling motion
for
hb1177 this is a roll call vote if you
are in favor you will press the green
button if you are opposed you will press
the red button voting stations are open
so
have all members present had the
opportunity to vote the house will
167 in the affirmative 157 in the
negative
so
for what reason does a member rise
um i like the remarks i move that the
remarks of the previous debate be added
i move that the remarks of the previous
debate be
entered into the permanent journal
okay so i already heard an objection the
motion is
to print the remarks of the previous
debate in the permanent journal
and a division has been requested
members should probably still be in
bam
all right it's time for members to go to
the question is whether to print the
remarks of the previous debate in the
permanent journal this is a division
okay
so like i said this is to print the
remarks of the previous debate in the
permanent journal if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
so
representative sandler representative
laid
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote
199 having voted in the affirmative 136
and the negative the remarks will be
printed
the majority of the committee on
municipal and county governments which
was referred to house bill 1184 an act
authorizing the establishment of
revolving funds having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is an
expedient to legislate
representative john mcdonald for the
majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative rosemary rung for
the minority of the committee
the question is on the majority
committee report of an expediency
legislate are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
for what reason does remember rise to
make a motion
okay state your motion
mr speaker i move to have house bill
oh yeah we don't have that bill up mr
speaker can you wait a little while for
me to get my head together
i didn't mean that
sorry
all right the majority of the committee
on municipal and county governments
which was referred to house bill 1194
and act relative to the procedure for
overriding a local tax cap having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass representative diane power for
the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
julie gilman for the minority of the
committee
to hopefully improve on my last request
mr speaker mr speaker i make a motion to
place
1194 on the table should you agree
motion is delayed house bill 1194 on the
table
our division has been requested this
will be a division vote members take
who requested a roll call
all right
representative request a roll call and
so
thank you mr speaker
hang on a sec
okay there's a division vote
the motion is delayed house bill 1194
to lay house bill 1194 on the table
representative manages recognized for a
thank you mr speaker
if i know
that this bill will only impact
seven communities out of 280
communities in new hampshire it only
impacts
seven
and we do not need it i would
urge you to press green color of my
jacket
irish luck
representative dolan's recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
i think we've wasted enough time on this
so i'm just going to say that
uh
vote against representative dolan
yes you're recognized for parliamentary
inquiry
if i know
that this bill
that this bill should not come off the
table
not go on the table i'm sorry
when i press the red button
the house will be in order
and that's why we do increase so we can
okay so this is a roll call vote
chile house bill 1194 on the table if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
[Music]
representative kid ridge
so
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
148 in the affirmative 181 and negative
the motion fails
back to the majority committee report
ought to pass
the member from exeter representative
gilman is recognized to speak against
thank you mr chair hang on a sec
the house will be in order so that we
sorry go ahead thank you mr speaker
house bill 1194
proposes a change to the voting process
of a tax cap override in a town or
district that has adopted rsa 32 colon
b-5
the proposed legislation requires a
three-fifth super-majority vote for tax
cap override which is already specified
in rsa 32 colon dash c
used for budget approval
the bill was proposed as a clarification
but is now confusing section b with
section c
further it has an additional change to
include only the first year payment of a
multi-year bond in the cap calculation
disregarding any debt service
and it's not clear what happens after
the initial payment or what may accrue
the following years
capital bonds are voted separately from
operating budgets
in the in the first year and then if
approved are appropriated in the
subsequent operating budgets
a further concern is that the bond
ratings may be affected by the lack of
guaranteed payments that were not
considered with this bill
it is also it also has no provision for
the possibility of rising inflation
this bill is not as clarifying as it
says it wanted to be
it leads to more questions than answers
for these reasons the minority found
this bill inexpedient to legislate and
the member from brookline representative
power is recognized to speak in support
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker i rise in support
of the committee recommendation of ought
to pass on house bill 1194.
year after year new hampshire citizens
are faced with increased local spending
and escalating tax bills
making it extremely difficult for some
to make ends meet in the granite state
house bill 1194 helps to address the
problem of escalating taxes resulting
from unsustainable spending at the local
level
currently a tax cap may be adopted with
a three-fifth super-majority vote by the
legislative body and
with just a simple majority vote the
legislative body can override a tax cap
this bill addresses this problem
since the purpose of a tax cap is to
ensure fiscal responsibility and
prudence in spending
it is therefore reasonable that any
proposed spending which exceeds the tax
cap should
have a higher standard to pass than just
a simple majority
and furthermore since a super majority
is required to adopt a tax cap
then it makes sense that a super
majority should be required to override
a tax cap
requiring a three-fifth super-majority
override will ensure
that any spending that exceeds a tax cap
is both warranted and is supported by
the legislative body
additionally
it is important to note that in this
bill in no way limits the legislative
body's authority
to either increase or decrease the
amount of any single appropriation or
the total amount of all appropriations
in conclusion
this bill
puts teeth
into a toothless tax cap
and it provides an essential tool
for new hampshire taxpayers to more
effectively
manage unsustainable spending and keep
local taxes under control
for these reasons i urge my fellow
colleagues to support
the committee recommendation of ought to
pass
by voting yes on house bill 1194
by pushing the green button
the questions on the majority committee
report of ought to pass are you ready
for the question
uh division has been requested members
take receipts or a roll call who's who
requested a roll call
representative teroshan requests a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded it is
faster we get to our seats faster we can
the questions on the majority committee
report of
ought to pass representative maggiore is
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that this bill is not merely a bill
to create the voting percentage to
create a local tax cap
and if mr speaker if i know that the
additional language in this bill
requires that only the first year
payment on a bond
long-term contract municipal project
capital improvement project are the
numbers that should be used in the
analysis for the tax cap and not the
subsequent years
and if mr speaker if i know that this
bill only applies to seven
out of the 234 municipalities and school
units in new hampshire and that none of
those communities testified about a
problem within their communities and
finally mr speaker if i know that we
should preserve the local authority
that legislative bodies and school
districts need to negotiate their own
prudent funding without any additional
interference from the state than would i
press the red red button to overturn the
otp so that a different motion can be
representative silber is recognized for
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that across the granite state
taxpayers are met year after year
with increasing local budgets in taxes
in towns cities and schools resulting in
constantly escalating tax bills
year after year making it difficult for
our constituents
and their families to make their ends
meet
and mr speaker if i know that local tax
caps have been enacted in many parts of
the state
in an attempt to moderate the increasing
tax burdens on our families
and mr speaker if i know that current
law
enables the voters of a town or district
to adopt a local tax cap
by a three-fifth super majority
but allows the legislative body to
override the tax cap
by but a simple majority vote
and mr speaker if i know that hb 1194
would change the vote to override
a local tax cap
from a simple majority to the same
three-fifths super majority now required
to put the tax cap in plate in the first
place
and if i know that hb 1194 would provide
new hampshire taxpayers
with an important tool
that can enable them to more effectively
manage
unsustainable spending at the local
level in an effort to keep tax increases
at more reasonable
levels
then would i press the bright green
button to approve the otp motion to
all right we're in the voting mode
representatives should have been all
the questions on the majority committee
report about to pass
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
of all members president an opportunity
to vote
the house will attend of the state of
the vote
183 and the affirmative 146 and the
majority of the committee on municipal
and county government to which was
referred house bill 1219 and act
relative to parking requirements for
religious institutional affiliated
housing
development projects having considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolve that it's
inexpedient to
legislate president paul heir for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study
representative eric gallagher from the
representative gallagher waves off
chair recognizer representative mcdonald
question before the house is the
majority report of an expedient to
legislate on house bill one two one nine
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
eyes have it and the majority committee
majority of the committee on municipal
house bill one two two three enact
relative to meeting attendance
requirements for elected members of
budget committee and school board
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that bill be referred
for interim study
senator richard lasallis for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution result that is
inexpedient to legislate senator
rosemary rung for the minority of the
committee
question before the house is the
majority report of refer for interim
study on house bill one two two three
are ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
majority committee on this the house
majority of the committee on municipal
and county government to which was
referred house bill 1268 not limiting
the authority for city council bylaws
and ordinances having considered the
same report the same with the following
amendment and recommendation that bill
ought to pass with amendment senator
richard loseles for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate senator laurel
stavis for the minority of the committee
chair
stavis
colleagues we've seen a version of hb
1268 in a previous session
and we rejected it
i hope you'll agree that we should do so
again
this bill seeks to limit the authority
of city councils
to make certain bylaws and ordinances
a responsibility uh representative
uh could you suspend please uh my
mistake i forgot to do the amendment
first so let me do the amendment and
then
you can start over again
the amendment is 0-6-8-0-h printed in
house record 10-a pages 35-36 question
is on the amendment are you ready for
the question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the ice the ice having an amendment is
adopted
thank you mr
speaker ah so okay we've seen a version
of this bill before and we've rejected
it i hope you'll agree that we should do
so again
it seeks to limit the authority of city
councils to make certain bylaws and
ordinances
a responsibility that the citizens who
elected them expect them to carry out
city councils have brought authority
under rsa 47 17
to regulate activities taking place
within their jurisdictions
hb 1268 proposes to delete a key phrase
from section 15 of that law
that allows municipalities to make any
regulations that
and i quote may seem needful for the
well-being of the city
substituting it with and i quote again
to regulate nuisances that interfere
with the use and enjoyment of one's
property
this is classic government overreach
not only does hb 1268
assume that we in the legislature
know more than the local officials our
citizens elect
it ports forth the notion
that enjoyment property is all that
matters
public health measures
regulations to design protect citizens
and help them thrive those are trivial
and in fact they should be prohibited
this bill as amended
undermines the essence of rsa 4717
which empowers local elected officials
to protect the people they serve
and not just their property
and it subverts existing law further
by preventing city councils from
carrying out the duties they are sworn
to perform
i have no doubt
that all of us in this chamber are very
wise
but are we better equipped to know at
the local level
what citizens in the 13 cities across
our state want
i really don't think so
and that is why they chose some of us to
serve at the state level
while expecting the counselors they
elected locally to understand their
needs and ensure their safety
i urge you to vote itl yet again on this
newest version of state house overreach
we're down to our last speaker
xenoblasic has requested a roll call is
that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded
this is going to be a roll call vote
members take your seats
chair recognizes harvey bolio speak for
thank you mr speaker
this bill is simple it fixes vague
language about what kinds of health
bylaws
city councils may pass
it inserts a definition about public
health nuisances into the statute to
clear up vagaries
it only pertains to one sentence in the
miscellaneous section about city council
bylaws not the whole chapter
the definition was developed by the new
hampshire public health nuisance task
force to address this sometimes
confusing subject matter
it leaves intact the broad authority
that city councils have enjoyed to make
local issue bylaws
it covers everything from septic codes
to mosquito control
everything
that is a local issue
but it ensures that broader public
health issues
will be addressed by the state
please support the committee
recommendation and vote green
the motion before us the majority report
of water passes amended on house bill
1268 this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative magliore
wait a minute mr representative
sorry go ahead
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that this bill
creates government overreach by limiting
the local control so crucial to each and
every city council and if mr speaker i
know that the current statutory language
which is
make any bylaws or ordinance which may
seem for the well-being of the city
has served our cities well
and that the
limiting language to be amended would
limit the statute to the enjoyment of
property
and mr speaker if i know that the
current statute ensures that local
elected officials in our cities are
empowered to protect
all the people that they serve and not
just their property that mr speaker
would i vote red on the current motion
so that a different motion can be made
thank you mr speaker
jerick and i as representative dolan for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this bill as amended
clarifies and better defines how city
councils make laws
and if i know that dhhs is best staffed
with expertise
to lead state efforts regarding
communicable diseases
and if i know
a city by city approach would create a
confusing patchwork of differing laws
then would i not press the green button
the motion before us is the majority
report of auto passes amended on house
bill one two six eight
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your post you press the
red button voting stations are open for
so
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
176 voting yay 156 voting a committee
jury of the committee on municipal and
county government which was referred
house bill 1289 and act relative to
applications for abatements and
authority to abate prior year taxes for
certain homeowners considered the same
report the same the recommendation that
the bill be referred for interim study
senate rosemary run for the majority of
the committee
minority of the committee ever
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator joseph
guthrie from the minority of the
committee
motion before us is majority committed
reporter refer for interim study are
ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
also paul's nay
the ice habit committee report is
adopted
majority committee on the municipal and
county government which was referred
house bill 1307 an act modifying the
authority and duties of the housing
appeals board considered the same report
the same the recommendation that bill
ought to pass it's in a richard trip for
the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution result that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
ivy van from the minority of the
committee chair recognizes
representative
van
thank you mr speaker thank you members
of the house
this bill seeks to change the rules
under which the housing appeals board
does its
work
and i am
asking you
not to support the committee report
because the housing appeals board has
only been in operation for about two
years
and so far
it looks like it's working okay
what this bill does is say that
some
local
land some local boards
and elected officials
shall not be considered
when you're when the housing appeals
board is looking at whether to
approve or not approve an appeal
and while it seems sensible that maybe
only
the planning board and the zba should be
part of that
since
boards have to do with
whether roads are open and closed and
what
classification roads have and road
classification does in fact affect how
land use can be done
so i would respectfully ask you for that
reason to vote against the ought to pass
so that all of the boards and elected
officials
that and appointed officials that have
to do with decisions
concerning land use may continue
to be part of the housing appeals board
process thank you chair reckon as
thank you mr speaker
as you've heard this bill relates to the
housing appeals board h.a.b the have
board it was formed sort of like the
board of tax and land appeals it's a
three-person board appointed supposed to
be people of expertise in the area and
it's to provide an avenue for appeal
from local decisions
this board is a lesson in legislative
experience much like committees getting
a bill and having it be in their
jurisdiction the h.a.b board was
actually created in 2019
in what some people referred to as the
christmas tree bill
hb2
it was a bill that has tried to meander
its way through the legislative process
one body to the other body to a
signature but didn't quite make it
and sort of like the christmas tree that
has unexpected presence under it it
reappeared
in the how in the hb2 was a bill that
ultimately was passed without following
what some argue is the typical
legislative process
as stated this board is relatively new
but i would suggest to you that waiting
for something we create to go bad to fix
it is not a reason to not address it
today
since the housing appeals board was
formed there have actually been 15 at
least at the time the committee
considered it 15 bills that were
considered by this which are appeals
from your local boards and
as also suggested it has included an
appeal from the board of selectmen even
though an appeal from the board of
selectmen was not ever listed
in the jurisdiction of this board when
the bill was adopted
what was listed in the jurisdiction of
bills
of for the board when this was adopted
was a non-exclusive list
of things that do not include
development of land
so what it is it was authorized by
statute to do was to hear appeals of
fines ordinances
and things that were never
expressed as the purpose of the housing
appeals board
what this bill does
is put the housing appeals board in a
position where its authority is clearly
delineated to those decisions in your
localities that deal with the approval
of development of land that's what it
was intended to do and i ask that you
approve the bill so it is what it can
motion before is the majority report of
our past house bill 1307 you're ready
for the question
all those in favor say aye
you guys have it committee report is
adopted
majority committee on municipal and
county government to which was referred
house bill 1342
act relative to municipal charter
provisions for tax caps having
considered the same report the same the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass senator patricia keel for the
majority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution that it isn't
expedient to legislate president richard
tripp from the minority of the committee
chair recognizes representative
power
okay the chair recognizes representative
weiler
thank you mr chairman
thank you mr speaker excuse me
i rise to oppose the passage of house
bill 1342.
sometimes the people we elect to our
governing boards get impressed
with all the demands of government
when most of the voices they hear
they are listening to are all saying
spend spend spend
so we allowed the taxpayers to vote in
spending caps
a landmark decision on manchester
spending led to the passage of a 2011
law to put in law guidance on spending
caps that had been passed locally
the law stated and i quote
all town or city charters which have
been adopted revised or amended to
include a tax or spending cap of any
kind and all charter commissions which
have been properly established and
elected all elections properly held in
all actions properly taken related to
the tax or spending cap and such
charters are hereby endorsed ratified
validated and legalized and are fully
enforceable without regard to whether
such entities or actions were authorized
by law at the time they were established
or taken
when enacted some of the spending caps
included an override clause but
not all of them did
so those are left without that control
thus we see
house bill 1342
it was filed to benefit nashua
because when their spending cap was
passed there was no section to provide
for a super majority override
in order to
override the nashua budget now it would
take a charter commission to place the
override language therein
a charter commission by the legal
procedure
takes about two years
nashua wants their representatives to
pass this law so they can do it in less
time
although many of the municipal and
county government
committee seem to sympathize with that
intent this bill before us has
unintended consequences as it was
written
i see that it eliminates provisions in
an earlier law that would have protected
previous actions it eliminates some of
the language in the paragraph i just
read in quotation marks
it would remove the necessity for an
annual
municipal budget super majority vote in
order to exclude interest and principle
on municipal bonded debt or capital
expenditure to outside the limit of the
capped budget it would remove the
necessity of an annual municipal budget
super majority vote in order for an
ordinance or accounting practice to
redistribute budget items from within
the limits of the cap budget most
importantly
this bill would eliminate the crucial
provisions signed into law just last
year
that grandfather tax and spending caps
enacted before july 5th 2011
that would be eliminated thus
jeopardizing municipal charter tax and
spending caps across the state
unintended consequences
could affect your municipal budget while
narrowly focusing on nashua's problem to
fix one problem we should not jeopardize
the situation of perhaps many other
places this bill has flaws rather than
having to come back next time to fix
them let's just reverse this octopass
and make the bill inexpedient to
legislate
chair representatives representative
thank you mr speaker happy st patrick's
day to you and to all my colleagues
uh what's before us this afternoon is uh
house bill 13 uh
and it is kind of in an indirect way a
rebuttal to senate bill 52
if
the representative if i listen to his
debate
and he says well how things came in well
senate bill
52 instead of taking the freight
elevator it definitely took the express
elevator
okay the right way to have done this
was to have something brought up as on a
referendum within the city budget as
a city ballot but that wasn't done
instead it came in via a back door
with a senator
and thus here we are so whenever
anything comes in the back door
does it really
solve a hundred percent of the problem
the answer is usually not
okay so in this particular case
nashua yes is seeking resolve now i
understand and i don't want you some of
my good friends and colleagues to be
rolling your eyes sort of like an old
episode of the brady bunch where jan
goes up and says masha masha maja
and here's ob down at duelgo in nashua
but this is a truly legitimate problem
for the citizens of nashua
what's at hand here if there is some
dire emergency
nashville may need a mechanism
to override the cap on a particular
issue
so i arise today to urge you
and i would also like to say in our
existing charter there is our it is
already codified
that we do have a super majority it's in
the charter
so i rise today to urge you to support
1342 with a positive recommendation of
what to pass
this bill would allow the citizens of
nashua the same fiscal rights
enjoyed by many of your same communities
if you have in your community a spending
cap you probably do have some overripe
vision in it
all nashville wants to do in this
particular bill is to be treated fairly
you remember
i previously came last year and came
before you on senate bill 52 which was
discussed by this body at that time i
spoke 52 was flawed and created problems
again as i reiterated earlier
having this without an override is one
of the problems
this does not harm senate bill 52
as a matter of fact it enhances it
by enhancing it
it will basically allow the override
position now how do we get here from
nashua this was tried and true the
supreme court ruled down the spending
cap till we can have the override
position put into it
why is this override provision needed
well many of you will they'll wear two
hats like i do i'm uh alderman in the
city now sure and maybe some of you
besides being the same rep are in the
same boat
you know that sometimes murphy speaking
in the same party say murphy's law what
can go wrong will
maybe a wall might fall on your fire
truck or something might happen and at
times you might need a remedy to go
above the cap
so by allowing nashua to have this will
allow them to address those particular
issues
in essence senate house bill 1342 does
not in any form like they say try to
harm
senate bill 52.
so therefore
there is further president on this and i
want to bring up that
rsa49c semicolon 33
the letter i
parentheses d
and i don't want to bore you
but i'll limit on the annual spending
increases that increases the amount
raised by taxes on the city budget
adopted pursuant to rsa 49 dash c23
such a cap shall provide for an override
threshold on a vote to exceed the normal
annual increase which shall be a
supermajority as determined by the
charter a tax cap in the provision of a
city charter may provide for
specific conclusions so i don't think
you want me to go on with the whole
thing
but i think you can believe me on
exactly what i say it's right in near
the rsa
so i'm asking you
to be a little bit friendly nashua has a
little bit of an issue i know it's the
only
we're the only city or town
that has this particular issue
so i'm asking for your grace
that you will come up and support the
citizens of nashua in uh by
passing house bill 1342
and to allow the right that evidently
was wrong to allow the city of nashville
which was a stand-alone municipality
with no override provision
and to become part of it just like
manchester which is similar in size to
us
and they have the override as well
so i'm asking for fair treatment thank
the motion before us majority committee
report have ought to pass on house bill
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested members
will take their seats this will be a
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us
is the majority report of ought to pass
on house bill 1342
this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative power
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know today is st
patrick's day and shamrocks are green
would i then oppose the committee
recommendation
of ought to pass by pressing the red
button so that another motion can be
made thank you mr speaker
geo recognizes representative van for
parliamentary degree
also be in order
thank you mr speaker thank you members
of the house if i know that this bill
corrects
an oversight and puts
our second largest city on the same
footing as other places
would i now press the green button
and support
the committee recommendation of ought to
pass
the motion before us is majority
committee report of ought to pass on
house bill one three four two this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if your opposed
to press the red button voting stations
[Music]
while members president had an
opportunity to vote
157 voting
yay 181 voting a
representative weiler moves
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
the eyes have it and the committee
majority of the committee on municipal
and county government to which was
referred house bill 1393 enact relative
to the adoption of school district
budget caps
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass so die in power for the majority
minority of the committee haven't
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority
report with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate
representative jim magliori for the
minority of the committee
the motion before us is the
majority report of ought to pass are you
ready for the question all those in
favor
what reason does it memorize
to make a motion
state your motion i moved to table house
bill 1393
that is a
proper motion
the motion before us is to table
house
bill
1393. a division has been requested
members will take their seats this will
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
[Music]
the house will come to order
the motion before us is the table
on house bill
1393.
mag magiwari
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that this bill as it's drafted will
create a mandate
throughout the state that it's going to
be confusing for every municipality then
would i now press the green button to
place this bill on the table thank you
chair recognizes representative osborne
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i am
very concerned tonight about out of
control spending and ever escalating
property taxes and i know that this bill
will help us do something about that
the motion before us is the tabling
motion on house bill 1393
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppose you press the
red button voting stations are open for
so
while members president had an
opportunity to vote
164 voting a 178 voting a the tabling
we're back to the question of ought to
pass
the majority committee report of house
bill 1393
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
you guys have it the committee report is
adopted
the chair recognizes the clerk thank you
mr speaker several members uh we're just
asking at the bottom of page 80 of the
calendar um it appears house bill 1387
as i sent an email to all members last
week uh that was innova inadvertently
printed in the calendar was acted on
last week so please pardon our our
i also come to order
the majority of the committee on
municipal and county governments which
was referred to house bill 1667 an act
relative to the standard and optional
veterans tax credits and the
all veterans tax credit having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass representative diane power for
the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolve that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
patricia cleave for the minority of the
committee
the member from nashua representative
clee is recognized to speak against the
thank you mr speaker
colleagues i have to admit as a person
who's worked with the military veterans
since i was 18 years old who's worked
with department of defense department of
veterans affairs
for me to speak against anything that
would limit any person from a military
background veteran or active duty
getting any extra benefit puts a dagger
into my heart
but the truth is we have to look at the
big picture
and we have to be honest that in the end
this is a tax shifting bill
it shifts the tax burden from one group
of individuals to another group of
individuals
the broadened definition will only add
more to the pool who qualify for the
veterans credits and exemptions
i agree we should do everything that we
can to take to thank those
that have and are serving our country in
keeping us safe but doing so at the
expense of others doesn't make us the
good guys
while serving on state federal relations
and veterans affairs there were a number
of bills brought to create equity
between title 38 veterans benefits us
code 101 definitions
often referred to as usc 101
meaning the definitions
of veterans and what is a veteran as
well as what is active duty as per usc
101 a veteran by definition is a person
who served
in the active military naval or air
service and who was discharged or
released there from
under conditions other than dishonorable
the key word here is served not serving
as i already stated but bears repeating
if we were to change the definition
for the purpose of credits and
exemptions we're adding to the pool of
those who qualify for these credits and
exemptions
in 2020 based on the department of
revenue
the dra
reports the the state of new hampshire
through the municipalities granted 31
million
seven hundred and seventy five thousand
six hundred and thirty seven
dollars in tax relief
to fifty four thousand six hundred and
fifty four
veterans and or families
in a nutshell
those who do not qualify for these
exemptions and credits share in what is
often referred to as lost taxes
meaning their taxes go up to cover these
lost taxes
it should be noted that the veterans tax
credit exemption program is enabling
and will remain that way even if this
passes but
and this is a big but
when each municipality designed their
program they based it on what they felt
their residents could or would bear
someone else chose not to grant any
veterans credits exemptions and others
have given
high amounts and others not quite so
much
i stated that in 2020 in the state of
new hampshire municipalities granted
almost 32 million in tax relief just to
veterans and their families
these are small communities i'm sorry
there are small communities who don't
grant any
and some that grant as little as an
overall amount of only fifty dollars and
then there are those larger communities
cited in the minority report they
granted credits exemptions in excess of
1.5 million dollars
communities such as those in the area of
peace and those communities that border
the state to our south will have the
largest impact
based on 2020 figures of active duty and
reservists here in new hampshire there's
potential an increase of the pool by an
additional 10 percent who will qualify
again shifting the burden to other
property owners who do not qualify
in the end isn't a new tax shift of any
form an increase in taxes
and isn't the state of new hampshire all
about little to no taxes
i'm not going to throw around the cliche
that is often spoken in this chamber
relative to taxes but i know that i
can't ask those already struggling in my
city to pick up an additional burden can
you
the only way to eliminate that burden
would be to either one
lessen the amount granted for a credit
or two completely the eliminate the
credit exemption in that community
personally i don't see the latter
happening but i do believe it's
conceivable for larger communities to
reduce what they currently grant
if that happens once again we are
increasing the tax burden of those
veterans
who are getting the credit slash
exemptions
this is a very hard catch 22 in that
passing this legislation will hurt one
group or another or multiple groups
this is not a political fight
rather it's a fight to not burden those
already held down by taxes just to say
look how we helped one very important
population
i have to ask
can we do so on the backs of the
remaining property owners
again i'm going to repeat something to
help make it clear so that we all
understand the situation you'll hear
from others that veterans tax credit is
enabling and yes it is
however
if you implement it or have done so you
must do so in its entirety
you can't say this group or that group
you have to do it all exactly as the
legislation says
you can set the amount that you give as
long as you stay within the minimum and
maximum set by this very body
this means that some municipalities have
veterans tax credits
exemptions while others have a credit as
low as the minimum of fifty dollars and
others as high as the maximum of seven
hundred and fifty dollars
some may say this doesn't cost the state
of the municipality a single dime
they're one hundred percent right it
doesn't take a toll on either budget
however
it does hit the wallets of those
who this does not apply to
as my mom taught me
stealing from peter to pay paul
and patting ourselves on the back
because we helped veterans doesn't make
us better people
let's continue to use the definition
provided by title 38 usc 101 relative to
veterans as those who have served and
not broadened the definition here
those that argue in favor of this bill
may say this is just a housekeeping bill
to bring one state statute into the
other in line with another
while there may be another new hampshire
statute that defines a veteran to
include active duty etc perhaps we need
to examine why
and if necessary bring that statute into
alignment
and the veterans benefit title 38 usc
101's definition of a veteran as a
person who served and not serving
remember unintended consequences a
broadened definition for a veteran that
puts us in conflict with the federal
definition of a veteran only puts a
burden on those pools of property owners
who don't qualify
this body does everything that we can to
keep taxes low and we do that do what we
can to maintain equity throughout our
state
this is a simple tax shift to those who
don't qualify
i hope that you will join me in over
overturning the ought to pass of this
tax shifting bill so that another motion
can be made and thank you so much for
the member from brookline representative
power is recognized to speak in favor of
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker i rise in support of the
committee recommendation of ought to
pass on house bill
1667.
in 1871 after the civil civil war the
first veterans tax credit was signed
into law in new hampshire
over the past 150 years a number of
statutory changes have been made to
include the latest armed conflicts
the definition of a veteran
and to include certain certain national
guardsmen and reservists
new hampshire law clearly defines a
veteran as any person who has served in
the armed forces for more than four
years and
continues to serve or
who has been honorably discharged or has
received an uncharacterized discharge
based on a service-connected injury
illness or disability
due to the discrepancy between this
definition of a veteran and the veterans
tax credit statutes
some military veterans are wrongly
excluded from receiving any of the
veterans tax credits
and ironically the all veterans tax
credit does not include all veterans
recognized under new hampshire law
house bill 1667
addresses these inconsistencies
first this bill amends the language in
the veterans tax credit
statutes to include
those veterans still serving
consistent with the statutory definition
of a veteran
and second
this bill removes the title 10 prefix
from the veterans tax credits language
so that title 10
title 32 and title 14 active service
all qualify for the 90-day requirement
lastly
it is important to note
that less than half a percent
of americans currently serve in our
armed forces
therefore
the claim that these changes will create
an undue tax burden is over exaggerated
and furthermore the dollar amount that
my colleague quoted
pertains
a large percentage to disabled veterans
in conclusion
this bill clarifies that all veterans of
the united states armed forces who
served in any active duty status
regardless of the title
or the branch of military that they
served in as well as those who continue
to serve
qualify for the veterans tax credits
for these reasons i urge my fellow
colleagues to support
the committee recommendation of ought to
pass by voting yay on house bill 1667
by pushing the green button
the house will be in order
representative baldur requests a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members please take
so
um
i also come to order members please take
and while i have you all here quick
reminder
when someone's speaking at the well
please use any other aisle
if you need that aisle to get to your
seat
it should be done in a minute or two
maybe wait but if you have to come down
here for anything for example someone's
at that well use one of the other aisles
please
representative stavis is recognized for
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that the expanded
definition of a veteran proposed in this
bill
conflicts with the definition of
veterans under federal law
and if i know that new hampshire towns
and cities already provide generous
support to veterans their spouses and
children
granting more than 32 million dollars in
2020 alone
and if i know
that this bill will shift tax burdens
from one group to another
something we really don't want to do
resulting in significant property tax
increases for those who do not qualify
would i now press the red button to
defeat the majorities ought to pass
recommendation so that another motion
can be made thank you mr speaker
representative edwards is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
uh thank you mr speaker
if if i know from my 33 years of serving
in all components of the army
that
my 10 years of active duty
was spent on hardship tours
in monterey california san antonio texas
the university of southern california
and seoul korea
but
that my two tours
of being called recalled to active duty
as a guardsman or a res or a reservist i
i deployed to afghanistan
and got shot at four times
i never got shot at on active duty
and so as we look dispassionately
if i know
that as we look dispassionately at these
definitions
the way the current
tax code is written
discriminates against the guardsmen and
the reservists
who
after 20 years of a land war
in the middle east
have probably seen as much combat duty
as most active duty people
so if i knew
that this wasn't about money because if
it's about money we can reduce the money
later
if this is if i knew that this was about
equity
wouldn't i
treat our guardsmen and our reservists
sacrificed by deploying away from their
families
only to be subjected to the same death
and injury that an active duty soldier
would
and if i knew all of that wouldn't i
the house will be in order
the question is on the majority
committee report of ought to pass on
house bill
1667 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
representative
of all members president an opportunity
to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
205 in the affirmative 127 and the
for what risen doesn't remember us i'd
like to make a motion
okay
i'd like to i'd like to take 11.77
off the table
and i'd like to speak to my motion
now
removed
okay
the motion is to remove house bill 1177
okay there we go i knew there'd be one
of those
who was that
and it is sufficiently second this will
be a roll
the call
mcguire
all right
all right this is a roll call vote the
motion is removed house bill 1177 from
the table representative bolio is
recognized for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know
that affordable housing is important
to the republicans for the republicans
in this room and the democrats and the
entire state if i know that i just spoke
with the public policy director of the
bia
and the bia
prior one of its priorities is
affordable housing
would i now
press
the green button to take this off the
representative osborne is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
so if i do know
that the affordability of housing is
probably the most critical issue that we
face today
but i also know that i already voted
against putting this bill on the table
once i voted to take it off the table
once
would i now
the motion is to remove house bill 1177
from the table
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
of all members president an opportunity
to vote
thou shall attend the state of the vote
159 on the affirmative 176 and the
the committee on public works and
highways which was referred house bill
prohibiting the use of state funds for
representative graham moves ought to
pass
for what reason does a member rise
mr speaker i arise for a motion
okay state your motion my motion is the
table
representative o'brien moves that house
bill 1432 be laid on the table
thank you mr speaker m.a.i mr speaker
requester
uh
alrighty representative o'brien moves
that house bill 1432 be laid on the
table
and requests a roll call vote is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members please take
all right members should be in their
this is a roll call vote the motion of
delay house bill 1432 on the table
representative o'brien is recognized for
a parliamentary inquiry
i'm sorry representative query is
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that the committee
members who support and expedient to
legislate believe this bill is premature
and if i know that the new hampshire
d.o.t was authorized to conduct a
project development phase for the
proposed capital corridor under the
state's 10-year transportation plan
entirely paid for with federal
transportation funds no state money and
if this bill passes could potentially
leave us on the hook for an unknown sum
and if i know that when completed next
year the project development will give
the legislature a clearer picture of the
total costs in the legislature's
legislators in the next term can debate
those costs on and where the funding
should or should not come from
and if i further know that manchester is
the economic driver of the state and
that this project will come right
through my district of manchester's ward
9 bringing with it the opportunities of
private public partnerships and
boundless new business ventures for
residents of manchester nashua bedford
and countless other surrounding
communities then would i now press the
green button to table this premature
legislation
representative graham is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker mr speaker if i've learned
anything of the two decades up here that
sometimes it's nice to listen to the
opposition before you vote against their
position
and
if i know that the debate on this bill
will be one-on-one and very short
and that you should listen to both sides
since it is without recommendation
and if i truly believe that the ought to
pass position will prevail in this body
when i now press the red button and keep
this off of the table thank you mr
speaker
the question is whether the lay house
bill 1432 on the table this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor
your house will be in order if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
of all members president an opportunity
to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
152 in the affirmative 182 and the
negative the motion fails
we're back to the motion of ought to
pass
the member from nashua representative
jack is recognized to speak against the
motion
thank you mr speaker
i rise in opposition to the ought to
pass motion
the federal transit administration has
an established process that we are
following step one is the alternatives
analysis that was completed in 2014.
it evaluated seven bus and rail
alternatives including doing nothing to
develop ridership estimates economic
benefit estimates and cost estimates the
best cost benefit was achieved by
extension of the mbta lowell line to
manchester on the existing freight line
step two is the project development
phase that was funded in 2019 by sb 241
an identical language in that year's
budget hb4
this phase does enough engineering to
determine a firm project cost
completes environmental permitting and
produces a financial plan
to suggest how capital and operating
costs could be covered it is on track to
be completed later this year
the source of funds is federal transit
administration funds already in the
state's possession matched with toll
credits it is important to note this
pool of money can only be spent on
transit and only in the boston urbanized
area the state receives a new allocation
every year and using this funding is not
starving any other project
with these two steps complete a future
legislature could decide to apply for a
competitive construction grant under the
new starts program after what i am sure
would be a full and vigorous debate on
the financial plan
nothing in what we have done so far
obligates the state to proceed to
construction or to repay any of the
federal funds that have been used
amtrak operates the downeaster from
boston into maine and the vermonter that
crosses into new hampshire to make a
stop in claremont these are not using
state funds at this time but they may
may wish to in the future
knowing all of this we can see that the
bill does nothing to advance the
intention to stop the capital corridor
project since no state funds are being
used there is strong public support for
commuter rail i looked at a poll over
the weekend that was over 70 percent in
support
not having rail makes it more difficult
for employers to attract workers some of
those workers might be
the cryptocurrency developers that we
heard about on tuesday
passing this bill would send a terrible
message about how willing the
legislature is to listen to its citizens
and businesses
we avoid appropriating funds outside of
the budget cycle and it is equally wrong
to pass a bill that would restrict the
use of funds outside of the budget cycle
i encourage members to join me in
pressing the red button it is
hang on
it's super noisy in here and can
sorry about that please continue
i encourage members to join me in
pressing the red button to defeat the
ought to pass motion so another motion
hopefully they're not too comfy out
the member from bedford representative
graham is recognized to speak in favor
of the motion
he's the last speaker
i'd be shocked if this was
they've already asked for division vote
on this so members should start
migrating back
quietly please um thank you mr speaker
i rise in support of the ought to pass
motion
on h.b
1432. let's talk about this for a little
bit
it is not whether or not passenger rail
is going to come to new hampshire
that is a policy decision for another
day
it is not about
private public partnerships with the
political subdivisions of the state that
is their decision to make in the future
it is also unfortunately
not about ancillary costs to
municipalities
in any rail corridor
and there will be some if this is ever
built
it is not about stopping the ongoing
project development plan for the capital
uh rail corridor project
that is being done with federal monies
and is well underway with a report date
for that
study in early 2023
we have some preliminary reports from it
but nothing that that really indicates
what it's going to cost
this
report
will cover cons what it costs for
construction
operating
maintenance
whatever else is needed
to include if we have to
put down
new rail or anything else
and it will also address funding sources
to pay for all of this which will in
probability taking in total be in the
hundreds of millions of dollars
what it is is a statement that the state
of new hampshire
will not
be used as the piggy bank for passenger
rail service
what this bill does is clearly tell
those making the recommendations on
funding
that the state of new hampshire
will not be providing the funds
it will also clearly
make clear
to the department of transportation
that when they come in within this
project that they're going to have to
have funding sources outside of state
monies
i ask for your support and not to pass
so that we have a position to lay down
in front of this
project development phase and in front
of the commissioner of d.o.t
that if we are going to do passenger
rail service anywhere in the state
that it will not be done
with new hampshire funds and i ask that
you uh support the
uh to pass motion i was going to say the
majority but it was without
recommendation
so please
support ought to pass and i thank you mr
speaker
well only one of you can request the
representative
request a roll call and it's already
well seconded this will be a roll call
vote
so
all right the house will be in order
the motion is out to pass on house bill
1432 this is a roll call vote
representative clutier is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker fellow house
members
if i
know according to a 2019
poll conducted by a new hampshire
business publication that 75 percent of
our state's residents support bringing
passenger rail to southern new hampshire
and if i believe this bill is premature
because now the project development
phase of the proposed capital corridor
rail line is being done using federal
funds
and in in a phase that will be complete
should be completed in 2023
then the next term those of us who
return next term
will have a chance to debate how we pay
for this project which may or may not
include state funds
and finally if i know
that if let's say this bill were to pass
and become law
a future legislature could easily repeal
it next term or later because
no
current legislature can ever bind future
legislatures in this or other policy
matters would i now press the red button
and oppose the ought to pass
representative mcconkey is recognized
thank you mr
speaker mr speaker if i know no
passenger rail service in the world
operates without extensive public
subsidies
and
i know nothing in this bill prohibits
any political subdivision of the state
such as manchester or nashua from
entering into public private
partnerships and further mr speaker
if i know there is an ongoing project
development phase for a rail service
project
funded entirely with federal funds
and this bill is providing clear notice
no state funds will be used would i now
press the green button and pass house
bill 1432
house will be in order this is a roll
call vote
if you are in favor of octopass you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
station
so
representative
have all members president an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
187 in the affirmative 144 and the
the majority of the committee on public
works and highways to which was referred
house bill 2022
an act relative to the 10-year
transportation plan
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with amendment
representative john graham for the
majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment representative bill
the majority amendment is zero seven
four five h printed in house record 10 a
on pages 91 to 93. the question is on
the amendment are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it
and the amendment is adopted the bill's
on second reading and open a further
amendment
representative boyd moves amendment zero
eight five nine h
also printed in house record santa a on
thank you mr speaker and through you mr
speaker to my
esteemed colleagues of the general court
i rise in support of my minority
amendment to house bill 2022 the state
10-year plan
the state of new hampshire has 259
cities towns and unincorporated places
within its borders
the state department of transportation
maintains over 17 000 miles of roads
within its borders
house bill
2022 as presented wants to give back 2.5
miles of state roadway back to the town
of merrimack currently known as
continental boulevard
we don't want it
this road came about in 1993 when the
d.o.t acquired lands through eminent
domain proceedings to build the road
the town of merrimack back then argued
against eminent domain proceedings for
continental boulevard but the d.o.t
prevailed arguing that public necessity
for the use of private property for this
stretch of road was needed by the public
in the region for the greater good
some thirty odd years later continental
boulevard continues to serve
as a primary arterial connection for
route 101a running west to east from
milford to nashua
to the fever turnpike at exits 10-11 and
daniel webster highway us-3
this connection carries more than 17 000
vehicles per day many of which are from
surrounding communities
more than 10 000 of those vehicles can
be found in traffic counts along
industrial drive and continental
boulevard
the traffic volumes on the state section
of continental boulevard exceed those of
any merrimack public road
including the urban compact section of
daniel webster highway that carries a
traffic volume of 14 550 cars daily
the demand for a high level of service
will be constant as this roadway remains
a critical part of the state's
infrastructure as a primary artery
between the major east-west
and north-south route in southern new
hampshire region
now the argument is being made that the
stretch of roadway is no longer
needed as a public necessity to the
state
d.o.t seeks to abdicate its ownership
from a roadway it richly wanted back in
1993.
the town's absorption of this roadway to
our town's budget is an additional 200
000 annually with potential long-term
capital costs exceeding 2.5 million
dollars over the next 20 years
and that's infrastructure not including
staffing equipment and other ancillary
components necessary to maintain the
roadway
furthermore the road
the town also gets the roadway in its
supporting infrastructure
as is
no caveat emptor
just the town being gifted a piece of
infrastructure that the town didn't want
in 1993 and still doesn't want today
as you deliberate this amendment please
consider that this application of
content at the boulevard by the d.o.t to
the town of merrimack
could also happen in your community
if you agree with me then please press
the green button
to ensure that the d.o.t remains
committed and engaged to maintain the
roads and the highways it has been
entrusted to oversee mr speaker through
you i thank my colleagues for listening
to me today i sincerely ask for a
division vote and i do yield for
thank you mr steve speaker and thank you
representative for taking the question
would you believe that i agree with you
100 percent and i'll be voting green and
i thank the gentlelady for agreeing with
me
thank you mr speaker and thank you
representative for checking my question
um representative how much would this
cost the town of merrimack to repave the
i thank the gentlelady for the question
the maintenance cost
potentially for paving the search of
roadway is 200 000. what i can know that
was brought up in testimony in committee
was that the d.o.t in 2017 bonded this
stretcher road for seven hundred
the member from hinsdale representative
abbott is recognized to speak
[Music]
thank you mr speaker
it's been asserted that this incident
was with continental boulevard was an
attempt to downshift
to the
merrimack community
the expense of this
area
this if it was i would be voting
for it
i'm not voting for it
i think that
first of all
the average cost according to the dot
for this roadway
that they plow and pave is eighty
initially merrimack
wanted to have continental boulevard it
is not a state highway
it is a municipal road
and
they wanted it because they wanted to
develop it they wanted to bring digital
in they wanted to bring other industries
into merrimack
in exchange for that
on the turnpike system
exit 10 11 and 12
in merrimack
were
created
eventually this became a problem for the
citizens of merrimack
they didn't want to pay the tolls
so it was eliminated
the toll booth at exit 12
and then with the exit 11 there was a
bill
presented to our committee
to have
the
tolls eliminated at exit 11.
that did not happen by vote of 18 to 2
it was defeated
and then
it went
what they did is they went to the
executive council
who sets the tolls
and got them to set the toll at exit 11
at zero
which eliminated
that from the scheme
and now they've passed uh
a bill to get rid of the tolls at exit
10.
so in other words they're getting no
total money
and what you have to understand
that all the toll money from the
turnpikes
has to be spent on the turnpike
and at the time when it first happened
the salt sheds in the storage areas
where the trucks
the state trucks were a long continental
boulevard
that has since gone away
so
what the expenses are now
with the elimination of the tolls at
exit 10
and 11 and 12
is 1.7 million dollars annually again
1.7
million dollars annually
the cost to remove the toll plazas
the other point is
that when the money that is collected
from the tolls
what it has to be used for and again
only on the turnpike
is for winter maintenance first that's
the priority
second is preservation
and the third is any new projects
so what this is mean
that all these projects
are going to be delayed
a lot of them are going to be delayed
because the money the revenue was not
there
i think that it would make more sense
for
and i question the fact whether it's
going to cost merrick mack the sum that
they said i will tell you
that it was
repaved
in 2017. and it's an average of five
years for it to go
and the cost to remove
the total booth
at exit 10
which is in the 10-year plan
is eight hundred thousand dollars
the member from merrimack representative
wrong is recognized to speak in support
of the amendment
thank you mr speaker
i come before you in support of this
minority amendment
it removes from the 10-year
transportation plan as we amended it the
transfer of continental boulevard a
state road to the town of merrimack
the reasoning for making this transfer
is that since merrimack no longer has
the three ramp tolls which supported the
everett turnpike we should take on the
more than two hundred thousand dollars
expense of maintaining this road
annually it is outrageous and illogical
as well as unjust
here is why
first off let me tell you about
continental boulevard
it is a connector planned and built by
the state to join 101a with the everett
turnpikes exit 10 and 11.
both state roads
it is considered part of the turnpike
system
this is not a road for townspeople to
navigate merrimack
there are no homes on continental
boulevard
it is primarily used to get travelers
from one state road to another
it exists for the benefit of state
transportation
to think that a town should take over
responsibility for this road is
ridiculous
second to justify that this transfer
to justify this transfer because of the
closure of the merrimack ramp tools is
also ridiculous
for decades decades
merrimack residents paid for the cost
for the turnpike every time a merrimack
resident got on or off to go to work or
to go home
while tens of thousands of drivers south
of merrimack paid nothing
tolls are user fees
not
just some others who get shouldered with
the burden
we have a toll booth
at the northern boundary of the turnpike
in hooksett
but the state failed to put one in at
the southern boundary
even though that road the tunnel and
other infrastructure is already in place
for a toll booth in nashua
so the heaviest eight miles of the
turnpike from the state line through
nashua
have not paid
one penny for that use
nor for the new ramps
and bridge work nada zilch zero
i would go as far to say that if the
state kept to their plan to have a toll
in nashua the turnpike system would be
flush with money
and we wouldn't be having this
discussion today
the last point i want to make is this
plan
is to dump the cost of continental
boulevard on merrimack
comes without any discussion with our
town leaders or dpw department
it takes what should be a state
supported cost
and turns it into a property tax
increase for the residents of merrimack
so for all the people of my community
who don't even travel to on continental
boulevard will have their property taxes
increased
so the state can make up
its turnpike revenue losses
that is not a user fee that is not a
toll it is an injustice of government
don't allow it to happen
please vote green in support of this
amendment
enough is enough thank you
does the member yield for a question no
the member does not yield
the member from bedford representative
graham is recognized to speak against
thank you
mr speaker mr speaker i rise in
opposition to the minority amendment
let me tell you what it does first i
don't think anybody hit that
it modifies the majority amendment by
taking out one section
it takes out the the very first section
that says transfer of ownership of
continental boulevard it re leaves the
rest of the majority amendment in place
i just want everybody to make sure they
understand that
when they're voting
a little bit of background
you've heard it here i'll recap the
exits in merrimack were constructed
by the turnpike some at the requests of
the town for development especially for
digital corp now fidelity
the town acknowledged that they would be
told
but it led to the development of large
sections of merrimack
and it allowed both business and
industrial development
over the past several terms these sole
plazas have been removed
and bills that i deem must pass let me
give you a couple examples in 2020 a
democratic senator inserted the removal
of one of the toll plazas and one of
those infamous
omnibus bills that the speaker and
senate president agreed would not have a
committee a conference
last year 2021 a republican center added
the removal of a toll plaza in the house
bill 2
while it was in the senate
so the last vestiges of the grand
agreement
that opened up merrimack for development
is the turnpike's ownership of a portion
of continental boulevard it's a fine
time to finish the breakup of this
bargain
by transferring the road to the town
you've heard different costs
i'll accept what my good colleague from
merrimack said that it's two hundred
thousand dollars maintenance in 2.5 in
the in the longer term
if that is the cost of the town that is
the cost of the turnpike system
and so everybody who goes through
another toll plaza will be paying that
amount for the next however long we
maintain control of continental
boulevard that's not cost downshifting
per se to me that is cost shifting to
every other person who uses the turnpike
system
um
you've heard the talks about what it
will cost to finish up the removal of
the toll plazas but the other thing that
has happened within the turnpike system
is that because
of this
expenditures and others we've had to
delay in this 10-year plan all of the
major turnpike projects by at least two
years
we can continue to do that
that's up to this body to
decide for me it is an equity
issue should those drivers on the
spalding or the rest of the effort pay
for what is now in my opinion
essentially a town thoroughfare
the majority of the committee does not
think so and ask that you vote down this
amendment
and i'm sure it's not going to be a
voice vote by pressing the red button
thank you very much mr speaker
does the member yield for a question no
division
representative boyd requests a division
vote this will be a division vote
this
the house will come to order
the question is whether to adopt
amendment zero eight five nine h this is
a division vote
representative mooney is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you
mr speaker
if i know that we just adopted an
amendment to carefully detail the
10-year transportation plan
and if i know that there is one section
one
in this plan that downshifts a
six-figure
annual road maintenance cost directly to
merrimack
and if i further know that this one
section of the plan
received no public input from town
officials or town public works from
merrimack
despite it causing a sizable
unanticipated
unexpected
town expense
then
would i remove this one section
by adopting this minority amendment
and now press the green
button
representative graham is recognized for
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that this should have come as no
surprise to the town of merrimack this
one's piece of the majority amendment it
has been in prior
10-year plans
and if i know that if we keep the cost
of continental boulevard accepting the
town of merrimack's cost that everybody
else who uses the turnpike system will
be paying for those 2.5 million 2.5
miles of road that are within the town
of merrimack
and if i know that the committee did
have work sessions
and there are
members of the merrimack delegation on
our committee
would i now
vote no
by pressing the red button thank you mr
speaker
the question is whether to adopt
amendment eight five nine h this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
so
[Music]
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote
148 in the affirmative 181 and the
negative the amendment fails
we are back to the original motion of
ought to pass with the
majority amendment representative graham
is good
the question is on the majority
committee report about to pass with
amendment are you ready for the question
what
all right are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
for what reason does it memorize
for a motion mr speaker state your
motion
i uh move that hb 1097 be special order
all right representative osborne moves
that house bill 1097 be special ordered
to the next order of business and is
recognized to speak to his motion
thank you mr speaker so i i have to feel
really badly for our colleagues over in
ways and means
mostly because of my friend from salem
who i have to listen to
every time we meet about it
all their bills are at the end of the
day after everyone's tired and no one
wants to pay attention and so forth
but more importantly i have a chairman
who needs to leave
early and we're not going to get to his
bills before he has to leave so
we really need to hear from him
on this bill so if you could please vote
the question is whether special order
house bill 1097 to the next order of
business are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it
and
1097 a special order to the next order
the majority of the committee on ways
and means to which was referred house
bill 1097 an act relative to taxation of
income of new hampshire residents when
working remotely for an out-of-state
employer
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with amendment representative
walters pillsbury for the majority of
the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study representative mary
hacking phillips for the minority of the
committee
majority amendment is
1037h printed in house record 10a on
page 13.
the question is on the amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
all those opposed nay
okay the eyes have it and the amendment
now on the recommendation of octopass
with amendment the member from hanover
representative hopkins phillips is
recognized to speak against the
thank you mr
speaker mr speaker i rise in opposition
to hb 1097 as amended
i agree with my distinguished colleagues
on the ways and means committee
that the matter of remote employment and
multi-state income taxation is worthy of
protecting new hampshire residents in
fact i love the idea behind the bill
it's a marvelous talking point for our
campaigns after all who here among us
does not want to support new hampshire
workers
but
we must be sure that this legislation
actually protects new hampshire workers
and this cautious committee has
uncharacteristically rushed to legislate
in an area where fiscal prudence
patience and study should drive our
policy making mr speaker i oppose this
bill for two primary reasons first i
oppose the bill because it fails to
properly consider the legal complexities
involved in crafting a litigation
strategy
the majority lists several guesses why
the previous litigation of this very
matter
was unsuccessful before the united
states supreme court
then selectively focuses the language
here on a limited issue rather
developing rather than developing a
broad litigation approach
after the amended language was offered
the committee did not gather substantive
testimony from constitutional
interpretation or legal experts
policy experts or independent tax
experts
the committee did not study the most
likely reasons for the previous denial
by the u.s supreme court nor did they
identify the most likely pathway forward
for future success
instead the committee heard an assertion
that the attorney general's office
approved of the language offered
and that a promise
that the amended bill encompassed the
strongest legal position for the state
to protect its citizens
no representative from the attorney
general's office was made available to
comment on that proposed language
no additional hearings were held to
verify those assertions to ask questions
or to confirm the soundness of that
legal strategy
no new facts were presented to suggest
that the timing of this legislation is
urgent right now
so
what does the state gain by rushing this
legislation through and the consequences
of being improperly prepared for future
litigation
is a huge
greater risk make no mistake this bill
could leave new hampshire in a worse
position to defend its remote workers in
the future
and we should acknowledge that new
hampshire taxpayers will be responsible
for the tens if not thousands or
hundreds of thousands
of dollars to litigate
a sub-optimal position
the minority urges cautions and caution
in proceeding without further
investigation into the legal
complexities here
and second i oppose this bill
for its technical deficiencies and with
a little bit of irish luck you'll just
hear me for one more moment
the majority revised the mandatory
language of the original bill
and replaced it with a permissive
enforcement of the state's sovereign
power
see this is problematic because the
language change may undermine the
state's right to bring a lawsuit there
is if there's no mandate for new
hampshire to defend its student
sovereignty
we never heard from the attorney
general's office as to why the suggested
language change to permissive was so
important so we're left with answered
unanswered questions
uh you know does this undermine
the position that we're intending to to
so second the bill also creates this
problematic double taxation standard in
one paragraph it stands for the
principle that no other state may tax
new hampshire citizens who work remotely
in our state
but then in another paragraph reaffirms
new hampshire's right to tax another
state's citizens located outside of new
hampshire through our business profits
and enterprises taxes
the logical incongruency here of the
double tax
double standard and taxation cannot be
ignored
and we also have to remember the state's
shift to single sales factor taxation
and determining those big
business taxes
you've got to wonder is this bill
intention unintentionally harming our
position by setting up our state to lose
significant portion of its revenue
stream
this body has a responsibility
to be prudent
to be patient
and to properly study the issue before
us
there are simply too many unanswered
questions too many unknowns and too many
risks to support this legislation as
written for these reasons i urge my
colleagues to vote no on the motion for
ought to pass with amendment on hb 1097
so that another motion may be put forth
thank you mr speaker and happy st
the member from charlestown
representative spillsberry is recognized
to speak in favor of the committee
report
i make my maiden voyage to the well
to urge your support of hb 1097
which has the
bipartisan support of a 17-6 majority
i think everybody is generally familiar
with the background so i won't labor it
but we know that during the pandemic
massachusetts asserted a taxation power
we didn't expect
claiming that
new hampshire residents
while staying home and working
exclusively in new hampshire
would be subjected to massachusetts
personal income tax and withholding
i venture we all had a visceral reaction
that that was
illegitimate
our governor objected
massachusetts
did not yield
and the result was our attorney general
took a case to the united states supreme
court
invoking original jurisdiction
in which the court can take a case to
resolve a conflict between two states
but the supreme court declined to take
the case
there are theories that it's mandatory
but when the supreme court chooses not
to take a case it's under no obligation
to explain why
so once left to wonder why
and new hampshire is left to wonder
exactly how will we repel
such an intrusion
on our sovereign interests if it arises
in the future
the pandemic came unexpectedly
the reactions to the pandemic including
this massachusetts taxation act
were sudden
and unanticipated
there is a possibility whether it's a
pandemic
or shifting
commuter
and work patterns
or high gas prices
helping to persuade employers to allow
their workers to work from home
there is a distinct possibility that
this could arise at any time and
unfortunately
without having been repelled
is all too likely to be revoked to be
invoked again
from any one of our neighbors who all
have
income taxes
and a vested interest in collecting as
much as they can
so hb 1097 is originally introduced
essentially asserted that massachusetts
or any other state has no power
to tax in this way
but we don't have actually the ability
to tell another state what their power
is what we can do though
is we can
directly place into law
a clear statement of our taxation policy
and our sovereign interest
and thus arm the attorney general
in the case they have to litigate again
to establish the basis for standing
the likely
thinking of the supreme court was
it's the individual taxpayer who's
aggrieved and that taxpayer would have
to file a lawsuit
imagine
you're just a guy trying to bring home
his income without massachusetts taking
a portion of it and you're going to have
to litigate to the united states supreme
court
so
in short
this amendment
was co-drafted with attorneys from the
dra
who attended four or five sessions of
the ways and means committee
and attorneys from the
attorney general's office
and when the draft was
completed
it was placed directly under the eyes of
attorney general formella
who affirmed that he wants this in law
so what the minority has basically told
you
is that tax laws complex
they think there might be a way to
further perfect and
develop a silver bullet
but they have yet to tell us what
changes they would make
so my suggestion
is that we
embrace hb 1097
with the blessing of the attorney
general
and if any of us comes up with an even
better idea later
i am sure the ways and means committee
will gladly look at it
thank you
does the member yield for a question
the questions on the majority committee
report of ought to pass with amendment
this will be a division vote members
oh
representative you know keller requests
a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded
it is sufficiently seconded now this
so
i also come to order
this is a roll call vote
you ultimately have control over how
long this vote takes
this is a roll call vote representative
ames is recognized for parliamentary
inquiry
if i know that personal income
earned by new hampshire residents
working entirely within new hampshire
should be protected from unfair personal
income taxation
by other states
but
if i believe that the proposal contained
in hb 1097
that is intended to protect new
hampshire workers from such interstate
taxation
fails
to adequately address the complexities
of interstate commerce
and tax law
and related constitutional limitations
and therefore is not ready for prime
time
nor is there any reason for immediate
action
would i now vote against the otp a
motion
representative major is recognized for
parliamentary
thank you mr speaker
if i know this bill addresses the issue
of personal income of new hampshire
resident that is earned entirely within
the state of new hampshire
and another state
is subjecting it to their income tax and
withholding
and if i know that the committee
believes that this bill addresses a very
important issue
that was offensive to new hampshire
independent sovereignty
and that this issue must be addressed
permanently
lest it
arise again without recourse
and if i know the committee concluded
that the bill needed to be reframed
so in connection with the attorney
general
and the department of revenue
administration
the committee's amendment seeks to
re-aim the bill
towards firmly and unequivocally
establishing an explicit claim of policy
and sovereign interests
that will put other states on notice
and clearly lay the foundation
for successful litigation if it should
ever become necessary
then would you join me in the bipartisan
vote of the committee and press the
the questions on the majority committee
report about to pass with amendment this
is a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the red button if you're
opposed you'll press the green if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
that's why we ask voting stations are
[Music]
so
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote
i realize it's anticlimactic at this
point but 251 having voted in the
affirmative 72 and the negative the
committee report is adopted
representatives page and ward declared a
conflict and did not participate in the
vote
for what reason does a member rise
mr speaker i would like to make a motion
please state your motion
i would like to move that
tuesday's debate on house bill 1266 of
the criminal justice committee
be placed in the permanent journal
1066 twelve six six
six
yes
representative panolakis would like the
debate from house bill 1266 printed in
the permanent journal without objection
i know i'm a daily nadal shot here but
thank you mr speaker
i would like to make a motion
please state your motion
yet tuesday's debate on house bill 1476
be placed in the permanent journal from
representative moves that the debate
from house bill 1476 be placed in the
permanent journal without objection
this place getting busy for what reason
does a member rise
for a motion mr speaker
state your motion
move that uh house bill 1221 fn be
special order to the next order of
business and i will be happy to speak to
representative osborne moves at house
bill 1221 be special order to the next
order of business and is recognized to
speak to his motion
thank you mr speaker
for the same reasons as before
if you all vote yes then the chairman of
ways and means will owe you a favor and
if there's anyone you want to owe you a
favor as the chairman of ways and means
the question is on the special order of
house bill
one two two one
then the next order of business
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
majority committee on ways and means to
which was referred house bill one two
two one fn
act relative to the rates of the
business profits tax in the business
enterprise tax considered the same
report the same the following amendment
recommendation of the bill ought to pass
with amendment
president of john genetian for the
minority of the committee have been
considered the same in being unable to
agree with the majority report
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient legislate
represented richard ames for the
okay
the amendment is 0471
roll call has been requested is that
it is sufficiently seconded so be a roll
so
mr speaker
so sylvia is going to do the pi against
it
members take your seats it's a roll call
vote
the motion before us is the adoption of
this is a roll-call vote chair
recognizer representative sylvia for
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that house bill 1221
in its original form
provides tax relief for both
the business enterprise tax
and the business profits tax
but that the committee amendment
would only reduce the business profits
tax
and mr speaker
if i also know
that the business profits tax is mostly
paid by larger companies
while smaller businesses
are much more likely to pay just the
business enterprise tax
and mr speaker
if i further know
that the small businesses were much more
likely to be negatively impacted during
the pandemic
and they are
they are at least as deserving if not
more deserving as larger businesses to
re
receive
tax relief
mr speaker if i know
that the new hampshire new hampshire has
had several other rounds of business
relief
in the past seven years
and despite assertions that these cuts
would undermine our business tax and
revenues
our business taxes for this fiscal year
are currently more than 88 percent
higher than they were
the final year at the highest rates
finally mr speaker
if i know that this fiscal year alone
through just eight months
our business taxes
are already more than 91 million dollars
ahead of plan and overall revenues are
more than 191 million dollars over plan
so we can clearly afford to give relief
for
and b-p-t
then
would i now press
the red button
so that we can provide tax relief to all
businesses this this is a parliamentary
inquiry
then would i press the red button
so that we can provide
tax relief to all businesses so that we
can continue to grow the new hampshire
advantage and our economy thank you mr
speaker
recognized representative major for
thank you mr speaker
if i know
that
this bill originally
was to reduce the business profits tax
and the business enterprise tax
and it would reduce income by a total of
36 million dollars
also if i know
that we have
instituted
through hospital 2 last year and others
a reduction in the business and
enterprise tax business profits tax
mills and rooms tax
and they're going to glide down to zero
on the interest and dividend tax
and we also raise the threshold for
filing the business enterprise tax
raised the threshold for filing the
business tax
and if i know
that yes our
business taxes are high
there's two major reasons for that if i
know
they're high because
we didn't change the
tax laws for ppp loans
and therefore
the businesses had to pay taxes on those
and that's going to be about 100 million
dollars is going to have to be refunded
and if i also know
that there's been a
number of stimuluses over the last
couple of years
[Music]
everybody gets checks for fourteen
hundred dollars we get checks
for
our employment and all kinds of checks
now
that raises our profits and you we're
seeing that now those are one-time
things
if the member will suspend
this is a parliamentary inquiry
okay if i know that that raises our
profits and this is a one-time event
and that this amendment
reduces
changes the
bill from just a tax
on
business profits tax and business
enterprise tax to just business profits
tax which will be eight million dollars
and if i know
that
due to 100 million dollars of refunds
and not receiving stimulus tax in the
future years
that this bill is
very reasonable
then would you
i'm sorry yes on the amendment
sorry
is the amendment to house bill one two
two one
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
so
if all members president had the
opportunity to vote house will attend
227 voting a 99 voting nay the amendment
is adopted
we'll now move on
to the majority report of what to pass
as amendment the chair recognized
for what reason is a member rise
mr speaker i have a question and i'm not
sure
how to word it so i think it's a
question
to the speaker
state your question
at the beginning of the discussion
something was said
that would indicate
that the chair of ways and means
would be more likely
to
give members a favor
if
if if
we voted with him there is no one in
this body
who is more honorable than the chair of
wasteland if you were recognized for a
question
and my question is how do we
once once again representative i'm going
the motion before us now is the majority
report of autopass as amended the chair
recognizes representative ames to speak
so i rise to speak against the pending
otpa motion
on hb 1221.
the amended version of hp 1221
reduces the business profits tax from a
rate of
67.6 percent
of net taxable
business profits to a rate of 7.5
percent
that is all it does
it makes no change in the business
enterprise tax
this this single decimal
bpt tax rate reduction
is expected per
department of revenue administration
estimates
to lower the state's total business tax
revenues by about 2 million dollars in
fiscal year 2023
and then the annual loss is expected to
build up
to about 8.5 million dollars per year
starting in fiscal year 2024
and this hb 2021
revenue loss
will be additional
to a probable 100 million dollars in
revenue losses attributable to prior
year cuts in the bbt
tax rate
the business profits tax is paid mostly
by big business as you have heard
of the 77
businesses that filed business property
tax returns
for fiscal year 2019
just
or about one percent of all filers
paid close to 80
of the 515 million dollars in business
property tax revenue received that year
80 of these high-end filers
had taxable profits above 1 million
dollars per year
these high-end filers
mostly if not exclusively out-of-state
international
corporations
will be the primary beneficiaries of hb
1221's single point
single decimal point tax rate reduction
the average tax break for each of the
top 20 would be about
seven 36
dollars
based on fiscal year 2019 data
in contrast
about
400 businesses
or 76 percent of all businesses filing
ppt tax returns in 2019
would get no benefit from the new
hp 1221 tax break
since their net profit after all credits
will remain too low to be taxable
in the middle of the 2019 business
profit taxpayer range
about 7 800 taxpayers
those with net business property tax
paid in fiscal year 2019
of between a thousand dollars and ten
thousand dollars
will receive on average just a forty
nine dollar tax break
from the hp 2021
single decimal point rate reduction
trust
excuse me
testimony on the bill
included no persuasive evidence
demonstrating that a single decimal
point rate reduction would have any
noticeable impact on business decisions
to move to
or depart from
new hampshire
state revenues have been high this year
most likely because new hampshire has
benefited from a huge temporary infusion
of kovid related federal funds
and from soaring worldwide
corporate profits realized by our large
largest business profit taxpayers
but even so the state's revenues have
proved insufficient to meet local school
and essential human service funding
needs
property tax rates
have been forced up this year in many
property poor jurisdictions
where state aid
has failed to keep up with essential
needs
in jaffrey
where i live
state school aid is substantially down
from fiscal year 2021 levels
and and
the school tax rate is expected to rise
this year
by about three dollars per thousand of
assessed property valuation
translating to a three hundred dollar
property tax increase
for each one thousand one hundred
thousand dollars of business property
valuation
this property tax increase will for most
business property taxpayers in jaffrey
dwarf
any tax break received because of hp
and even with that three dollar per
thousand school tax rate increase
the public school system serving jeffrey
is being forced to reduce its staff
by about seven full-time teachers
testimony on this bill and at the ways
and means economic forum on march 4
provided no evidence-based support for
the bill's proposed rate reduction but
made clear instead
that equitable relief from high property
tax rates
is urgently needed to enhance the
profitability of many struggling new
hampshire businesses
as well as the quality and sufficiency
of local public schools
working housing and infrastructure on
which these businesses depend
since 2014
rapid national and global growth
and more recently enormous federal
stimulus funding for state businesses
and consumers alike
have masked the state's revenue losses
due to tax cuts given mostly to our
largest businesses over the last six
years
as the stimulus
fades
and as new recession threatens our
revenue situation could become dire
the hp 21 2021
single
decimal point business property tax rate
cut
is mindless and senseless i hope that
you will agree and join me in voting
against the pending otpa
motion so that another motion can be
a roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded representative
it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
will take your seats where you're on the
the chair recognizes representative
genetian
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker as several speakers before me
have now
announced the original hb 1221 proposed
to cut the business enterprise tax and
the business profits tax we all know
that now it's been said more than once
the amendment that we just voted on and
approved is only going to lower the
business profits tax so the
so any revenue hit to the state
is very minimal it's it's estimated to
be eight million dollars but the thing
that we have seen is every time we have
cut taxes
we've seen an increase in tax revenue
so who knows the 8 million may it may
actually be zero
the um
many taxes were lowered in previous
years
and so one of the that was one of the
reasons
as representative major mentioned that
we focus just on the bpt right now is
because we want things to settle down we
want to see how the ppp
loans and the coveted relief funds
affect the tax in the end
now some will say and some have already
said
that big business is going to profit
from this i i disagree with that basic
assertion there are a lot of small
businesses that are paying the business
profits tax and not paying the business
enterprise tax
both those thresholds were increased the
business profits tax threshold and the
business enterprise tax threshold have
both both been raised and that's helping
small business
and i i beg to differ even a 0.1 percent
decrease helps business
furthermore
when we think about those who are
thinking about coming to new hampshire
and bringing their business to new
hampshire
and those who are in new hampshire that
want to we want them to stay here every
now we
compare very favorably to the other
states massachusetts is at eight percent
so they'd compare with our 7.5 vermont
is at 8.5 percent as soon as you net
more than 25 thousand dollars
i'm going to venture to say there's a
lot of businesses that make more than 25
000.
so
in the end
this tax reduction will be good for new
hampshire businesses
good for this state
please vote yes and push the green
button it will send the message once
again
that the freest
and safest state in new hampshire
is open for business
the motion before us is the majority
report of auto passes amended on house
bill one two two one this is a roll call
vote
recognizes representative almi for a
thank you mr speaker
if i know
as the chair
as our chair said
earlier
that there have been major changes to
our tax rates law and structure in
recent years
not just in this term
as well as unforeseeable blows
and
one-time federal supports to our economy
and if i know
that
property taxes
which businesses as well as residents
have to pay
rise even faster when the state deficits
cause shortfalls in municipal or school
and if i know that our committee finds
it exceedingly difficult to forecast
whether we will find ourselves next year
maybe even the end of this year
or in
several years to come in deficit or in
surplus
and finally if i believe that it is
foolhardy to make this further totally
symbolic
0.1 percent cut to our revenues
until things stabilize
shouldn't i push the red button
thank you
jay i recognize representative major for
thank you mr speaker
if i know this bill originally proposed
lowering the business profits tax and
the business enterprise tax
resulting in about 36 million dollars in
reduction in revenues
and if i know the bill was amended to
only lower
the business profits tax from six seven
point six percent to seven point five
percent
which will lower the business taxes
approximately eight million dollars
and if i know this reduction in the beep
business profits tax rate will be good
for both the small and the large
businesses
and therefore resulting in the most
important thing is keeping our economy
growing then would you join with me and
the majority of the committee and push
the green button thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of ought to pass as
amended on house bill one two two one
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
so
[Music]
mr speaker
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
177 voting 141 voting a committee report
is adopted for what reason does a member
rise i asked that the remarks of the
previous debate be placed in the
the motion is to place
the remarks of the previous debate in a
permanent journal without objection
we got three quick ones and then it
looks like we're going to break for
dinner
if members
member house will be in order if members
will stay in their seats
we got three that are just going to be
pis and division votes
majority of the committee on resources
recreation development to which was
referred house bill 1071
act relative to wake surfing
having considered the same report the
same
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate
of greg huff for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the
bill ought to pass representative susan
gotling for the minority of the
committee
this is a division vote members take
house will be in order
the motion before us is the majority
port of inexpedient to legislate on
house bill 1071 this is the division
vote chair recognizes representative
thank you mr speaker and thank you
members of the house for your patient
attention
if i know that hb 1071 asks boaters to
maintain a 250 clearance from shore
docks and other vessels vessels only
when wake surfing
in order to moderate the effects of
their powerful waves and wakes
on other boats boaters bathers and the
shoreline
and if i know the captain of marine
patrol
stated this 100 foot increase is
unlikely to preclude wake surfing on any
water body in new hampshire
and the department of environmental
services agreed
250 feet is a distance that will protect
the environment
while allowing a very popular sport to
continue
and if i know that lake and river
associations
advocate 300 and to 500 feet clearance
then would i agree
that hb 1071 is a modest proposal that
hits the sweet spot
250 feet
between what the wake surfing community
wants
education enforcement and no change
and what the concerned public wants the
opportunity for everyone to enjoy their
lake experiences now and into the future
and if i know all this
i would push the red button to overturn
the itl and allow another motion to be
made
chair recognized representation for
thank you mr speaker
if i know that new hampshire boating
laws and coast guard regulations
currently require boaters to be
responsible for their own wake
and violators can face enforcement and
fines
and if i know that new hampshire lakes
and ponds are held in public trust for
all to enjoy and hb 1071 would hurt
access for those who enjoy wake surfing
as the committee heard from over 1100
people who oppose the bill
and if i know mr speaker that new
hampshire marine patrol and new
hampshire's boating industry
were working together to better educate
voters through the new hampshire wake
responsibly campaign thus making
restrictions
in hb 1071 unfair and unnecessary
would i now push the green button to
uphold the committee recommendation
and vote hb 1071 inexpedient to
legislate thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is the majority
report of inexpedient to legislator and
house bill 107.1 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
so
[Music]
representative
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will tend to stay to the
vote
171 voting 149 voting a committee report
majority of the committee on resource
recreation development to which was
referred house bill 1227
act relative to the definition of prime
wetland been considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolve that it is inexpedient to
legislate senator andrew missoula for
the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
report with a recommendation that the
bill ought to pass representative chuck
for what reason does the member rise
for a motion state your motion a motion
to table
it is a proper motion
the motion before us is the table house
bill one two two seven
and there is no vote no uh wave off
okay
the motion before us is the majority
committed report of inexplication to
legislate no the motion before us is a
tabling motion on house bill one two two
seven are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
guys have it and the bill house bill
all right
everyone stay in your seats we have a
division vote ahead of us and all we
have is parliamentary inquiries
majority of the committee on resources
recreation development to which was
referred house bill 1317
an act requiring the director of the
state police in consultation with the
bureau of marine patrol to report
annually to the legislature regarding
new developments in electric and
gasoline-powered recreational watercraft
having considered the same report the
same with a resolution that is
inexpedient to legislate is in a great
cuff for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee
have been considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass
senate of suzanne gottling for the
the motion before us is
the
majority report expedient to legislate
on health bill 1317
this is going to be a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
thank you again mr speaker and thank you
again colleagues for your continuing
patient attention
if i know that hb
1317 requires the department of safety
aka marine patrol
to give a yearly written update to the
appropriate house and senate
committees alerting members to
developments in gasoline or electric
power watercraft that may make changes
in voting
regulations or rules advisable
and if i know that recently innovative
vessels such as battery-powered efoils
and even jet-propelled surfboards
have emerged to challenge present
regulations and rules
and that the relentless ingenuity of new
hampshire men and william will continue
to challenge the aqua quo
and if i know
that although the captain of marine
patrol was most agreeable to this update
at a hearing
putting the agreement into the rsas is
advisable
since committee members committee chairs
and even captains change over the years
if i know all these things would i not
then push the red button to overturn the
out itl and allow another motion to be
made
chair recognize president huff for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that new hampshire state
police along with the new hampshire
marine patrol are exceedingly competent
organizations that diligently work to
keep our highways byways and waterways
safe
for all who use them
and if i know
that as an exceedingly competent
organization
they are well informed and knowledgeable
in all aspects of their duties including
knowledge of any new developments in
watercraft that may be headed to our
waterways
and if i
know that both the new hampshire marine
patrol and the new hampshire state
police are always available and more
than happy
to provide the legislature with any and
all information that would assist us in
understanding new innovation and how
they might impact new hampshire and
already do so voluntarily willingly
make this bill unnecessary
would i now push the green button and
uphold the committee report of any
expedia to legislate thank you mr
speaker the motion before us is the
majority report of inexpedient to
legislation house bill
1 three one seven this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed or press
the red button voting stations are open
representative
all members president an opportunity to
vote
201 voting yay 110 voting a the
tonight we have pizza for you
the pizza is made possible again
by the generosity of sponsors of the new
hampshire home builders association and
the kit the food will be served on the
kitchen side of the cafeteria area like
last night
and the basement level dining room and
members lounge in first floor are
available for seating
please be back in your seats no later
than seven
o'clock and again thank the new
hampshire home builders association and
legislative solutions for tonight's
dinner
majority committee on science technology
and nad to which was referred house bill
enact relative to renewable energy
customer generator accounts and credits
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate
janine nodder from the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass senate rebecca mcwilliams minority
for what reason does the member rise
mr speaker i make a motion to table
the motion before us is the table house
a division has been requested members
the motion before us is a tabling motion
in house bill 1116.
the chair recognizes
representative
he's first
thank you mr speaker mr speaker
if i know that the additional
administrative costs to implement this
bill
would increase electricity costs at a
time when we don't want to see
electricity costs go any go up any more
than they already have
and in addition mr speaker if i know
that very few people expressed an
interest in this bill during the public
hearing
would i now press the green button to
the chair recognizes representative
christian for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr chair
if i know that this bill will help
individuals and small businesses with
multiple electricity meters who generate
their own energy to budget and avoid
taking on unnecessary debt by allowing
them to apply the credit generated on
one meter to the bill on another meter
and if i know that utilities already
administer these credits manually once a
year meaning that this should not
require substantial additional costs or
complexity
and further if i know that allowing a
utility to hold and collect interest
from funds for a period of up to 11
months that have already been
earned by and properly
sorry
and should be paid to granite staters is
an illegal taking of funds that properly
belong to the customer generators would
i now press the red button so that
another motion can be made
the motion before us is the tabling
motion on house bill one one one six
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
right
all members president an opportunity to
168 voting and voting yay 127 voting a
majority committee on science technology
and energy to which was referred house
the noise is getting very loud again the
an act relative to prohibiting
government entities subordinate to the
state from restricting the types of fuel
sources that may be used for energy
considered the same report the same the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
representative fred plett for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution result that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
cat mcgee for the minority of the
committee
for what reason to memorize mr speaker
i'd like to make a motion
state your motion like the table
it is a proper motion
there is a motion the motion is a table
house bill one one four
eight
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
chair recognizes
thank you mr speaker
and thank you all for your patience and
indulgence these three days and and
happy saint patty's day
[Music]
hb 1148
if you if you heard the description
relative to prohibiting governmental
entities subordinate to the state blah
blah blah
what it really boils down to
is saying that
local towns and cities uh are unable to
determine whether there are certain fuel
types that will not be used within their
borders
so the minority finds this to be an
extremely disruptive bill to new
hampshire energy planning
hb 1148 not only removes local control
for energy planning from those who are
doing the work on town energy committees
to help lower costs
and emissions
it voids decisions already made
by towns
who have adopted plans to eliminate
fossil fuels from their municipal energy
portfolios because the bill is also
retroactive
this bill is an about face
in direction setting that walks back
support for local clean energy efforts
to implement a mandate that says new
hampshire counties and towns have no
authority to exclude an energy source
can only be seen as paving the way for
continued fossil fuel dependence
this is not the desire of many towns who
have already invested in moving forward
with clean energy targets and i know
because i live in one of those towns in
my town hollis over eight years ago we
did a benchmarking study of all our
municipal buildings and then we began
investing in converting maybe some of
you have had the same experience some of
your town buildings to pellet burners
we put solar panels on top of the
elementary schools and all of these have
resulted in hundreds of thousands a year
of dollars going down in our energy
costs so
we believe the minority believes
we should have the right to do that we
should have the right to lower our costs
and invest in which sources we want and
if we want to set a target saying we
will be fossil fuel free by 2050 which
many towns in new hampshire already have
we should be free to do that this bill
would prohibit that
so
this
this is very much an issue of granite
staters having greater control over
their energy bills which we talk often
is something we want
creating savings through local
generation hb 1148 disrupts orderly
planning for many municipalities and
defies our long-standing tradition for
local control please oppose the ought to
chair recognized representative platt
thank you mr speaker and i thank the
colleagues who came back
from dinner tonight and i know you did
it just to listen to my scintillating
speech
this bill
first of all has nothing to do with
heating systems it was a senate bill
last year which
stopped municipalities from prohibiting
any kind of heating system this is power
production or conversion and contrary to
the minority speaker it doesn't block a
municipality from investing their own
money and solar what it does do is keep
them from
prohibiting
generation of any sort or throwing
ordinances in the way of them changing
zoning
power production has to follow local
zoning unless accepted by the site
evaluation committee but
but the ordinance that the town or
municipality cannot change zoning to
throw roadblocks in the way of uh
production
so this is a state responsibility before
the site evaluation committee any kind
of
generation that's proposed
is an automatic opposition from a lot of
people no matter what it is it's not in
my backyard
uh or or it's uh
ideologically driven but it is an
automatic negative reaction some cases
is positive site evaluation committee
the municipality can go there and argue
for pro or con but it should be at the
site evaluation committee
the motion before us on house bill 1148
is a majority report about to pass
a division has been requested members
will take their seats this will be a
while we're waiting for everybody to
take a seat
i would remind members
that
parliamentary inquiries
are supposed to be short
and to the point
we actually we have a form up here
to tell everyone how to do a
parliamentary inquiry
they're getting way too long
and way too involved in what a
parliamentary inquiry is supposed to be
and i'm addressing it to both sides of
the question before us is a majority
report of ought to pass on house bill
1148 this is a division vote the chair
recognizes representative mcgee for a
thank you mr speaker
if i know that prohibiting cities and
towns from saying no to any type of fuel
means pulling the rug out from under
towns with climate action plans who are
doing great work to lower the costs of
their taxpayers and if i know
that this kind of reversal of
long-standing state policy creates
economic uncertainty
and hurts the clean energy sector just
as defunding new hampshire saves hurt
the weatherization sector these are new
hampshire jobs and finally if i know
that this type of mandate runs counter
to long-standing efforts to make new
hampshire's energy economy competitive
in the region and sends poor pricing
signals to new companies looking to do
business in the area
then would i now press the red button to
reject the ought to pass motion so that
another motion can be made thank you
chair i recognize representative thomas
thank you mr speaker
if i know
that
this is not a home rule state and that
municipalities should not
be restricting types of fuels to use to
their new residents and if i know that
is the job of the sec to decide matters
like this
would i now
press the green button to pass this bill
the motion before us is the majority
report of ought to pass in house bill
1148 this is division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you press
the red button voting stations are open
so
representative
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
167 voting 142 voting a to commit a
majority of the committee on science and
technology and energy to which was
referred house bill 1250
an act requiring the public utilities
commission to consider climate change
and making rate-setting decisions
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate president
j.d bernardi from the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study
representative lee oxenham for the
minority of the committee
for what reason is a member rise
to make a motion mr speaker stage in
motion
a motion table
that is a proper motion the motion
before us is the table house bill 1250.
i
division has been requested members will
[Music]
yes
the motion is to lay house bill 1250 on
the table
this is a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker the
bill requires the puc to consider
climate change in its rulings
if i if i know the puc
is
this if i know this bill requires a puc
to consider climate change climate
change in its rulings and if i know the
bill does not tell the puc how to
consider it
if i know that the bill does not tell a
pc why to consider it and if i know
that the bill does not require or tell
the puc what to consider
then would i press the green button to
table this bill
crx representative oxenham for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker colleagues
if i know that climate change could cut
usgnp by 10 percent over the coming
decades and do billions of dollars of
damage to new hampshire
and if i know that increasingly
prevalent extreme weather events pose
major threats to our clean water
agricultural production and human health
even our lifespans
and if i know that wildfires droughts
and extreme heat events pose looming
financial risks that could cause major
economic losses to residents and
businesses here in new hampshire
then would i not want the puc to take
into account climate-related risks in
its decision-making on utility
investment decisions
please push the red button so that we
can have this debate
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1250
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
168 voting 843 voting a
committee on science technology and
energy to which was referred house bill
1258 and act relative to the
implementation of the department of
energy
i'm still reading the bill
but we didn't take a vote on the bill
that was the tabling motion
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment senator michael
harrigan harry harrington for the senate
committee
amendment the amendment is zero eight
five one h printed in house record 10 a
pages 29 through 35. are you ready for
the question on the amendment all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
the motion before us now is the ought to
pass with amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
will suppose nay
eyes have it and the committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred house bill 1270 and that
dissolving the legislative oversight
committee to monitor the transformation
of delivery of electric services
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment incentive doug
minority of the committee have been
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator
jacqueline kelly pitts for the minority
chair recognizes representative callie
pitts mr speaker
for what reason did the member rise for
a motion
stage of motion
i moved we table uh hb 1270.
that is a proper motion the motion
before us is the table
house bill 1270
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
the amendment is zero eight eight o h
printed in house record 10 a pages 39
i've been informed that we already did
the amendment
so
we're back to the majority report of
autopass as amended
and i'm recognizing representative kelly
pitts
i was
the bill was not tabled not we're not
okay that's not what i had in front of
me but if we're just going to do a
division vote and pis that's fine that's
great
this will this will be a division vote
clearer
for what reason does a member rise
point of order
state your point of water uh mr
mr speaker as far as i know we never
voted on the amendment when we were
getting ready to vote on the amendment
the tabling motion was made the clerk
the clerk informed me we did vote on the
amendment
the record shows that we adopted the
so
the motion before us
is the majority report of ought to pass
as amended
on house bill 1270.
this is a division vote with pis only
chair recognizes representative kelly
mr speaker
house
may cooper may cooper i don't know
what's going on
um
[Music]
if i know this is a pi
if i believe that we are currently in an
energy crisis
and if i believe that we you the way we
use and obtain energy
is in transition and that transition is
not over
and the work of the oversight committee
is far from over
if i believe that
we need a comprehensive
study of all the reports that we get
and all the information that we get
and that we can't get that in committee
many times
i believe that we should continue with
this oversight committee which does not
hurt anything
and if i know that this committee has
not met
i believe that it was due to covet
so
my information was that the
committee had come out with an itl
but i believe that this is an odd to
pass
it harms no one and it helps everyone
chair recognizes representative votes
for a parliamentary inquiry in case
everybody just doesn't know please press
thank you mr speaker mr speaker
if i know that i served on the
restructuring oversight committee myself
a couple of terms ago
but if i also know that the
restructuring process has been completed
if i further know that a couple years
ago
[Music]
a new bill was passed to repurpose the
committee but its language was vague
and didn't really do the job of defining
what the new committee's role would be
as a result the committee hasn't met for
two or three years
if i knew all that mr speaker would i
to pass this bill ought to pass as
the clerk's office has reviewed the
video and
it is right
that the
so
this is
we have not
so
we're going to take up the amendment
the amendment is 080h
printed in house record 10a pages 39
through 40.
the question is on the amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
would uh representative callie pitts
so we're going to do this once again
on the majority report of ought to pass
as amended on house bill 1270.
if you're in favor you will press the
green button if you're opposed you will
press the red button voting stations are
oh
[Music]
president had an opportunity to vote
173 voting a 138 voting nay and for the
second time tonight
majority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred house bill 1328 fn
an act authorizing a utility to position
to be relieved of their carrier of last
resort obligations considered the same
report the same in the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass senator
michael harrington
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study senator lee oxenham
for the minority of the committee
for what reason does a member rise
for a motion mr speaker stage a motion
uh i move that we lay this bill on the
table
the motion is to lay house bill 1328 on
the table and i asked for a division
vote
so
house will be in order
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1328
the chair recognizes representative
oxenham for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker colleagues
if i know
that despite new communication
technologies and increased competition
carrier of last resort requirements
still meet a vital need here in new
hampshire
and if i know
that this requirement means that
incumbent telecommunications service
providers
must ensure the continuing availability
of life-saving communication services to
all
their customers not just 95 percent or
97 of them
and if i recognize that many areas of
our state still do not have either
reliable broadband service or cell phone
service
then would i not put the cart before the
horse by removing this vital safeguard
until we have other sufficient
technologies in place
please push the red button so another
i recognize representative votes for
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that
the few small regional telephone
companies that still exist in new
hampshire
would experience financial relief from
the passage of this bill to relieve them
of that
carrier of last resort obligation
but if i further know that the public
utilities can commission continues to
collect an obsolete assessment
based on that carrier of last resort
obligation
which rate payers continue to pay
would i vote no on the tabling motion by
pressing the red button so that we can
listen to the debate on this bill and
pass this really good bill thank you mr
speaker
the motion before us is delay 1328 on
the table
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you press the red button
while members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend to the
142 voting yay 168 voting nay
we're now back to the original
motion of the majority report ought to
pass
division has been requested members will
okay
the motion before us is the majority
report about a pass in house bill 1328
we're going right to parliamentary
inquiries this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative oxingham
i know everyone wants to go home thank
you mr speaker so i'll be brief
we have a vital need for carrier of last
resort
excuse me
if i know
that we still have a vital need
for the protections that are offered by
carrier of last resort would i vote
against the ought to pass by pushing the
red button
thank you
chair recognize the representative
thank you mr speaker
if i know it's time to read new
hampshire of an obsolete and costly
public utilities commission
assessment
and 38 other states have done likewise
for the past six years with no problems
and if i know that having rate payers
pay for a service no longer needed is
just wrong would i now press the green
the motion before us is the majority
report of ought to pass on house bill
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you press the green button if
you're opposed you press the red button
[Music]
all members president an opportunity to
173 voting a 138 voting a committee
majority of the committee on science
acknowledge innate which was referred
house bill 1459 fn act relative to
recycling solar panels considered the
same report the same with the following
amendment a recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with the amendment senator
fred plett for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolve that it's
inexpedient to legislate
representative roderick pimentel for the
minority of the committee
for what reason does a member rise
to make a motion mr speaker stage
emotion
i move to
place this bill on the table
the most
the motion is to lay
1459 on the table and i ask for a
division vote
you seats claim something's dilatory if
um
uh
so
chair recognize representative pimentel
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that we need to do
a better job of recycling all products
and if i know that this bill targets
only the solar industry
in new hampshire
in at its infancy
would i press the green button to table
chair recognizes representative votes
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that we have a tendency to kick the
can down the road
and it's time to stop doing that
solar panels may last for
15 or 20 years but they're eventually
going to fail and have to be recycled
if i know that if we start a stewardship
plan now the money will be in place when
the time comes to recycle those solar
panels
knowing that would i press the
red button
not to table this bill
thank
you motion before us is a table house
bill 1459
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed to press
the red button voting stations are open
[Music]
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend this
141 voting 867 voting a the motion to
the question before us now is amendment
printed in house record 10a pages 62-64.
are you ready for the question on the
amendment
all those in favor say
as aye nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
the question before us right now
is on the majority report of what to
a division has been requested
[Music]
there's no debate just parliamentary
inquiries
the chair recognizes
representative partial for a
you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know this restrictive bill that's
trying to kick a can that may possibly
exist 25 years down the road
and i recently and the recently passed
house bill
1149 provides a far superior and less
biased means of examining extended
producer responsibility
and further
if i know that the unexamined economic
consequences
of this
anti-business and anti-environmental
legislation will impede new hampshire
energy independence at a time when grid
stability should be our top priority
would i not now
press the red button
so that another motion may be brought
forward that removes the legislative
thumb
from the new hampshire homegrown
renewable energy and mr speaker i
request a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
plett for parliamentary inquiry thank
you mr speaker
if i know
that
this is a growing problem the solar
panels in in new hampshire there's 153
megawatts installed already and by 2025
there'll be 389 megawatts and if i know
every time i mention megawatts people
fall asleep
but so i'll turn it into other terms
megawatts rounding up to 400 that's 2
000 2 million panels and if i know that
that's 400 acres of panels
and if i know that other production
going to site evaluation committee has a
re has a plan at end of life but most
solar does not go to the recycle
site evaluation committee and if i know
that small electronics can handle by a
dpw for nominal fees but for the solar
panels it can run to thousands of
dollars then when i pass this important
bill i i also know that califor that
it's modeled after washington bill
law rather to work representatives
parliamentary inquiry yes if i know that
that has been done in
in
in washington and several other states
are considering it
then which would i press green to pass
the motion before us is the majority
report of autopass as amended on house
bill 1459 this is a division vote
if your house will be in order
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you press
the red button voting stations are open
while memphis president had an
opportunity to vote the house will
167 voting a 145 voting a committee
majority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred house bill 1596 fn act relative
to net energy metering limits for
individual and business customers
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate senator j.d
bernardi from the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass presenter rebecca mcwilliams from
the minority of the committee
i chair recognizes representative
wait
what reason does a memorize
mr speaker i make a motion to lay this
the motion before us is the lay house
bill 1596 on the table a division has
this will be a division vote
motion before us
is to lay house bill 1596 on the table
this will be a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that our current
fall policy to camp net energy metering
at one megawatt for new hampshire
individuals and businesses not only has
the effect
of depressing the competitive energy
market but also unfairly penalizes the
nascent green power jobs market in new
hampshire and further
if i know my constituents are acutely
aware of our desperate need for the
removal of arbitrary caps that impede
new hampshire's energy independence and
like them
i'm reminded this the fact every with
every electric bill i open
and every gas pump i visit
would i not now push the red button so
that another motion may be brought
forward that once again would remove our
legislative thumb from new hampshire's
homegrown renewable energy thank you
when i believe the division was called
thank you
jerick and isis
representative votes for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that house bill 1596
is substantively the same bill
that our governor vetoed three times
over the course of the last two years
the motion before us is to lay
house bill 1596 on the table this is a
division vote if you're opposed you'll
press if you're in favor you'll press
the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
so
representative
while members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
167 voting a 140 voting a committee of
the late house bill for
the committee on science technology and
entity to which was referred help house
will be in order
to which was referred 1599 fn enact
relative to customer generators who sell
renewable energy certificates having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendations the bill ought to
pass senator fred platt for the
committee
a division has been recalled has been
the motion before us is the committee
report of ought to pass
on house bill 1599
this is going to be a division vote
chair recognizes representative pimentel
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know that hb 1599 only looks at one
side of the ledger and if i know that
the puc will be completing a four year
study that addresses both sides of the
ledger
then would i let the puc
do their job before the legislature
arbitrarily changes the formula and
press the green button
chair recognizes representative votes
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that this bill
fixes a mistake that was made back in
2017 by the public public utilities
commission
when they determined what the tariff
would be
for
default service with regard to net
metering this created something called
the
missing money problem
the missing money problem essentially
allows
customer generators people who generate
electricity and put it back onto the
grid to avoid paying
the rps charges that they are
responsible for
and that requires representatives i know
that that requires the public the
utilities to recover those costs
from
ratepayers
and if i further know house will be in
and i believe i corrected my mistake
and if i further know
that this bill fixes the missing money
problem and prevents cost shifting to
other rate payers would i now press the
green button
the motion before us is ought to pass on
house bill 1599
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you oppose you press the red button
so
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote the house will
163 voting yay 137 voting nay
the committee report is adopted
committee on science technology and
energy to which was referred house bills
act relative to rules of the site
evaluation committee having considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution result that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
the motion before us is the
committee reporter been expedient to
legislate are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
your eyes have it and the committee
committee on science technology and
energy to which was referred house bill
1628 fn enact directing the department
of energy to generate a report on the
microgrid project currently in progress
the university of new hampshire in
collaboration with the regional
utilities considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate
representative tom project for the
committee
for what reason does the member rise
mr speaker
i make a motion that we lay this bill
that is a proper motion
division has been requested members take
the motion is to lay house bill 1628 on
the table
chair recognizes of representative votes
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that the department of energy
testified before our committee
that the micro grid project involving
eversource and the university of new
hampshire had been terminated
would i now press the green button to
chair recognizes representative samsuch
for a parliamentary inquiry
if i know that this project with the unh
and the utilities is in fact on hold
right now because of several problems
but i also know that microgrids have a
great potential in the future for
community power and for rural
communities to unite to create energy
networks and i'd like to see more
information and furthermore i know also
now that there are several businesses in
this state that are doing that so i i
was requesting the department energy to
put together a report of what we know
right now about microwaves so we can go
ahead and and and so i ask you to vote
against the tabling motion
the motion before us is lighthouse bill
1628 on the table
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed to press the red button
so
representative toole
representatives
while members president had an
opportunity to vote household in the
208 voting yay 99 voting nay house bill
majority of the committee on science
acknowledge energy to which was referred
house bill 1629 fn
an act relative to default service for
net metering having considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass senator
michael harrington for the majority of
the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator cat
the motion before us is the majority
report of ought to pass
division has been requested members take
so
the motion before us is the ought to
pass motion on house bill 1629
this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative mcgee
for a parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker
colleagues
if i know that this bill seeks to adjust
net metering rates by removing all
current charges ex that make up the rate
except for the energy itself
basically this bill says the wholesale
rate of energy is what we should use for
net metering credit
but if i further know that this is not a
legitimate method of evaluating the
value of net metered energy
and that a long pending public utilities
commission's study on this very topic is
due out any day to let us know what that
rate should be
and finally if i know that it is
fiscally irresponsible to knowingly
create an adverse effect on existing
renewable energy facilities and slow
planned adoption of new projects by
throwing this kind of wrench into the
mix when there is no evidence that this
arbitrary calculation is the right price
point for a complex market
then what i now press the green the red
button to stop this bad bill becoming
law thank you
geo recognize representative harrington
for parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker mr speaker if i know that the
rate being paid to uh net metering
involves lots of costs that they don't
see such as risk premiums and on the go
i could list a whole mess of them
there's a lot of them it raises your
electric rates but you know what nothing
more i say is going to change a single
vote so just please press the green
button
the motion before us is the
majority report of auto pass on house
bill 1629
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you press the red button
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
163 voting a 140 voting a committee
committee on science technology and
energy to which was referred house bill
1635 fn
act relative to the purchase of output
of limited electrical energy producers
including qualifying storage system
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill be referred for interim study
senator nick white for the committee
the motion before us is
the motion of re referred for interim
study are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
you guys have it and the committee
majority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
an act requiring notification to
renewable energy customer generators of
issues related to renewable energy
credits considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to the
legislate representative lex
presidency to
brzezinski
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation of bill auto pass
president of lee oxenham for the
the motion before us is the majority
report of inexpediting to legislate on
house bill 1645
this is going to be a division vote
members take your seats this is just
going to be a division vote
the motion before us is the majority
report of index being to legislator on
house bill 1645.
this is a division vote the chair
recognizes representative oxenham for
thank you mr speaker colleagues
with your indulgence i know we're all
tired
one minute and we can be done with the
bills for ste
please
if i know
that there have been bills aimed at
eliminating rex sweeping for years and
in the last session we passed the bill
the other body passed the bill
but the governor vetoed it
thereby violating the new hampshire
constitution's guarantees of property
rights protection due process and equal
protection under the law
and if i know that via rex sweeping the
state of new hampshire is seizing the
property rights of new hampshire
citizens and businesses
without their knowledge
and without any compensation
and if i know that this practice has
transferred millions of dollars from new
hampshire residents and businesses to
private corporations
with roughly half yes going to the
utilities and
pennies on your rate going down but with
the other half
going to out-of-state private
corporations like constellation energy
and direct energy
thereby placing the state of new
hampshire in legal jeopardy
and lastly if i know that this bill
simply
informs those customer generators who
are being harmed and have been harmed by
this practice
of the fact of the taking and the means
they can take to protect their property
from further seizure
would i now push the red button
chair recognizes representative thomas
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that the state
created these wrecks
and the state can also take them away
but if i also know that these wrecks
these unclaimed wrecks are used by the
electric utilities to reduce your
electric bill
and if i know that if we stop letting
them use these unclaimed rates it will
be raising your electric bill and if i
believe that's wrong let's press
the
red button on the green button and get
the motion before us is the majority
report of an expedient to legislate this
is a division vote you're in favor
you'll press the green button of your
poster press the red button voting
so
law members president had an opportunity
to vote house will tend to stay to the
vote
165 voting a 139 voting a committee
for what reason does a member rise um i
will call it a parliamentary inquiry
state your inquiry if i think that all
of my colleagues would acknowledge
that the clerk staff is probably getting
as tired and bleary-eyed as we all are
and i think that they would like to join
me
in saying how much we appreciate them
getting the record correct
a few minutes ago before we proceeded
wouldn't they all join me now in
thanking them for sticking with us at
[Applause]
house will be in order
majority committee on state federal
relations and veterans affairs to which
was referred house bill 1284
an act establishing a committee to study
the effects of deportation of primary
earners on family members who are united
states citizens consider the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to legislate
senator albel disarro from the majority
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following amendment and the
recommendation that bill ought to pass
with amendment
representative amanda elizabeth toll for
the minority of the committee
for what reason is a member rise uh to
make a motion mr speaker stage motion
i'd like to make a motion to table this
bill
the motion before us is the table
house bill 1284 it is a proper motion
a division has been requested members
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
so
the motion before us is to table house
bill 1284.
this is going to be a division vote the
chair recognizes representative bell
disarro for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i've
known i've seen this bill about three
four times
and and if i also believe and many of us
here all of us here have taken the oath
of the constitution knowing that the
federal government take is deals with
immigration so mr speaker if i believe
that there's no way that we'd be able to
get the information requested in this
bill due to privacy and we do not have
subpoena then would i press that
green button thank
you
chair recognizes representative toll for
thank you mr speaker
if i know that deportation has
devastating economic and humanitarian
impacts
if i know
that it is clear that we have much
anecdotal evidence about the impacts of
deportation of primary earners but no
statewide data collection
if i know that we have data elements in
very local places like school districts
municipal welfare offices and state and
human services offices but these haven't
been woven together into a state
narrative
if i know we need this study to collect
reputable data on a statewide level to
inform public policy that leads to the
best economic and humanitary outcomes
for new hampshire residents would i go
ahead and vote no on the motion to table
the motion before us is to table house
bill 1284 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button of your polls you'll press the
red button
so
representative iv
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
172 voting yeah 135 voting a
the tabling motion passes for house bill
majority of committee on state and
federal relations and veterans affairs
to which was referred to hcr7
and act reaffirming support for the
nation of israel and the location of the
embassy of the united states therein
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation of bill out
of pass
representative michael moffat for the
minority of the committee
have been considered
considered the same in being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution result that is
inexpedient to legislate senator israel
p d
representative le branch offers floor
amendment 1078
l
the chair recognizes representative
lebranch
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
honorable colleagues
i rise today to offer an amendment
located in your seat pockets if you'd
like to read along
to house concurrent resolution 7
reaffirming our support for the nation
of israel and the location of the
embassy therein
what my amendment seeks to do is make
this resolution less controversial by
removing the section relating to the
moving of the embassy to jerusalem and
by adding a section about supporting the
israel israeli-palestinian peace process
the moving of the embassy to jerusalem
was a very controversial one
as jerusalem is claimed by both israel
and palestine
the united states should not be picking
aside in this decades-long conflict and
should serve instead
as a neutral arbiter
the united states cannot be considered a
neutral arbiter if it is picking a side
on who owns jerusalem
secondly it adds after the section about
reaffirming our support for israel and i
quote
that the new hampshire general court
recognizes the right of the palestinian
people to exist and that the new
hampshire general court supports the
israeli-palestinian
peace process
now i believe that every member in this
house can agree that we support peace in
the middle east and for a peaceful
resolution to this conflict
this is why i asked for a roll call so
that we can see who stands for peace and
who does not
i believe that if this amendment were to
pass that we would pass this underlying
resolution unanimously
that is why i ask for your support on
this important amendment and to please
some of the branches requests that are
all calls that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote we're on our final
speaker members take your seats
thank you mr speaker
one of my arab american
friends and colleagues representative
abbas was waiting to to call for
a roll call vote anyhow
this amendment and the underlying
resolution
is both
substantive
and highly symbolic
if you read the underlying resolution
crcr7
it's merely a
clear restatement
of american foreign policy
american foreign policy that has existed
now
for decades essentially since shortly
after the founding of the state of
the move to the embassy
was voted by the congress of the united
states
many years ago
under several administrations and
finally was implemented under the trump
administration
before the embassy and before israel
took back control of jerusalem
in the 67 war when it was under the
control of jordan
the three religions that called
jerusalem a holy site
were not all allowed
access
if you look at this amendment
it basically guts the underlying
resolution completely
for a peace process to work
the parties involved in the conflict
all the parties involved in the conflict
must want peace
that is not the case with the so-called
palestinian people
they
their principal spokesman
are from a designated terrorist
organization called hamas
hamas has in its charter
its goal of the destruction of the state
of israel
fails to recognize the right of the
state of israel to exist
controls the gaza strip
from which it builds underground tunnels
to infiltrate terrorists into the state
of israel
rains rockets down
the member will suspend stage
appointment
stage a point of order i believe uh the
member uh unfairly generalized a whole
group of people
into a one terrorist organization
and i don't think that's fair there's
mr chairman it's a matter of fact that
the hamas is the principal spokesman of
the
hamas hamas's
hamas
hamas statement
which has been repeated
which has been repeated publicly
in the last couple of months by a member
of this very house
from the river
to the sea palestine will be free
and that means that they want to push
all the jews out of israel into the
mediterranean kill the jews that's what
they want so that's what this amendment
will stand for
so i urge you
for what reason does a member rise i'd
like to make a motion mr speaker
state your motion
i would like to move to table this bill
i think it's all gotten out of water
it's not debatable excuse me i apologize
the motion before us is the table
hcr7
a division has been requested members
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
seconded
oh
the chair recognizes the representative
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know
that
for reasons that are far larger than
this room
that the conflict between
israel and palestine
that has gone on for nearly a century
now
is so
not going to be solved
by the new hampshire house at 9 00 pm at
night
would i then
agree with the wise decision from my
colleague from newbury to table this hcr
i recognize representative baldassaro
for parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker fellow representatives under
rule 30 my committee is
required this is a parliamentary inquiry
let me try this listen to the word i use
fellow representatives if you know that
my committee is required
mr speaker i've got people shaking their
head here and if you read here if i know
i'm going to try it again thank you
the house will be in order
mr speaker
let me make it simple so if you know out
there
that my committee
understands we are required to rule 30
which is we have to listen to
resolutions
and if i know
that i give the respect to every state
representative that comes in with a
resolution for the last 16 years are the
two times i've been the chair in that
committee
to give you and listen and vote properly
as a committee and mr speaker if my
committee and i know
that this should have never gone to that
resolute that amendment in the speech
that we had and if i know here i try to
stop that amendment earlier working with
my ranking member and if you know the
whole story of what's going on here this
is a resolution about a building being
moved
nothing about palestine or jurism and if
you know all that will you support me in
[Music]
the motion before us is the table cacr7
hcr7
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're impulse you'll
press the red button voting stations are
representative
so
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
road
yays
155 knees the tabling motion fails
let me quickly explain what's going to
happen here
we're going to go right into
we've already had the debate on the
amendment so we're going to go right
into the vote presidential branch has
requested a roll call is that
it is sufficiently seconded this is
going to be a roll call vote with just
yes
oh
the motion before us is a blanche floor
amendment
this is a roll call vote the chair
recognizes the representative of a
is this a roll call on the bill itself
for the amendment roll call on the
amendment
mr speaker
if i stand for peace and if i know that
not
[Music]
mr speaker if i stand for peace and if i
know
not all
palestinians are part of hamas and if i
know
that this if this amendment passes we
will pass this resolution unanimously
jay reckon has ripped in a belt of hour
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that this amendment's not going to
go anywhere and it wasted a little bit
of time god bless them mr speaker and if
you know as i do that
let's just vote this thing down and move
on thank you
the motion before us is a branch floor
amendment this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote the house will
voting a 185 vote in may
the amendment motion fails
now we're on to
roll call has already been requested is
that sufficiently seconded seeing that
somebody made the call
it is sufficiently seconded everybody
[Music]
go ahead
for what reason does a member rise to
make a motion mr speaker stage emotion
mr speaker i'm
deeply hurt by what's happened and i
would like to make a motion to
definitely postpone this
bill the house will be in order
it is a higher motion so the motion
before us is in to definitely postpone
hcr 7.
are you ready for the question
roll call has been requested
that is sufficiently seconded
blue
so
the
house will be in order
the motion before us is into
indefinitely postpone hcr seven
this is a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
mr speaker
if i know that this resolution makes us
pick a side in a decades-long conflict
and if i know many organizations such as
the new hampshire chapter of jewish
voice for peace oppose this resolution
would i now press the green button to
the motion before us is
of hcr 7.
no it's
the motion before us is into
indefinitely postpone hcr seven
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
so
[Music]
well
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
144 voting a 160 vote in a motion to
now we're back to the original motion of
members will stay in your seats
we had a request for roll call that was
sufficiently seconded so members will be
in your seats we'll have the debate and
then we'll go right in to the vote the
mr speaker
i rise in opposition to ought to pass on
house concurrent resolution 7.
i oppose this legislation because of its
controversial and confrontational nature
i do not believe it is the place of the
united states let alone the state of new
hampshire to pick a side in the
decades-long israeli-palestinian
conflict
now i do support the nation of israel
but i also believe in the right of the
palestinian people to exist and have
their own nation state
i believe in peace and diplomacy and i
believe those are the efforts we need to
support
[Music]
as written this legislation would have
us supporting israel and moving the
mr speaker was uh thank you for
recognizing me was this to be a pi or
another no this is this is a this is not
a pi this is a thank you i apologize
yeah
as written this legislation would have
us supporting israel and the moving of
the capital with no nuance regarding the
decades-long conflict
israel has long illegally occupied
palestinian land and has been labeled as
an apartheid state by amnesty
international
and human rights watch for its treatment
of the palestinian people
the new hampshire coalition
the jewish voice for peace has come out
against this legislation
when we have these resolutions
we must look deeper into the matter and
the nuances involved
words have meaning
that is why i ask you all to oppose the
otp motion and press the red button so
that another motion can be made thank
you
members will be in their seats this is
this is the last speaker coming up
roll calls already been
declared
and voted on
this is the last speaker and then we're
going to go into two p to the p i's and
vote
first of all i'd like to say that this
hcr-7
has absolutely nothing to do with the
palestinian issue
hcr 7
offers a concurrent resolution
reaffirming the general court's support
for the nation of israel
and the location of the embassy of the
united states therein
as a co-sponsor of this bill
i believe this is an extremely important
statement for our new hampshire house to
make
and especially to communicate to our
federal delegation
at this time
first
the support of israel is something we
should declare
israel is our ally
and the only free and democratic country
in the middle east
second
the movement of the u.s embassy from tel
aviv to jerusalem
was an affirmation
that the holy city is indeed the
political seat
secular heart
and religious soul
of the country of israel
jerusalem has been fought over for
millennia by its inhabitants and by
regional powers and invaders
it is sacred to judaism christianity and
islam
and each religion has sites of great
significance there
which israel recognizes and protects
fiercely
israel's government regards jerusalem as
the eternal and indivisible capital of
the country and the united states
recognized that important historical
political and religious claim
and so do 32 other countries in the
world
i believe that we must as a legislative
body make a bold statement in support
and solidarity of the jewish people and
their homeland israel
as well as the decision by our
government
to move the u s embassy to the rightful
capital city of israel
jerusalem
watching the hostage situation unfold at
congregation beth israel
in coleyville texas this past january
of the unfortunate rise in anti-semitism
throughout our country and the world
it reminds us
all
that we must take a stand against
anti-semitism and the discrimination
and discrimination of all kinds indeed
we have even had a bipartisan statement
broadcast taking a stance against
anti-semitism on december 2nd 2021 by
our speaker
and the house and minority leadership
and by
representative renny cushing may god
rest his soul
so this bill seems a natural follow-up
my family
has
my husband has family that live in
israel
and members of his family immigrated to
before it became a state
when it was the only place jews could go
to escape persecution
both of us personally have many family
members who perished in hitler's
concentration camps
i have an aunt a great aunt who still is
alive
who has the numbers tattooed on her arm
and she goes and she speaks
to high school students across the
country even at the age of 96
to tell them
about her story of survival in
concentration camps
and to preach that we should all
get be together and
we as descendants are considered
survivors
thank god that our relatives survived
those awful times
and were either able to come to america
or go to israel
but still my husband and i have seen the
ugly realities of anti-semitism
we grew up with it
and unfortunately it still lingers even
since hitler's defeat
we've heard the ugly words of people
we've seen the graffiti saw stickers
on synagogues and jewish schools
and have heard the cries
of anti-semites who want to push the
house of israel into the sea
[Music]
and so
i would like to see our new hampshire
house
take a leading role into affirming the
support of the jewish state of israel
and the jewish people
as one way to combat anti-semitism
and i ask you
to please vote yes
by pressing the green button
in support of the committee's otp
recommendation
and i also would like to
wish you all
a very happy forum
which we just ended celebrating
it's a feast of lots
a time
when the jewish people commemorate
their deliverance
from an evil persian
advisor named haman
who wanted to kill all the jews
and thankfully
queen esther
was able to stop this horrific decree
so please
support this
support
hcr and please
reaffirm
our support of israel and the jewish
the motion before us
is the ought to pass motion on hcr 7.
this is a roll call vote members take
the motion before us is the ought to
pass motion on hcr 7.
this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative lebranch for
mr speaker
if i know that this resolution
makes us pick a side in a decades-long
conflict as jerusalem is claimed by both
israel and palestine
and if i know
and if i know many organizations such as
jewish voice for peace oppose this
resolution
and if i know supporting israel and
opposing anti-semitism are two different
things and i would co-sponsor a
resolution condemning anti-semitism
would i now press the red button so
another motion can be made
chair recognizes representative bell
desiral for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
believe that i really want to apologize
on behalf of my committee that we never
expected this to go on mr speaker and if
i know
that if i killed it in committee
either way there was going to be a fight
or i passed it
therefore mr speaker
i
now would love to see everyone just post
push the green button let's move on
thank you
the motion before us is the auto pass
motion on hcr 7. this is a roll call
vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your poser press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
for all members president an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
175 voting yeah 107 voting a committee
report is
for what reason does the member rise mr
speaker mr speaker i ask that the
remarks for the octopass be placed in
i recognize the clerk mr speaker
representatives osborne and walner move
that all necessary house rules be so far
suspended as to allow action on all the
remaining bills referenced in today's
house calendar by the date of march 31st
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
[Music]
the house will be in order with a couple
the chair recognizes representative
osborne for the third reading motion
resolved that the house now adjourned
from the earlier session that the
business of the late session be in order
at the present time that the reading of
bills be by title only in resolutions by
caption only and that all the bills
ordered to third reading be read a third
time at this resolution and that all
titles of bills be the same as adopted
and that they be passed at the present
time and when the house adjourns today
it be to meet on thursday march 31st
2022 at 9 00 a.m
the question is on the third reading
motion are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
we have a couple of announcements
i have one here
as you all know we lost our valued
colleague minority leader
robert rennie cushing just last week on
march 7.
memorial services have been planned for
the family and friends the river mill
dover landing located at two washington
street in dover
the services will be held from three to
six pm on saturday march 19th
attendees will be required to wear masks
please join me in keeping leader
cushing's family and friends and your
chair recognizes the clerk mr speaker
members of the house there is leftover
pizza available to go in the anteroom
please help yourself on your way out in
representative osborne moves the house
stand and recess for the purpose of
introduction of bills enrolled bills
amendments enroll build reports from
receiving messages are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it the
until
march 31st march
you